The infamous Jamie double finger gun and
we're live.
How are you sir?
Good.
Seeing that it's coming back.
Looking healthy.
Looking fresh.
When I stopped eating meat since I last
saw I heard about that.
I want to talk to you about that.
And uh,
I don't know that
correlating with health.
I,
every time I worry about this out loud,
I get hate mail from vegans and
vegetarians.
You say stop,
you start putting your bullshit on us.
Well you,
they,
they don't like when you associate any
negative consequences whatsoever with
only in vegetables because it's because
it's essentially a cult.
It's a wonderful cult of people that
want to take care of animals,
be nice to animals,
but they're very tribal,
very tribal,
very cult like.
And if you say anything that's negative
against Vegans,
they gang up.
I go to forums and I read the things
they say they organize like little troll
attacks and they make youtube videos.
It's kind of hilarious,
like from a psychological standpoint.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
obviously I don't want it to become a
new religion or my,
my one religion,
but there is a moral high ground to the
position that I find very attractive
because I felt like a hypocrite as a
mediator now.
Um,
and I don't think there's necessarily
extends to someone like you who hunts
and feels okay about hunting.
Um,
and I don't have an argument against
hunting the way I do against factory
farming or,
or more,
more or less any of the way we get meat.
Um,
you know,
the,
the environmental implications of it,
but it's um,
so it is very captivating as a position
and you feel like an ass and when,
once you,
once you go far enough into the inquiry,
you feel like an asshole not being
sensitive to these concerns and just,
I'm ignoring how you're getting your
food three times a day.
But,
um,
I'm not yet for me.
I maybe,
I'm sure there's individual variation
and I'm not the smartest vegetarian in
the world in terms of how I prepare my
food and how attentive I am to it.
So the onus is somewhat on me,
but I,
I'm,
uh,
I'm not totally sure it's uh,
the healthiest thing for me so I,
you know,
so you say this started,
you said you look healthy.
Mbi,
I feel like my health is somewhat with
reign under this has been about nine
months.
Weathering,
um,
are you getting your blood checked?
Are You doing year 12 supplementation?
Yeah,
that's essential oils.
Essential [inaudible] is essential as
well.
Most people are just not going to get
enough from the sun.
And are you monitoring your intake of
fatty acids and things along those
lines?
Not really beyond the supplementation.
I'm,
I'm just,
uh,
trying to get the food in.
Yeah.
Well it's good.
It's all good stuff,
but it's really important,
like one of the things that people rage
against,
unfortunately,
it's the stigma and it's fats,
it's dietary cholesterol,
dietary cholesterol and saturated fats
which are critical for hormone.
And it's one
of the reasons why people when they get
an all vegetable diet,
if you're not really careful with
coconut oil,
you got to eat a lot of coconut oil.
I'm a big fan of Avocados.
I eat a lot of Avocados,
a lot of avocado oil,
coconut oil as well though.
Almond butter,
nuts,
things on those lines like you,
you really need to get those essential
fats.
Well actually I'm not Vegan so I would
like to be Vegan,
but.
But I'm still eating dairy.
And did you say you would like to be?
No one's holding you.
No one's holding you down to Goddammit
Sam,
you need to have some milk?
No,
no.
I think just.
I think I would screw it up again.
I'm going to reap the whirlwind when
from the Vegans,
but I should've brought you some eggs,
but I eat eggs.
I eat eggs and a,
but as you know,
you can only eat so many eggs and,
and so much dairy,
but I eat a lot of eggs.
The eggs are very good for you too.
Here's the,
there's another thing,
dietary cholesterol,
like people are always concerned with
dietary cholesterol.
Well,
that was a big myth for the longest
time.
As a matter of fact,
dietary cholesterol barely moves the
needle and blood lipids,
a lot of them people have cholesterol
issues.
It's sedentary lifestyle.
There's genetics,
there's all sorts of other variables,
but people with healthy lifestyles,
it doesn't seem to be that dietary
cholesterol is bad for you.
And also it's essential for testosterone
production.
Yeah.
So I get a ton of,
or not a ton,
but I'm not trying to avoid saturated
fat.
So I,
um,
I get a fair amount of.
You have a yard?
Uh,
yeah.
Could you raise some chickens?
No,
no,
not after this.
I'll take you to my house.
So I'll show you the chicken setup we
have.
We just got five new ones.
We have an 18 now.
One of them died.
They just fucking die sometimes.
You don't know why.
Just go in the chicken coop.
One's dead father time got in there with
his side and they're getting kind of old
now.
Some of them,
I don't know how old the chicken lasts
honestly,
but they're like pets.
They give you food,
like there's no negativity.
I opened the door,
they come up to me,
the run around.
I feed feel like there's no,
they're not trapped.
As a matter of fact,
they go into their pen at night,
like you leave it open and they wander
around my.
I have a big yard.
They wander in my yard,
they eat a bunch of bugs and stuff and
then they go back inside when they want
to.
So there's no like animal captivities,
no cruelty.
There's nothing weird going on.
And so those eggs,
they're pretty much Karma free.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No,
I don't doubt that.
It's just when you read the details of
how our dairy and I mean it's near
arguably as bad if not worse than much
of the meat production.
So you know,
moving from eating,
eating me to being a vegetarian in some
ways is a symbolic move ethically if
you,
if you really wanted to,
to not participate in the machinery,
but there's an issue with me that's for
vegetarianism.
There is an issue with the how they
gather food.
I mean there's,
there's a giant issue that people don't
want to take into consideration is like
how are they growing all this food?
How they growing all these plants.
Well,
one of the things they're doing is
they're displacing wildlife that chewing
up this ground in these combines,
if you eat grain and particular combines
indiscriminately,
just chew up all that stuff and they get
deer,
Fonz,
mice,
rabbits,
rats,
rodents,
untold amount of bugs if you want to get
really deep.
I mean there's no like being a Vegan and
being a vegetarian is most certainly
less cruel and less harmful overall,
but it's not Karma free.
It can't,
unless you're growing your own stuff.
If you can grow all your own vegetables
and you essentially live on a small
farm,
yeah,
you could.
You could do it and really feel good,
but it's.
If you're buying it in the store,
you're participating in factory farming.
Whether you like it or not,
you're just participating it vegetable
farming,
but it's.
There's still issues.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just,
just viewer.
I had this guy on my podcast boom.
Have a lady who's running this company
called Memphis meats,
which is cultured meat is a startup in
silicon.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
and then try that.
I haven't tried it.
No,
I want to try it,
but it was a fascinating conversation
because he basically,
what's,
what's fascinating to me on two levels
is one is just,
it's fascinating that we're on the cusp
of being able to produce actual
biologically identical meat.
That is,
that is totally cruelty.
I mean,
it's,
there's no,
there's no implication of cruelty at all
in it.
Right.
And you would just grow,
grow this in a Vat,
the way you brew beer essentially.
And uh,
so that's,
you know,
that seems like the future.
But what's interesting psychologically
is that people have this,
this creepy feeling around it,
which is very strange because it,
so you,
I'm telling you,
I can take the misery and death out of
the process,
right?
I can take the suffering animal out of
it.
I can take the chaos of the
slaughterhouse out of it.
There's no,
you know,
a cow that has been mistreated for its
whole life,
stumbling in blood and feces on the way
to the,
you know,
the killing floor.
Um,
and somehow removing all of that makes
it creepy or people,
right?
They want,
they want,
they want that.
I mean,
that's the natural way to get me,
and if I told you this is grown in a vat
by a guy in a white lab coat and has no
xeno viruses and no bacteria,
nothing,
you know,
antibiotics were used to pump this thing
up and it's just the cells you want
people start to just kind of an eerie
feeling that,
that,
that I think we're going to get over.
But it's interesting psychologically
that it's there in the first place.
Did you get that feeling or you just
know the people know?
I hope they understand it.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm past it,
but I understand it.
Who Do you know that got it,
that just,
I just see the reaction that,
you know,
when I actually pulled this on twitter,
I'm at 20 percent of pay,
like 15,000
people answered the poll.
So it was like,
it was a,
it's not a scientifically valid poll of
the general population.
It's just whoever got it on my,
on my feet.
But um,
it was interesting to see.
I,
I asked,
you know,
of the people who wouldn't switch,
I asked would you switch?
And something like 80 percent said they
would switch if this was affordable and
available and safe.
Um,
but of the people who wouldn't switch,
it was 25 percent wouldn't switch
because it's just creepy and 25 percent
assume that it was um,
a not healthy.
I think I forgot the,
the for the breakdown.
Um,
another 25 percent was we're already
vegan or vegetarian and didn't want to
eat meat,
but there was an ick factor for at least
25 percent of the people who wouldn't do
it.
I understand it.
I wonder how many people would go back
to eating meat if they could raise it
this way.
Like how many people who had gone vegan
would go back to eating this
scientifically created lab created beef?
I think enough for a series market.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
there'd be a serious market for it for
sure.
If they could get the cost effective.
Because last time I saw it was like
quarter million bucks for a
cheeseburger.
I think it's down.
I think it's $18,000
from me for.
I mean,
it'll eventually be like,
you know,
the Apollo computers now fit in your
pocket much stronger in fact,
than the Apollo computers.
Well,
the sequencing,
the genome,
this,
this I just noticed,
which is fascinating.
Um,
sequencing the genome 15 years ago,
cost $3,000,000,000.
It's now 3000,
so it's a million fold reduction in cost
in 15 years.
That's insane.
So something like that,
things tend to scale that way.
So yeah,
that's a giant scale though when you
talk about human history,
that's awesome.
Good Lord.
Imagine if you're a guy who spent 3
billion of it 15 years ago and you're
like,
God,
if I just fucking wait here would to
saved so much money.
And that's mean.
We don't anticipate that.
When we think of how difficult it is to
solve certain problems,
we don't.
And this is ray Kurzweil's point of
records while who I think is,
is a bit of a cult leader.
And um,
I'm a carnival barker on many topics.
This,
this point,
he makes it again and again I think is
quite valid,
which is when you're factoring how
difficult it will be to get into the end
zone,
whatever that ends on is you're not
tending to factor all of the
improvements and the compounding
improvements in technology along the
way.
So I would love to get back to Ray
Kurzweil,
but I wanted to bring up this point
about did you.
One of the things about going Vegan,
especially when you proclaim and you go
public with going Vegan,
if you back out of that,
that's where,
that's where I am as a vegetarian.
They get fucking mad.
They get mad.
Did you see that family?
A couple that runs a bunch of Vegan
restaurants.
Um,
and they decided to start eating meat
again.
Even though they,
a Vegan restaurants,
they decided to start.
They have their own farm,
they raise their own cattle and they
started eating their own cattle.
It was real weird too because they
brought,
there was a lot of Jesus in their
message,
right?
There was a lot of,
like Jesus said,
we're supposed to take care of the
biblical quotes.
You know,
like really obscure biblical quotes
about food,
like,
oh,
okay,
like what are you doing here?
But they have a.
Here it is.
Vegans were bold against owners of
famous La Vegan restaurants after meat
eating outed.
Well,
I think,
I don't think you could say the outage
because I'm pretty sure they put it on
their facebook page.
Like the guy was like first cheeseburger
and 15 years.
Is this,
this is cafe gratitude.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
So,
well the other thing that's hilarious
about that restaurant,
which I like it.
The food is good,
but have you been there?
No.
So everyone,
now forgive me if this is no longer
true,
but at one point every employee there
did the,
um,
the landmark forum that the successor to
asked.
Oh,
that's right.
They get sued for that.
Who gets this?
This,
this,
this restaurant is one of the reasons
why they closed one of the restaurants.
Can you explain that though?
Because.
Okay,
so landmarks.
So,
um,
which I've never done this.
So again,
I'm speaking outside the,
the cult walls.
But um,
so runner earhart was a,
a sixties.
Um,
you know,
human potential figure who started
asked,
I'm never met him,
um,
but,
uh,
you know,
obviously impressive enough as a person
to get a lot of people to spend a lot of
time doing whatever he said.
And he had this,
he had this,
um,
a growth,
a course called asked,
which has been,
I mean,
you've seen it in many movies,
no name comes to mind now,
but some version of this where you can
keep everyone in the room and the people
have to ask permission to go to the
bathroom and there's kind of like a
pressure cooker situation socially where
you have everyone sort of torn down.
I'm actually the classic case of this,
I think this,
this wasn't ss was the forum which is
now the successor to.
So they were at one point hired to do
coaching,
uh,
of,
you know,
various companies.
And I think they're hired by the FAA.
I wrote about this in one of my books in
a footnote.
It was the FAA FAA hired the forum to
coach their,
their,
um,
uh,
administrators.
And one of the exercises they a force
these guys to do is,
they almost certainly were mostly guys,
um,
they chained the boss to his secretary
and had for like the whole day and they
had to go to the bathroom together and
like sort of,
you know,
ego annihilating experience.
Anyway,
this is,
this is the recipe that,
that,
um,
one of the recipes that asked is
pioneered.
This is not to say that people don't go
to the forum and get a lot out of it.
I,
I've actually met those people.
But
the,
um,
every employee of this restaurant
apparently has gone or used to go do the
forum.
Um,
so it's a very,
you walk into the restaurant and your
interaction with,
with people in the restaurant is,
is unlike most restaurants,
people are just very,
you know,
lots of eye contact and,
and it's just,
it's an intense,
it's intense restaurant.
And also the stuff on the menu,
um,
this was just so lacerating I could
never comply.
But the,
um,
the name of everything on the menu is
like,
I am humble,
I am magical alliance.
So you have to,
you're,
you're meant to order it that way.
Like I am humble.
Oh God,
I'll have an I am humble and they're
given to you.
It's your humble.
So that's that.
That becomes a little of.
That goes a long way.
Well,
they're retarded.
That's what's going on.
And if you go to is good though.
I,
I don't,
uh,
don't get me the wrong way.
The food is good,
but it makes sense then that they would
go all Jesus,
he religiousy when they were trying to
justify their meat consumption.
Jamie,
see soon as you pull up the quotes for
them,
a justifying their meat consumption
because it was real weird.
I was like,
how weird is that?
These guys are like using Jesus and
religion to justify eating cows when
they've been a Vegan for all those
years.
What did you not listen to Jesus all
those other years?
Like you're like,
fuck you,
Jesus.
I'm not eating meat.
Like what was the,
what was the turnaround there?
It doesn't make any sense.
Well,
I don't think you can pull veganism out
of the Bible unless you know a.
well,
I guess if you go back to the garden and
there's nothing about them eating meat,
right?
It's just,
it was all provided from the trees.
There's no slaughterhouse in the garden
and Riparian Ism is fairly old.
Mean.
Vegetarianism has been around in Hindu
cultures and so many different cultures
forever,
but not veganism.
Right?
I mean,
veganism is really fairly recent.
It's pretty impractical in history.
Okay.
Hurting remanence of our best tool to
restore fertility to the earth.
Keep the earth covered in reverse.
Desertification and climate change.
He wrote,
we need cows to keep the earth alive.
Cows make an extreme sacrifice for
humanity,
but that's their position in God's plan
as food for the predators.
Whoa.
Huh.
That's a strange quote,
but I think there was more of them,
but that's good enough.
But there was.
There was more of that kind of stuff.
Like all the sudden he's a predator.
Predators go after animals.
They chase him down and they kill them.
It,
I guess we're kind of predators in a
way,
but we're some new thing where some
completely new thing.
We.
We use weapons or we corral them and if
you've got them corralled and you just
stick in that no country for old men
thing in their head and killing them
with it,
I mean that's what they're doing,
right?
If you're doing that,
it's like,
I don't know if you're allowed to call
yourself a predator.
Well,
historically were predatory and chimps
are predators.
Know not.
Not entirely,
but they are that
too.
We're certainly a kind of a Predator,
but we're so much different now and this
is what we're talking about.
We're talking about factory farming and
these weird businesses where they slam
all these animals,
these entirely too small places and they
live in their own feces and urine and
I'm sure you've seen that drone footage
from the pig farm.
I've seen a lot of pig farm footage,
but I don't know if I've seen drone
footage.
I don't think I've seen lakes of urine
feces.
It's disgusting.
It's unbelievable.
They,
this guy flew this thing.
I mean they have these ag gag laws which
are evil.
Oh yeah,
and if you don't know what those means,
what that means.
Ag Gag laws are laws that they make it a
federal crime to show all of the abuse
of these animals,
to show factory farming because it'll
affect the business so drastically and
so radically when people are exposed to
the truth that they've made it illegal.
Those laws should be illegal.
Those laws are scary.
They're scary aspect of human beings.
I've never seen this with some toxic
lake.
It's a lake of pee and poop and all
those things are stuffed to the gills
with pigs.
Yeah.
That is a book,
um,
uh,
eating animals,
Jonathan Safran [inaudible] book,
which is worth reading if you think
you're immune to the details because
it's just.
I mean,
there's the,
there's two aspects to it.
There's the cruelty aspect,
which is actually three aspects.
which is horrific.
Um,
there's the environmental energy use
issue which has also just totally
untenable.
And then there's just the,
if you have any concern about your own
health and the contamination,
I mean just,
just the getting all these antibiotics
that weren't prescribed to you that you
don't want,
but it's still getting into you through
this,
this food chain.
Um,
and I mean,
just the stuff that they like the
chickens,
I mean,
the,
the details about chicken farming is
almost the most horrible.
But I mean,
they're,
they're covered in just,
uh,
just the,
the foulest uh,
no pun intended.
Just the most disgusting material they
go into like a broth that's just like
pure bacteria and um,
uh,
I mean they have to be washed with just
ammonia or whatever they put on them.
I mean,
it's just to really wash with a moment
that I,
I forget the details,
but it's just the read Jonathan Safran
Safran for his book on this.
It's just,
um,
the,
uh,
the details of what goes on from the
chickens.
Actually,
I think largely because they're so small
and it more of the process of killing
them as automated,
that they almost get the worst of it
because they're,
I mean,
they're just,
they're like,
they're getting singed before they're
done before that.
I mean,
there's just,
it's just not.
I mean,
at least with a cow,
you've got a single person interacting
with a single cow,
however,
and it's,
there's less chaos and in,
in the machinery,
but chicken is just get 'em pulverized.
And um,
I think,
I mean,
that's arguably,
that's the one of the greatest pain
points ethically comes around just just
egg industry because fully half the
chickens that the male chicks just
immediately get,
get thrown into a,
literally like a meat grinder because
they're not the same chicken that is a
broiler chicken.
I mean,
the genetically they're not the same.
They don't,
they don't grow into the same kind of
chicken that would be useful.
So they,
they're,
they're useless.
And so they don't lay eggs and you,
you don't eat them.
And so they just get a,
literally just fed into a,
like a woodchipper,
uh,
alive.
I mean there's no,
and again,
this is in some ways an artifact of them
being so small that it would be so much
of a Ha,
just too much of a hassle to stun them
appropriately.
Right.
If they had to.
They made a law.
We had to bury them all and put little
crosses in the ground.
The labor intensive Jesus.
I mean I was like millions and billions,
you know,
I was on the highway and there was a
chicken truck that was passing me,
one of those trucks that's containing
live chickens and they just stacked to
stacked and cages on top of each other
cage on top of cage just shitting on
each other and I'm watching this and I'm
like,
it's so weird that we're allowed to do
that with some animals.
Like if you were doing that with horses,
people would lose their fucking minds.
Have you had dogs in boxes like that
stacked and in the open air on the
highway and you're driving down the road
with them.
People would freak out,
but no one bats an eye at these
chickens.
This chicken truck is.
It's chickens or weird thing.
We have like a hierarchy of animals that
we love and we're not really big into
reptiles,
not really big into birds.
It has something to do,
I think with facial expressiveness a
little bit.
And Mr Fisher also away down like the
fact that fish have these cold
expressionless faces no matter what
happens,
that,
that's,
that cuts down on empathy,
but I think its size,
its facial display and it's also the
sounds they make,
right?
So,
you know,
if a lobster could scream every time it
went to the pot,
you know,
um,
it would be,
it'd be a different encounter with,
you know,
just how much do I want to eat this
thing.
Um,
uh,
and so something obviously like an ape
or something that's cute.
I mean,
it's amazing what a,
what a fluffy tail will get you the
difference between a squirrel and a rat.
Right.
It's crazy.
It is crazy.
Squirrels could just hang out with
everybody.
We're cool with them.
They look so close to rats.
So like,
God,
I'm so close.
It's like a hot girl sister.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Like,
so,
so much so close.
There was an article today about some
woman who had rescued a lobster from a
restaurant and dropped it off in the
ocean and the journey of this all and
how you should think of this lobster or
something with a cute,
and if you did,
then you would appreciate her efforts
and understand that this lobster,
even though they're not even capable of
feeling pain in lobsters,
they don't have enough nervous system.
Their nervous systems aren't strong
enough for them to feel pain.
They don't have the same sort of sensors
that we have.
Allegedly.
Yeah,
I don't.
I,
I've threatened to do this actually when
I.
When I decided to become a vegetarian,
I said at some point maybe I will just
do a,
a,
a taxonomy of the kind of a comparative
neuroanatomy across species just to see
where we could plausibly say,
you know,
the suffering really begins to matter.
The killing anything.
No.
Actually,
there,
there are what are called by Val vegans
who eat clams and oysters and Mussels,
and I could get into that because they
think that,
you know,
there's no way you can make an argument
that there's no basis for suffering
there.
Well,
if there's no feeling,
there's no suffering,
my argument against that Tau is lobsters
are clearly not happy when you throw
them in boiling water.
So what's that reaction?
I think anything that can behave,
they can move right and move away from
the stimulus,
the,
the evolutionary rationale for it to
experience pain on the question of
consciousness is difficult.
You know,
where consciousness emerges.
And I think there is clearly an
unconscious pain mechanisms,
the same mechanisms that give us pain at
a certain level.
We can be unconscious and yet they can
be just as effective.
I mean,
all of our reflexes are like that.
So you touch a hot stove,
you're pulling your hand away actually
before you consciously registering.
Um,
and that's as it should be because
you're faster that way.
Um,
so it's possible to have unconscious
pain,
but anything they can move very quickly
is going to evolve and ability to move
away from noxious stimuli and that,
um,
uh,
there's every reason to make that,
you know,
in,
in evolutionary terms as salient and is
as urgent as possible,
and then our pain responds is that for
us,
and there's no reason to withhold that
from any other animal that's clearly
avoiding stuff with all of its power,
right?
Yeah.
It seems to me that there's got to be
all the way down to mushrooms because
everybody eats mushrooms,
even vegans,
but mushrooms breathe in oxygen and they
breathe out carbon dioxide.
They're way closer to humans than they
really are to plants.
They're weird.
They're a strange sort of an organism
that's been mushrooms.
Yeah.
They're not necessarily like a plant.
I mean,
we think of them as a plan because they
grow,
but they're a fungus.
It's a type of life form and they
interlink through the mycelium.
It will.
Terence Mckenna.
Okay.
If you got him talking on mushrooms long
enough,
he would,
uh,
it's very spooky stuff that he thought
about them.
But there's no nervous system there.
I think the crucial,
um,
variable is the complexity of a nervous
system.
So suffering and pain and emotions.
Yeah,
I mean,
just when you're,
when you're.
So there's suffering is one component of
it,
but then there's just the question of
what sort of experience can this
creature be deprived?
Right?
So when you ask like,
why is it a tragedy or why would it be a
tragedy to,
to kill someone painlessly in their
sleep,
right?
So there's no suffering there.
Right?
And if anything you've just ended
whatever suffering they were going to
have in their future,
why would that be a tragedy if it
happened to all of us tonight?
Right?
Just,
you know,
this,
um,
some neurotoxin comes down from space
and kills us all in our sleep and no
suffering is associated with it.
The only,
uh,
you know,
ethically speaking,
the only problem there,
and it's a huge one,
is that it forecloses all of the
possible happy future is most of us are,
all of us are,
at least some of us we're going to have.
So the,
all of the good things that we could
have done over the next million years
aren't going to get done.
Um,
all of the beauty,
all the creativity,
all of the joy,
all of that just gets canceled.
Um,
and so,
so leaving the,
the painfulness of pain aside,
you know,
why is it wrong to deprive any given
animal of life?
Well,
they're in so far as that life has any
intrinsic value in so far as that in so
far as the being that animal is better
than being nothing.
Right?
Then you're also just canceling all of
that good stuff.
And for that,
you know,
for any good stuff,
you need a,
a nervous system.
Yeah.
If and for any pain you need to.
Nervous system.
So far as we understand this,
um,
though there are people who say any good
stuff,
what do you experience any original
movement though,
right?
Like being prejudice about the
experiences that plants are having been
by being immobile,
you know,
have you ever thought ever paid
attention to some of the more recent
research on plant intelligence and weird
stuff that's going on with them?
Calculations and they're exuding,
I'm expressing some sense that causes a
when they're being eaten,
causes other other plants.
Downwind changed their flavor to avoid
predation.
There was a New Yorker article on this.
I forget when this came out.
We.
It's weird.
There's weird.
There's weird stuff that plants do,
which,
and I remember the details of that
article aren't so clear to me.
I remember not knowing what to think
about some of it,
but some of it clearly can be explained
in evolutionary terms.
That doesn't imply any experience.
It just,
it could all be dark and it's all blind
mechanism,
but so the,
it still has consciousness.
The consciousness as we know it is.
What's most valuable to you?
Well,
I think it's the only thing that's
valuable to anything.
It's like when you're going to talk
about value,
so it's like,
you know,
if this,
if this cup has no experience,
right?
So if,
if my trading places with it insofar as
you can make sense of that concept is
synonymous with just canceling my
experience.
Well then there's,
there's,
this cup is unconscious.
There's nothing that is like to be the
cup.
When I break it,
I haven't created a suffering.
I haven't,
I haven't done anything unethical to the
cup,
I have no ethical responsibilities
toward the cup,
but the moment you give me something
that can be made happy or be made
miserable depending on how I behave
around it or toward it,
well then I'm,
I'm ethically entangled with it.
And then it's.
And then,
and that begins to scale.
I'm in,
I think in a fairly linear way with just
how complex the thing is.
So,
and this is maybe something we even
talked about on a previous podcast.
Um,
you know,
if I'm driving home today and I know bug
hits my windshield,
you know that that has whatever ethical
implication it has,
but it's given what I believe about bugs
and given how small they are and given
how little they do and given how
primitive their nervous systems are,
um,
you know,
I'm not going to lose sleep over,
killing a bug.
If I hit a squirrel,
I'm going to feel worse.
If I had a dog,
I'm going to feel worse than his son was
a kid.
Obviously I may never get over it and
even if I live to be a thousand,
right,
so the,
the scaling and,
and granted there are cultural
accretions there so you can.
I justify that the way I feel about a
dog as opposed to a deer,
you know,
that there's a difference,
but the difference is one of richness of
experience in so far as we understand
what other species experience,
you could make that argument to justify
eating animals as opposed to being
accountable.
Right?
You could say,
well,
what kind of experiences a deer have?
They're just running around the woods.
Try not to get eaten.
They eat grass they made.
It's very simple.
It's a very simple experience in
comparison to your average person that
lives in Los Angeles that reads books,
you know,
I mean someone who goes into a lot of
trips,
someone has a lot of loved ones.
Someone who has a great career.
Someone who's deeply invested in their
work.
Yeah.
Is much more.
There's much more complexity and the
deer behave just as deer all over the
place and it's a very primitive sort of
a life form.
Well,
if you go further and further back,
like what did.
It seems like you can keep going with
that and one of the things that I that
concerns me the most about plants,
not concerns me but puzzles me the most
about plants is whether or not the way I
look at them,
me personally,
my prejudices about them,
I just not thinking at all of them as
being conscious.
What if we think about things in terms
of the complexity of their experiences,
just because we're,
we're prejudiced about things that move
made.
It's entirely possible that like,
it's going to sound really stupid,
but I've said a lot of stupid shit.
I went into a grow room once,
like a pot grow room,
right?
This guy had his Mac daddy room and
I walked in.
I was like,
this is like being in a room full of
people.
This feels weird as fuck.
It felt.
It felt very weird.
It felt like there was a tangible like
vibe of life in there and there's no
other way to describe that without
sounding like a complete moron,
but,
but it was my experience.
I know what it's like to be that more
on,
but you know what I mean.
Take enough acid.
You know what you're talking.
I'm not saying that we shouldn't eat
plants.
I'm not done.
I've seen people were ready up in arms
with their twitter fingers ready to get
off,
but what I am saying is it's entirely
possible that all things that are alive
have some sort of a way of of being
conscious.
May Not be mobile,
may not be as expressive,
but there might be the stillness of you
without language when you're in a place
of complete peace,
when you're in a zen meditative state.
What about that?
Stillness is really truly associated
with being a human are really,
truly associated with being an English
speaking person in North America.
Almost nothing.
It's just an existence.
Right,
and then everything else sort of
branches out from that and then humans,
we all make the agreement that of course
it branches out far further and wider
than any other animal,
but how do we know that these plants
aren't branching out like that too?
How do we know that?
Then if they're having some
communication with each other,
if they're responding to probation,
if they're literally changing their
flavor,
they're doing all these calculations and
all these strange things that they're
finding out that plants are capable of
doing,
like what?
What is going on there?
We don't know necessarily.
I'm agnostic on the question of how far
down consciousness goes and I agree that
there's very likely a condition of
something like pure consciousness that
really is separable from the details of
any given species.
I mean it's something that I've
experienced myself.
It feels like you certainly have this
experience,
what you know,
what its implications are.
I don't know,
but you can have the experience of just
consciousness and it doesn't have any
personal or even human reference point,
so it's not.
It's not.
You're not even.
It doesn't even have a reference point
in one of the channel that the human
sense channels so you're not seeing.
You're not hearing,
you're not smelling and you're not
thinking and you're yet.
You are.
So there is still just open conscious
experience and whether that is.
That is what it's like to be a plant.
I don't know because I don't know what
the relationship between consciousness
and information processing in the brain
actually is though.
It's not,
you know,
it's,
it's totally plausible.
In fact,
um,
I think it's probably the most plausible
thesis that there is some direct
connection between information
processing and integrated information
processing and consciousness and that
and that there is nothing that's like to
be this
cup and,
you know,
the atoms are not conscious and,
and,
but yet,
but that the thesis that every,
that consciousness goes all the way down
into the,
the most basic constituents of matter,
um,
that,
that thesis is called Panpsychism and
philosophy and that's pan everywhere.
A psych is a mind.
Um,
so that the mind is sometimes everywhere
in nature.
That's not,
you can't rule that out.
I mean,
there's nothing we know about the world
to rule that out.
What I think you can rule out is,
um,
the,
the richness of the content of
consciousness in these species.
And so,
so plants are not having conversations
like this,
right?
So plants don't understand what we're
doing.
There's no way they would.
There's just.
No,
they don't have nervous systems,
they're not there,
they can't be processing information in
a way that would give them what we know
as a,
as a rich experience.
But your point about the timescale and
movement is,
um,
is totally valid if,
if,
if every time you walked into a room
you're affirmed,
just turned and looked at you,
just oriented towards you and followed
you around the room with its,
with its leading branch,
you would feel very different about,
it's the possibility that it's
conscious,
right?
You'd be a good person to ask this,
but is that a,
an urban myth that if you sing to your
plants,
your plants,
music,
that they grow better?
Uh,
I haven't looked into it.
I would have.
When you define,
I would bet that it is.
Yes.
It sounds like one of those things will
chicks who like crystals tell you.
Yeah,
no.
I would bet.
I would bet that it is.
I sing to my flowers and they grow so
beautiful.
Yeah.
It seems like one of those things that
people say,
I'm definitely not insinuating that
plants would have as rich and experience
as human beings,
but I don't think a deer has as rich an
experience.
No,
no.
As a human being either.
And it's just to me,
my,
um,
my curiosity lies in the future of
understanding plant intelligence.
Like wouldn't it be fascinating if we
found out that they,
like,
one of the reasons why psychedelic drugs
puzzled me so much is that they exist
and there's a lot of plants you could
just eat them and you have your brain
already has this place.
It'll go.
If you eat these plants,
like if you eat pod,
if you,
uh,
if you try the San Pedro cactus out this
spring,
uh,
you,
you can,
you can have these really powerful
psychedelic experiences just from a
plant.
Like why does the human mind interact
with these plants like that?
Like especially fungus,
like when you have like major league
mushroom trips,
it's very strange sort of feeling like
you're in communication with another
Mckenna described it best in that way.
That there's someone there that it's not
just you and hallucinations.
It has this distinct feeling that
there's someone there and that someone
according to the.
The hippiest of hippies is plan
intelligence.
It's my mother,
Gaia.
It's the earth itself.
It's all life.
It's love.
It's God.
It's all.
It all exists inside the intelligence
that's intertwined in nature.
It's one of the most things that one of
the things that's most puzzling about
the most potent of all psychedelics,
which is dimethyltryptamine,
that it's in so many different plants
like to make dimethyltryptamine
containing plants illegal would be
hilarious because there'd be like
hundreds and hundreds of plants they'd
have to make illegal like including like
full Eris grass.
It's just really rich and five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine,
which is the most potent potent form of
it.
Also our own brains,
so every,
every brick,
every brain makes it a little weird
little lizards that have retinas and
lenses where their pineal gland is.
They're making it in their little screwy
little lizard brains.
We don't even know what the hell is for
like the the,
the questions about are just so much.
There's so many more questions than
there are answers.
They were like,
you've paid attention to,
um,
uh,
rick strassman stuff,
the general,
that book did you know,
that the cottonwood research foundation
and actually found mice brains producing
dimethyltryptamine.
So it's been proven that it's actually
been growing in the pineal gland,
the gland that they had always.
Yeah.
I,
I had assumed that if I got that from
the book or not,
but that's crazy
as a neuroscientist.
Like doesn't that kind of freak you out
that those Egyptians had those third
eyes and like all the eastern mysticism
had that pineal gland highlighted.
It was like the on the end of shafts are
staff.
They would put those pine cones like how
the hell they know all that.
Well,
there is a,
I mean the third eye metaphor or I mean
it's not as more than a metaphor,
you know,
anatomically,
but it's,
um,
it's a,
uh,
it's an,
it correlates with the kind of
experience you can have.
I don't actually know if the experience
people have.
That's the shocker of you need to talk
in yoga terms.
Um,
I don't know if that has anything to do
with the pineal gland,
I,
it may be because I don't know,
I don't think anyone's done this
neuroimaging experiment where he can get
people who can reliably produce a,
a third eye opening sort of experience
and,
and scan their brains while they do it.
In fact,
I'm almost positive that hasn't been
done.
But,
um,
there is a phenomenology here of people
having a kind of inner opening of,
it's almost certainly largely a matter
of,
of visual cortex getting stimulated,
but you can,
you can meditate in such a way as to
produce this experience.
And,
um,
it's also,
it's an experience that you have more or
less on,
on different psychedelics.
Psychedelics are much more visual than
others and certain doses in particular
like mushrooms and DMT,
which I've never taken,
which,
you know,
you can say better than I,
but it's,
it's reported to be quite visual and
the,
um,
the experience,
uh,
so in most people when they close their
eyes,
unless they have to,
having hypnogogic imagery is before
sleep or they just have to happen to be,
you know,
super good visualizers of,
of imagery.
You close your eyes and you just
basically have darkness there right now
that now if you close your eyes and if
you're listening to this and you close
your eyes and you look into the darkness
of your closed eyes,
this,
that actually is,
that's it.
That's a,
that is as much your visual field as it
is when your eyes are open,
right?
I mean,
it's not like your visual field hasn't
gone away when you close your eyes.
It's just,
it's now,
there's not much detail for you to
notice again,
unless you are in some unusual state,
but that,
you know,
based on,
on different techniques of meditation.
And this happened spontaneously,
again,
with hypnogogic images or,
or with psychedelics,
that space can open up in to a,
just a massive world of visual display,
right?
So you can just see a full blown,
you know,
three d movie in there,
um,
and it's a,
uh,
um,
but most of us just take it for granted
that when you close your eyes,
you,
you're functionally blind,
you can't see anything and you were not,
were not interested in that space,
but you can actually train yourself to
look deeply into that space as a,
as a technique of meditation.
I don't want to interrupt you,
but does that have implications in
people having eye witness testimony and
eye witness experiences that turned out
to not be true at all?
Because if you think about the,
the,
the human mind and the imagination be
able to being able to create imagery
once the eyes are closed,
like you can in sensory deprivation
tanks like 10 sensory deprivation tanks
are that a lot of people's experiences
are very visual even though it's in
complete darkness.
Now you know how people see things and
they thought they saw something.
And it turns out to not be true at all,
whether it's big foot or whether it's a
robbery or a suspect,
and they get the details completely
outright,
but isn't it possible that under fear
and when your your pulse is jacked up
and your adrenaline's running and you're
worried about all these possibilities in
your imagination starts formulating
predetermined possibilities.
You should be looking out for like what
if it's big foot?
What if it's a Robert Wood?
If it's an alien,
what if it's at this and then these
people that swear they saw these things
that everybody knows they didn't like.
Maybe there was video footage or for
whatever it was.
Is it possible that your brain can do
that?
Two,
U and t can literally show you things
that aren't real?
Oh yeah,
I can do that.
Although I think the unreliability of of
witness testimony and it's shockingly
unreliable,
is more a matter of memory that the
corruption of memory and the way
memories are recall are there especially
vulnerable when you're recalling them
can be revised when you were in the act
of recall.
And it's very easy to tamper with
people's memory,
you know,
albeit inadvertently.
I mean you can do this on purpose too,
but,
but people just do it with bad
interrogation techniques.
So you know,
the,
the cop will ask you,
you know,
so when did you see the,
the woman at the crosswalk and he's just
put a woman at the crosswalk into your
memory,
right?
So because you,
you can't help it visualize a woman at
the crosswalk and his memory is very
fragile.
And so when you're,
whenever you're giving an account of an
experience,
even if it's an experience that happened
half a second ago,
now we're in the domain of memory.
Now we're in the domain of,
of,
of just what you can report a we're not,
it's not a matter of what you're
consciously experiencing.
No.
I know there was a case in India where I
believe it was a woman was convicted of
murder through the use of an Fmr rye or
a functioning magnetic resonance imagery
machine.
And through this Fmr I,
they determined in some strange way that
she had functional knowledge of the
crime scene.
And the argument against that,
I believe,
was that she could have developed
functional memory of the crime scene by
being told you're being prosecuted for a
crime.
You might go to jail for murder.
Here's the crime scene.
Like it's or just being unlucky enough
to be familiar as,
I mean,
normally when this gets done and there
are people who do it in the states,
but they don't use Fmri as their
modality,
but they,
they do,
um,
they do sort of interrogate people's
familiarity.
Uh,
and they,
they use eeg as a,
as a,
um,
as a way of monitoring.
Um,
uh,
their familiarity with those.
Show them,
you know,
if you are shown evidence from the crime
scene that only the perpetrator could
have seen,
you know,
hopefully it's really something that
only the perpetrator could have seen.
But if,
you know,
if they show you the picture and you
know,
you see the,
Oh yeah,
you know,
I have that Ikea End table and you know,
I have that dress from banana republic
or whatever.
Um,
that just by dint of bad luck,
you're familiar with something that
you're being shown from the crime scene
and especially if it's a murder,
you're talking about someone who's.
She was probably intimate with.
She probably knew them at least.
So she's probably been good house.
Yeah,
I think that would be obviously a case
where you really couldn't do it at all.
How does it work?
Why don't I know no one in the states as
far as I know,
unless this has changed in the last year
or so since I've paid attention to this.
You can't,
this none.
None of this is admissible in court were
only on India and it's only the one case
that I ever heard of crazy premature use
of the technology.
But how does the technology work?
Like what does it,
what does it actually seeing where you
have,
um,
with Eeg,
I think this has worked out more.
You can have a,
a,
a kind of a canonical familiarity
response to a stimuli.
If you've seen something,
again,
if you've seen seen something for the
first time,
you know,
is it would be a novelty response.
Seeing something for the third,
fourth,
fifth time would be a different response
and you can,
I mean,
this has been,
um,
uh,
again,
it's been a long time since I've looked
at this particular research and I don't
know how,
you know,
I don't know what they're calling these,
these wave forms now.
I mean there was a p 300 wave form at
one point and they're there way forms
that come from certain areas of the
brain at certain timing intervals based
on,
you know,
from the moment of,
of receiving a stimulus,
you know,
let's say a photograph.
Um,
and they are the hallmark of either
being familiar or not with this thing.
And um,
yeah,
so I mean it's not,
there's no question that at a certain
point we will have reliable mind reading
machines.
I think I'm not.
I think it's really just a matter of
time.
I think there's also no question that we
don't have them now,
at least not in a way that we can,
we can send some,
send someone to prison on the basis of
what their brain did an experiment.
But I mean,
just,
just as you,
I mean anything but a lot,
a lot of this,
the most interesting stuff is
unconscious,
but anything you're consciously aware of
having seen before,
right?
So if you,
if you were to show me this Cup,
right?
And then,
uh,
five seconds later say,
is this the cup I showed you?
You know,
I have a,
a very clear sense of.
Yeah,
that's the cup,
right?
So,
and if you show me a completely
different cup,
I'm going to have a very clear internal
sentiment.
No,
that's.
And that's not the cup.
If you're having that experience,
you know,
that that is absolutely something about
the state of your brain that can be
discriminated by a person outside your
brain running the appropriate experiment
is just our tools are still sufficiently
course that,
you know,
it's not like,
sequencing your dna where we can say,
yeah,
that was you.
And what's your,
your uh,
blood at the crime scene.
But,
um,
eventually it will be,
it will be just,
there'll be no basis to doubt it because
I'll be able to put you through a
paradigm where it'll just be clear,
I know your thoughts,
right?
So to think of how much faith you would
have in this technology,
if you could open your computer and read
any file a file of your choosing that I
have never seen,
right?
So the contents of which are,
are completely blind,
I'm completely blind to and I'm scanning
your brain while you're reading this
journal entry or a newspaper or
whatever.
And at the end of that I can say,
well,
you know,
based on this report,
you clearly read a story about Donald
Trump and you,
you actually don't like Donald Trump.
And I could tell you in detail about,
you know,
what you were consciously thinking
about,
um,
you know,
if you did that,
if you could do that 100 percent of the
time,
right?
At a certain point,
the basis to doubt the validity of the
mind reading machine would just go away.
You would just,
it would be like,
you know,
it's like,
are you here really hearing my voice
right now?
You certainly seem to,
you know,
it's,
it's just,
it would become a,
just a,
a background assumption that the
technology works at a certain point just
as though the meat is scary.
The fake meat.
That idea is terrifying.
The idea of losing the,
the,
losing your thoughts.
Yeah.
The ownership.
Like losing a thought,
becoming non autonomous,
like the idea of everybody sharing
thoughts,
it seems almost inevitable.
Well,
this,
you know,
I don't know that we would decide to do
this.
Certainly I don't think we would do.
We would do this all the time,
right?
I mean it might be Sunday doing
something,
but no option.
We might be compelled to do it.
I mean,
if,
if you're at a murder trial,
right?
If you,
someone who may have killed somebody,
you,
I mean,
the,
the fifth amendment becomes interesting
in that case.
But,
um,
uh,
we have worked that out for DNA
evidence,
right?
So you,
you have a right to take the fifth,
but you don't have a right to withhold
your blood from the proceeding.
Right?
So I get,
I get to look at your blood or your
saliva so you don't have to talk,
but I can read your mind.
Yeah.
And that's,
I think that's a.
well,
and it's,
this is like the iphone case,
you know,
it's like I thus far decided that we
can't compel apple to unlock an iphone.
Uh,
this is just the ultimate case of that.
So the,
the argument in favor of apple is this
is far too intimate and far too
comprehensive.
Look at a person's mind.
Uh,
you know,
once you have cracked their iphone,
you,
you're basically walking around the
corridors of their brain,
um,
uh,
that's a,
that's a slippery slope.
We don't want to go down,
but ultimately we will be able to do it
with brains.
And I think it obviously you're going
gonna want all of the safeguards that
you can easily imagine and probably some
you have yet to imagine on this process,
but safeguards in place.
I think this would be the best thing
that could ever happen to us in terms
of,
you know,
when you look at a criminal justice
system and that when you look at the
price we pay for not being able to tell
whether someone is innocent or guilty or
whether they're lying.
It is just,
it is the most intolerable price that I
see in society.
It's just,
it's just the amount of human misery
born of not being able to demonstrate
that someone is lying reliably.
It's just,
it's off.
It's,
it's the biggest lever that would,
I think we could pull certainly when you
have prisons that are filled with a lot
of people that are probably innocent.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
People who have gone to to the gallows,
no doubt.
And we know innocent people who have
been killed.
And so one way to deal with as you be,
be against the death penalty.
Right?
So there's always a chance to find their
innocence.
But imagine being in prison on death row
for 30 years and you know,
for rape or rape,
you didn't commit,
you know,
it's um,
it's so horrible.
Terrifying.
So yeah,
that would be the major argument.
It would be such a simple solution.
Really A,
now there are corner cases that wouldn't
be solved.
I think there are people who are
delusional or easily self deceived who
either would be lying and,
but you know,
so convinced of the truth of their lives
that they would pass this,
this lie detector presumably.
Um,
and then there are people who are so
sick,
suggestible that they can be led to
believe something that's not true.
I mean they'd be the people who can be
convinced that you get these false
confessions of,
in response to a crime.
I mean,
it's a,
it's one of the strangest things in the
world,
but you know,
when,
when someone gets murdered,
this doesn't get publicized very much.
But it's a very common experience of
police officers or police departments to
hear from people in the community who
are confessing to the crime and they
didn't commit it.
They just come in and they say,
I did it,
and they,
they give all this,
you know,
this bogus account of what happened and
these,
and this is a sign of mental illness or
you know,
these are people I'm seeking attention
and some morbid way,
but there are people clearly who are so
suggestible that they can either lead
themselves to believe or be led by
others to believe that they've done
things they didn't do.
And,
and in,
in just shocking detail.
There was another New Yorker article on,
um,
uh,
I think it was written by William
Languish,
um,
uh,
this years ago,
but,
uh,
on a,
a satanic panic,
a case where a guy got a accused of
running a satanic cult,
uh,
by I think his daughter who was in
hypnosis,
hypnosis recovery therapy,
right?
Um,
so she had been led down the primrose
path by her therapist.
And so she obviously was fairly
suggestible and she recalled the most
lurid,
just insane Rosemary's baby style,
you know,
cult,
uh,
imaginable going on in her town where
the friends of dad were coming over and
raping everyone.
And there was a human sacrifice of
infants and the infants were buried by
the barn and um,
she,
this,
the dad was so suggestible that he just
confessed and he was just,
he and he was given more details and he
went to prison.
I don't know,
this is this now an old article.
It's probably like 10 or 15 years old,
but this guy,
this guy just fully confessed,
right?
And,
uh,
the journalist I believe was language.
Um,
uh,
at the end they actually did a Ted guy
is now in prison,
right?
The process is completed.
Justice has been done.
Uh,
the daughter convinced that her,
her dad has a satanic monster and uh,
as,
as he,
and he's now in prison and they went in
and interviewed him asking followup
questions with just details that they
made up,
right?
Because they began to suspect that he
was just this kind of suggestibility
machine,
right?
Who just would cop to anything.
And so they went in and they just made
up stuff like,
oh,
you know,
there's,
a few more details want to iron out.
Your daughter said that there was a time
where,
you know,
you got a,
you brought in a horse and riding on the
horse and um,
and then you killed the horse.
I've,
I,
I'm not,
I'm making these details up because I
don't remember.
But,
um,
something that they just concocted.
Right.
And he said,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
um,
so,
and he just copped to that.
It was,
it became like a twilight zone.
It's like a perfect twilight zone
episode where they,
like now you realize that this guy has
been put away is just saying yes to
everything.
Right.
And that's,
that's um,
so clearly that they resolve it.
I don't know.
Again,
I don't know if he ever wrote any
followup on this because this as I
recall,
and this,
uh,
this is like a 15 year old story.
It just,
they ended with like,
you know,
the twilight zone moment where now you
realize this guy is innocent and just
saying yes to everything.
And his daughter crazy,
she shares his jeans.
I don't remember.
I don't recall what the daughter did
with that.
Uh,
but he,
um,
I mean the,
the story and perhaps there's more to
the story,
but the story on his face was totally
exculpatory,
like,
like the reader experience was you got
to let this guy out of prison tomorrow
because you know,
I'm fucked and he needed.
If he gets out and he's mine is probably
so screwed up by this whole experience
and if he really does believe that he
ran these satanic rituals,
just the guilt and shame of it all.
I mean we're assuming that his mind
works.
I mean this is the thing that I wonder
how many people were like functionally
deeply,
deeply damaged,
but they're functional.
Like they're there,
they're going to the same schools and
you go to,
they work where you work,
but they're barely a person.
They're like,
all their connections are all fucked up.
Like if you went into the back wiring or
their head,
if you were like an appliance repair
person,
like sell your TV's not working.
Huh?
Let me go back here.
What the fuck is all this mean?
How many people are like that,
that are just sort of kind of
functional?
My question is if we do get to a point
where you could read minds,
what if you go into their minds and you
find out,
well,
this is what they really think,
like this is not a liar,
this is a person
who's seeing things that aren't there,
like a person who's completely
delusional,
like people that have these.
I'm hallucinating a hallucinogenic
visions like some people have like
really like deeply troubling visual
images that they see match.
If he's poor,
fucking people really are seeing that
and if you could read their mind,
you would.
You would literally be inside the mind
of a person whose mind isn't functioning
and we can get sort of an understanding
about what that would be like.
Yeah.
Well,
this has been done in a very simple way.
Where you with schizophrenia who mostly
have auditory hallucinations,
you can now detect auditory cortex
activity,
so mishaps,
misinterpretations.
We just know that they're.
They're auditory cortices are active in
the same way that when you're hearing my
voice,
it's going to be active.
When they're hearing internal voices,
it's active.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
Which is what you would expect.
Maybe be the surprise would be the other
way if it,
if nothing was going on and auditory
cortex and they were hearing voices,
then wow,
then that would be more surprising to
me.
That's fascinating.
You can watch the hallucinations take
place inside the mind of the person and
you can stimulate hallucinations in
people you can stimulate out of body
experiences and people with,
with transcranial magnetic stimulation
and.
Yeah,
how do they do that?
They've been able to do that recently
and to try to give people the same sort
of experience that they claim to have
had when like on the operating table.
That's what people have a lot,
right?
When they're almost dead.
Yeah.
What's going on?
What is that?
Well,
that is,
um,
uh,
there's an area,
I believe this is the temporal parietal
junction,
which is sort of like here,
um,
what you're pointing to a lot of time
talking to you and not talking to the
millions.
Um,
but uh,
it's um,
you know,
where the temporal lobe and the parietal
lobes intersect.
Um,
and the,
um,
I think it was first discovered in
surgery on an epileptic where they,
so are you in,
in any kind of resection of the brain
where the people are awake because
there's no pain sensors in the brain so
you can,
you can stay awake while you're getting
brain surgery and they tend to keep you
awake if they're going to be removing
areas of the brain,
you know,
let's say a tumor or the focus of an
epileptic seizure,
um,
and they don't want to remove working
parts,
especially the language part.
So,
so they're,
um,
they're keeping people awake and they're
probing,
uh,
those areas of the cortex to see what
it's correlated within the person's
experience.
So you said there having them talk,
they're having them answer questions and
they're,
and they're putting a little bit of
current in that area which would be
disruptive of normal.
And you know,
you can see there they're mapping the
almost entirely mapping language cortex
when they do this.
But there have been experiences where
they,
I'm a neurosurgeon will,
will put a little current in,
in an area near this region of the brain
and people will have this out of body
experience where they're,
you know,
up in the corner of the room looking
down on their bodies or um,
you know,
the classic,
astral projection experience where the
or the um,
um,
the near death experience where,
you know,
people have,
have risen out of their body or seem to
have risen out of their body and
consciousness now seems to be located
elsewhere.
And that's a,
um,
uh,
there's just,
the,
that region of the brain is,
um,
I mean,
virtually every region of the cortex
does many,
many things.
There's no,
there's no one region of the brain that
does one thing.
You know,
there's a couple of exceptions to this,
but the,
um,
uh,
so the burden,
the whole brain is participating in,
in much of what we do and it's just a
greater or lesser degrees of activity.
But in terms of your,
your mapping,
your body in space,
this is,
you know,
the parietal lobe is,
has got a lot to do with that and when
that gets disturbed,
you can have weird experiences.
You can have the experience of,
I'm not recognizing your body or parts
of your body.
You're like,
you,
like,
you don't really like Alien Hand
Syndrome where you'd like your left arm.
Uh,
seems seems like another person's arm,
you know,
and people,
try to disown half their body.
Um,
and uh,
you can trick people with visual,
um,
uh,
changes of display like you can,
you can wear headgear where you can make
me feel like it's like a,
it's called the body swapping illusion.
I can feel like I am located.
My consciousness is located in your
body.
Looking back at me,
there's a,
there's a clever experiment that they
did where,
um,
that is the ultimate extension of what
has long been called the rubber hand
illusion where you can,
you can put like my two hands are on the
table.
Now you can set up an experiment where
if you put a rubber hand,
um,
if,
if you,
if you set this up in a way where I am,
I am assuming I have my two hands here.
Um,
you can,
uh,
you can put a rubber hand in its place
and um,
touch,
touch this rubber hand with it,
with a brush,
right?
So,
so the,
so I'm seeing the rubber hand get
touched.
W W with a brush and I'm a,
I can feel like my hand is being
touched.
Like it's like if my hand is being
touched,
my hand is elsewhere under the table
being touched with a brush at the same
time.
I can feel like my hand is now the
rubber hand,
right?
I could,
so I can feel like my hand is in place
of the rubber hand based on visual and
tactile.
Um,
you know,
the simultaneity of my scene,
the rubber hand get touched with a brush
and my feeling my hand,
which is now under the table being
touched with the brush.
I'm,
I'm not explaining that setup great,
but people can look it up.
But you can do the same thing to a,
to the ultimate degree with this video
goggles display where I'm getting input,
visual input from where you're standing.
So like if you come up to shake my hand,
right,
I'm,
I'm seeing you come up to me and shake
my hand,
but I'm seeing it from your point of
view,
right?
So like I'm getting,
you know,
visual input from,
from,
you know,
I now feel like I'm walking up to me
shaking my hand and you can,
you can just kind of feel like you are
consciousness is,
is out,
is over there,
you know,
outside your body.
Um,
and it's just to say that,
that our,
our sense of self,
our sense of being located where we are
in our heads is largely a,
and in some cases almost entirely a
matter of a vision,
right?
It's a matter of fact.
The fact that you feel you're over there
is because you're,
I mean,
that's where your eyes are here.
You're behind your eyes.
You feel like you're behind your eyes.
And when you and tricks of a vision can,
can,
uh,
seem to dislodge,
um,
that's that sense of being located
there.
So stimulating one area of the brain
electrically has been shown,
like even just transdermally,
just the,
I guess,
what do they do?
They put little,
little,
what are those things called?
Those little glue on things.
Electrodes.
And they can.
You're talking about eeg.
They're reading from the brain,
right?
No,
I'm actually talking about some new
experiments that they've been doing that
they were talking about on radio lab.
And apparently there's a bunch of,
do it yourselfers that or if you ever
listened to radio lab.
Amazing Awhile.
But yeah,
amazing podcasts like one of the best
our.
But it has this one episode that dealt
with people learning certain skills
while the outside of their brain is
being stimulated with like a little
electrode.
And this woman who was one of the
reporters went to a sniper training
thing where they set up the scenario and
they give you like a fake gun and you
pointed the screen.
He tried to hit the targets as all these
things are happening.
Uh,
she did it once.
Yeah.
Nine Volt Nirvana is the name of the
episode.
Right,
right.
It is an outstanding episode.
It's so fascinating.
Anyway,
she goes through one.
She's terrible at it.
She just sucks terribly.
Then they hook her up to this machine.
They attached this electrode to a
certain certain area of her brain,
stimulate one area of her brain and she
goes through it like a fucking sniper
time,
slows down.
She gets 20 out of 20.
So she goes from being a complete
failure to being awesome at it and some
weird state
that she described and they're talking
about of the US government's using it
and they're trying to train soldiers and
snipers and people to try to understand
this mindset and try to achieve this
mindset and that they're trying to do
it.
And there's certain companies that are
experimenting with it at least by
stimulating the outside of your head.
Was it.
So I could not know this particular
story.
I remember hearing that title though,
but the transcranial magnetic
stimulation is magnetic energy,
which is,
you know,
the,
the flip side of electrical energy.
So if you apply a big magnet to the side
of your head,
you are changing the electrical
properties of your cortex.
Is that what they're doing?
Well,
no,
I'm,
I'm wondering if they've just made a
transcranial magnetic device so small
that it's,
that it's um,
I don't think it's Magneto is direct.
Current.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Okay.
Direct current stimulation.
Transcranial direct current stimulation.
Yeah,
that's what it's called.
TCD will say.
Yeah,
I'm unaware of the specifics of this,
but it's,
it's been true for a long time that
with,
with um,
a much bigger device in a lab,
you can change a person's performance
for good or for ill on,
on various tasks just by and,
and it's just an electromagnet which is
focusing its energy on various areas of
the cortex.
So bizarre.
Yeah.
Because what we're doing,
I mean you are,
you are disrupting a neural firing,
but your,
you can disrupt areas that are
inhibiting other things you want to
release.
So it's,
it can be,
it's not always synonymous with the
degradation of performance mean you
could,
you could increase performance on a
certain task by taking one region of the
brain offline are more or less offline.
Um,
but I'm not,
you know,
I'm not aware of how far they've taken
it in terms of doing anything that seems
useful in terms of performing something.
I mean what the research I'm more aware
of is just using this to figure out what
various regions of the brain are doing.
I mean I a mapping function because you
want to see if I disrupt area and area
here,
what,
how does that show up in an experiment
and that gives you some clue as to as to
what that region is doing,
at least in that task.
As much as we know about the mind and
being able to do things like this.
Like overall,
if you had a really like trying to map
out the exact functions of the mind and
how everything works,
how far do you think we are along the
understanding that we halfway to think
we understand half of how the brain
works.
Not what I mean,
I wouldn't even know how to quantify it
at this point.
It's just we know a ton,
right.
And we know how we know a lot about
where languages and where facial
recognition is.
And so your,
your,
your visual cortex been really well
mapped and um,
uh,
we know a lot and the last 150 years
based on just the neurological injury
and,
and then in the last,
uh,
decades based on imaging technology,
we know regions of the brain that,
you know,
absolutely governed language and regions
of the brain that have basically nothing
to do with language,
you know,
to take one example,
um,
and we know a lot about memory and we,
we know about a lot about the different
kinds of memory,
uh,
but it's um,
there's,
you know,
I think there's probably,
there's much more.
We don't know what's even more um,
because I kind of the greatest friction
in the system.
There's not often a lot to do with what
we know.
Right.
So like the,
like knowing is not enough for certain
things.
It's not because he tried to intervene
is another part of the process,
which where there are no guarantees,
I mean the,
the,
the way we can intervene in the
functioning of the brain is incredibly
crude,
you know,
pharmacologically or with surgery or
with a device like that.
Um,
so to get,
to get from a place of really refined
knowledge to a place of being able to do
something we want to do with that
knowledge,
that's another step.
And that's,
that's a step that is,
um,
you know,
I,
there's no reason to think that we're
not going to take it at some point,
but it's an additional complexity to get
inside the head safely and help people,
you know,
or improve function.
Um,
uh,
even if you know a lot about what you
know,
those areas of the brain do,
but we don't,
we don't know.
We haven't cracked the neural code.
We don't know.
We don't know how consciousness is
arising in the brain.
Um,
we wouldn't know how to build a,
a,
a computer that does what we do to say
nothing of experience the world as we
experience it yet.
And um,
and we may be going down paths where we
will build it more by happenstance,
whereas like we will,
we,
when we build it and not quite know how
it's doing,
what it's doing,
but it seeming to do more or less what
we do,
I would be doing it very differently.
I mean,
so the,
there are two paths are at least two
distinct paths in artificial
intelligence and one path could take a,
could try to emulate what the brain is
doing and that obviously requires a real
detailed understanding of what the brain
is doing.
Another path would be to just ignore the
brain,
right?
So like there's no reason why
artificially intelligent machines,
even machines that are super human in
their capacities need to do anything,
uh,
that is similar to what we do with our
brains.
You know,
it wouldn't,
you know,
neurochemical circus,
so because they're going to be organized
differently and um,
you know,
could be organized quite differently and
obviously made of totally different
stuff.
Um,
so whether you want to go down the path
of emulating the brain on the basis of
have a detailed understanding of it or
you just want to go down the path of
maximizing intelligent behavior in
machines or some combination of the two,
they're there.
They're not necessarily,
they're,
they're distinct and,
and,
um,
one doesn't entail really knowing that
much about the brain necessarily.
So there's really two different ways
they can go about it.
Either they could try to reproduce a
brain,
which people are,
they can make.
Yeah,
I mean,
if they can make fake meat,
why can't they make fake brain tissue?
It seems like they could.
I mean,
I know a woman got her bladder replaced
with stem cells.
Did you hear about that?
They took stem cells and recreated her
own bladder in a,
she had a bladder cancer,
so they built her a new bladder and a
laboratory and put her own ladder back
in her body.
That is sanely fascinating.
Now,
if they can figure out how to extract a
little bit of brain tissue thing is that
the brain is famously the most
complicated object in the universe.
A bladder is essentially a bag,
you know,
so it's a big leap.
It's a big leap,
but it's not,
um,
you know,
I think it's a leap we will take and you
know,
whether we take,
whether the May maybe a leap we take in
this step wise way where we build
machines down a path that is not at all
analogous to recreating brains,
which allow us to then understand the
brain,
you know,
totally.
I'm in,
in the,
uh,
in the Ray Kurtzweil sentence where we
can upload ourselves,
if that makes any sense.
Um,
but it's a uh,
uh,
I,
I think,
I think information processing is at
bottom what intelligence is,
I think that is,
that is not really up for dispute at
this point that any,
any intelligence system is processing
information and our brains are doing
that.
Um,
and any machine that is going to exhibit
the kind of general intelligence that we
exhibit a and surpass us,
we'll be doing by dent of its hardware
and software.
Something deeply analogous to what our
brains are doing.
But again,
it may not,
we may not get there based on,
um,
directly emulating what our brains are
doing and we may get there before we
actually understand,
understand our brains in a way that
would allow us to emulate it.
It's always very interesting
to me how it seems to be.
There's always a pushes and pulls in,
in life and when you have things that
are as horrific as factory farming and
people are exposed to it,
then there's this rebound and where
people were trying to find a solution.
And I always wonder like if will that be
the first artificial life that we
create?
Like Zombie cows,
like some made,
if we've figured out that meat in the
lab is not good because it has to
actually be moving around for it to be
good for you.
Maybe maybe they'll come up with some
idea to just look,
we're going to make zombies were going
to make livestock that essentially can
just move forward and consume food.
There's no thought whatsoever.
These are zombies.
You can go right up to him and you wave
your hand in front of them.
They don't even move.
Is it okay to kill those and then go
from that to making artificial people?
Because it seems to me that artificial
people,
it's going gonna happen.
I mean it's just a matter of how much
time,
if they're making bladders and then
they're going to start making all sorts
of different tissues with stem cells to
try to replace body parts in Oregon's
and they're,
they're gonna,
they're gonna work their way through an
actual human body.
It's going to happen.
What do you mean?
You mean a,
a brainless person that would be like
spare parts for,
for you?
For sure.
That's an option,
but I think also an artificial human,
I mean might take a thousand years,
but I think if we stay alive,
if human beings rather,
if human beings continue to evolve
technologically within the next hundred
years,
we're going to have artificial people
that are completely see that people.
So we're going to build a biological
person,
hundred percent.
So it's that sense that synthesize
synthesized person,
right?
So it's not,
we're not,
you're not talking about the perfect
robot.
You're talking about an actual person
built up cell by cell,
yet you know,
there's no,
there's no reason why that's not
possible.
And whether or not we would do it is,
is another question.
But yeah,
I had a,
I had this somebody would China where
you're.
Yeah,
well presumably there are limits.
Even in China,
they do an experience.
There's already with human embryos.
I don't know what they're doing in
China.
I believe they are.
I believe they got the goal to have that
dog festival every year.
I see people tweet about China's a big
place though,
can't remember them all in there,
but you know,
um,
uh,
what does that gene splicing software,
Chris Perrysburg to using crisper on a
human fetuses or human embryos.
Right?
So good luck,
good luck world.
Well,
so China is creating super athletes.
There are many issues there.
Mean.
So when you're talking about a changing
the genome and you,
especially when you're talking about
changing the germ line,
you know,
and then it gets passed onto future
generations that,
that has big implications.
But um,
you know,
I don't see why,
I mean this goes to,
it's like the artificial meat
conversation,
so to,
to grow meat in a vat is ethically the
same thing as,
at least my view.
It'd be the same thing as producing a
brainless cow,
right?
The,
so you have the whole cow that you could
slaughter,
but it has no brain.
And so presumably there's no experience
in this animal,
but it is the fully functioning animal,
right?
So let's say you could produce that and
it would be a,
you would produce healthy meat.
It's just a messier.
Presumably you have to feed this thing,
right?
Um,
or,
or I don't know how you get it to eat,
but you know,
you'll say you feed it intravenously.
It all begins to look weirder and
Weirder,
but there is no suffering there because
there's no brain.
Um,
I think we would,
and I think we have decided to bypass
that vision and just go straight to the
VAT and just build it up,
sell,
buy,
and build up only what we need,
which is the meatball or the steak or a.
and so why have the author and the and
the organs that you don't want and the
mess,
and I'm the kind of the energy intensive
aspects of,
of producing whole animal and I think
with like spare parts for humans rather
than create a clone of yourself that has
no brain,
that you just keep in a,
in a vat somewhere in your garage,
uh,
where you can get spare kidneys when you
need them.
Um,
we would just be able to print the
kidneys and that is that because that
gets around a lot of the weirdness,
right?
It'd be weird to have a copy of yourself
that's just a spare parts,
uh,
whereas it wouldn't be weird or at least
in my view,
wouldn't be weird.
It would be fantastic to be able to go
into a hospital when your kidneys are
failing and they just take a cell and
print you a new kidney.
Yeah.
Um,
I think that can be expected.
And that's going to.
I mean,
if it's possible,
it seems like it's going in.
The bladder example you just gave is,
is uh,
what's happening there.
It's amazing.
But I always want to extrapolate things
to some bizarre place a thousand years
from now for some reason because,
uh,
I've,
I've been,
you know,
since I got into Dan Carlin's hardcore
history,
um,
I've,
it really fucked my mind up about how I
think about the past in this way that I
look like a thousand years ago in
comparison to today.
And I,
you know,
I try to think,
well,
how much different will people be a
thousand years from now?
And it probably way more different.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean the,
the fascination that we have with
ancient histories that we,
one of the things obviously we want to
know where we came from,
but also we can kind of see people today
doing similar shit if they were allowed
to.
Like if everything went horribly wrong,
people at their base level of kind of
similar today as they were a thousand
years from now,
one of them might be running for
president.
We can talk about that.
And when I think about the future a
thousand years from now with the way
technology is accelerating and the just
the capacity that we have an ability
change,
things
to change the world,
change physical structures to change
bodies,
to dig into the ground and extract
resources like we're getting better and
better at changing things and
manipulating things that extracting
power from the sun and extracting salt
from the water.
There's like all this bizarre change
technology that's consistently and
constantly going on with people and it
continues to get better when I think
about a thousand years from now and
artificial people and light and this
concept of being able to read each
other's minds and being able to map out
imagery and pass it back and forth from
mind to mind and like a clear
spreadsheet form like a.
What does that movie with Tom Cruise
movie.
Minority report.
Thank you.
Mean that's the way it's on the way.
It's going to be incredibly strange to
be a person.
Yeah.
Whether we will be people in a thousand
years,
I think you would.
Unless we have done something terrible
and knocked ourselves back a thousand
years,
uh,
I think we will decide to change
ourselves in that time in ways that will
make us.
And we,
you know,
they'll be,
there may be many different species.
It's like tattoos,
you know,
you,
you have a bunch of tattoos.
I have none.
You could take that a lot further if you
can just begin really tinkering with
everything,
you know?
Oh yeah.
If you want to get nutty and put the
bolts in your head and shit or just,
just give yourself a,
just fundamentally different genetic,
uh,
abilities,
right?
I mean like if you could just go,
you could become a different species if
you took it far enough.
Maybe that's what the aliens are.
Maybe that's why they all look the same.
Maybe they figured it out like a little.
You got to look alike.
Otherwise you can't appreciate each
other.
When one guy's weird looking,
one guy short,
one guy's got a big nose.
Everybody is so confusing to many
people.
I could hate everybody look exactly the
same.
So the government gets together with all
the people to their planet and they go,
look where we have a problem with this
good looking thing.
Bullshits holding us back.
A lot of people that are stupid,
that getting ahead,
we've got all look the same blank,
emotionless and big giant eyes.
That's it.
They all just went in with a passion for
molesting cattle,
allegedly.
I think that's people.
People are blaming that on the aliens.
I had this guy on my podcast,
David Deutsch.
Have you heard of him?
He was a physicist at Oxford.
Yes.
I have.
Why ever heard of him?
He wrote a book.
He gave it at least one ted talk and
he's written two very good books.
The first came out about 10 years ago,
the fabric of reality and the more
recent one is the beginning of infinity.
And I'm extremely smart guy and I'm very
nice guy.
And He,
um,
he has this thesis which he,
he and I don't totally agree about the
implications going forward for ai,
but the,
um,
he's convinced me that his basic thesis,
which is fascinating,
which is his,
his,
um,
the role
that knowledge plays in our universe or
the potential role that it plays and his
argument is that in any corner of the
universe,
anything that is compatible with the
laws of physics can be done with the
requisite knowledge.
So that as,
uh,
his,
his argument about how deep knowledge
goes and therefore how valuable it is in
the end.
So I'm queuing off your notion of
building an artificial person.
I mean literally,
you know,
sell by salary,
atom by atom,
if that.
There's every reason to believe that's
compatible with the laws of physics.
I mean,
we exist,
right?
So we,
we got built by the happenstance of,
of biology.
Um,
if we had what he calls a,
a universal constructor,
you know,
the smallest machine that could assemble
and the other machine atom by atom,
um,
we could,
we could build anything.
Adam.
Bye Adam.
Right?
And um,
so he has this vision of it like you
could literally go into a,
um,
an area of deep space that is as close
to a vacuum as possible and you know,
begins sweeping up stray hydrogen atoms
and fuse them together and generate
heavier elements.
I mean literally,
so you could start with nothing but
hydrogen,
right and,
and bay with the requisite knowledge,
few bit,
build your own little fusion reactor,
create heavier elements,
and based on those elements,
create the smallest machine that can
then assemble anything else atom by
atom,
uh,
including more of itself.
Right?
And you could start this process of
building anything from a person to,
you know,
if there's something far more advanced
than a person to a planet,
but just anything is made of atoms,
right?
Anything is organized and,
and,
and so the,
the limiting factor in,
in that case is always the knowledge,
right?
So it's either the eliminating factors,
either the laws of physics,
either this can't be done because it's
physically impossible or the knowledge
is what you're lacking.
And I'm given that human beings are
physically impossible.
There should be some knowledge path
whereby you could assemble one atom by
atom,
right?
There's no,
there's no reason why there's no deep
physical reason why that wouldn't be the
case that the reason is it's we don't
know how to do it right.
But presumably a,
it'd be possible for us to,
to acquire that knowledge.
And so the,
the horizon of knowledge is just extends
functionally without limit,
right?
There's just,
there's,
we were nowhere near the place where we
know everything that's knowable,
um,
as,
as witnessed by the fact that we don't
yet know how to build a,
a human atom by atom.
Um,
but when you imagine just the changes
that could occur in our world,
uh,
w w with,
with the frontiers of knowledge
explored,
you know,
10,000
years beyond where we are now.
I mean,
it would be,
we will be unrecognizable to ourselves
and everything would be equivalent to
magic.
You know,
if we could see it now.
And,
and most of human history is not like
that in most of human history.
Have you dropped into any period of
human history?
It was,
for all intents and purposes,
identical to the way it was 500 years
before and 500 years before that.
It's only very recently where you would
drop in and be surprised by the
technology and by the culture and by
the,
what is being done with language and the
consequences of,
of a cooperation among apes like
ourselves.
And um,
so I think that this is one place where
someone like Kurtzweil makes a lot of
sense.
This is,
this is clearly accelerating,
right?
And if we,
and if we don't do something
catastrophic,
uh,
to set us back,
this acceleration is,
is the implication is that the future is
going to be far less recognizable than
it has been in an,
in any other period of human history to
the idea of creating a little machine
that you could shoot out into the
universe and we'll build you a planet.
Yeah.
But the planet is a planet.
It's not the planets obviously big and
the basis for our biosphere and
everything we care about.
But the planet is not what's
complicated.
It's the ecosystem.
It's the life on the planet.
And our own brains being the ultimate
example of,
of,
of that complexity,
but presumably intelligent systems can
become much more complex than that,
right?
There's no reason to think that we are
near the summit of possible
intelligence,
a biological or otherwise.
And I'm a,
yeah,
it's a,
uh,
once you,
once you begin thinking about building
things atom by atom,
then then,
then the,
the future begins to look very weird
because it's,
and automating that process,
right?
Where you have,
and this is,
this is the promise of nanotechnology,
um,
where you have something,
you tiny machines that can,
can both build more of themselves and
more of anything else that would be made
of,
of tiny machines or assemble anything
atom by atom or treat your own body like
a machine that it is and deal with it
atom by atom.
I mean,
that's the possibilities of intervention
in the human body or,
or then virtually limitless.
Um,
so it's a uh,
um,
yeah.
I mean,
that's,
that's where we,
that's where the physical world begins
to look.
Just totally fungible.
One,
you know when you're not talking about
surgery where you're cutting into
someone's head and hoping you know in
very coarse way,
hoping you're not taking out areas of
brain that they need,
but you're talking about actually
repairing A.
I mean if you're talking,
if you can,
if you can tinker with Adam's in a way
that you understand you,
then you're talking about repairing
anything,
you know.
Then in creating anything.
Yeah,
like literally Dr Manhattan style,
build ice condos on Mars.
I mean you could create art with it.
You could do anything with it.
It would just somehow or another have to
be programmed with whatever pattern you
were trying to create.
You could,
you could essentially like make an earth
somewhere else with all the biological
diversity,
water,
even intelligent life that all could be
done through some sort of a machine.
Well it is only one day.
It is at bottom.
Again,
just the information.
It's the knowledge of how to organize
and how to implement it.
So it's like it's analogous to what has
happened in films now where like an
animation and film has gotten good
suddenly.
Right?
Where you can see like,
like if they can animate,
you know,
waving hair and full and flowing water
and it looks pretty damn good at it.
It looked terrible 30 years ago.
Right.
And we just acclimated to look terrible,
but I'm now at you can,
you can really trick the eye.
You can build up scenes of nature where
they're not actually using any
photography of nature to build it up.
It's just,
it's all a confection of,
of ones and zeroes.
Right.
They've just,
they've just,
they've just built it in,
in software like the revenant.
Perfect example,
that giant bear,
the attack Leonardo Dicaprio.
See,
I don't know how that was done,
but I mean,
I,
I had heard that that was all just pure
CGI.
Right.
Then when there was a dude in a costume
that acted it out with them.
But,
uh,
essentially it was just all CGI.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So that,
so that the fact that that's beginning
to look good,
that's just,
I mean,
obviously that's just all surface that
doesn't,
has no implication for the um,
you know,
building a rendering of a bear on film
is not the same thing as building a
bear,
but the fact that we can move so far
into a building,
I'm modeling that kind of complexity
visually.
Just imagine what a superintelligent,
um,
mind could do with a thousand years to,
to work at it.
Right?
And that's,
and that's we're on the cusp of.
And when I say cuss,
you know,
I don't mean five years,
but let's say a century we're on the
cusp of a producing the kind
of technology that will allow for that.
And if we put it into perspective
photography,
I don't believe was even invented until
the early 18 hundreds when it was first.
It says sounds about photographs of
Lincoln.
There are though.
Yeah.
So was that the early 18 hundreds when
he was killed?
I'm 18,
sixties,
five,
10,
65.
So somewhere after that or somewhere
before the other,
they invented photography.
So essentially give or take 10 years,
200 years ago.
That's really amazing.
Oh yeah.
If you stop thinking about the revenue
from 200 years ago,
we couldn't figure out how to get sound
in our movies until that 100 years ago.
That thought right there just actually
just freaked me out with a 200 year
thought.
Like how little 200 years is the hmong
gold days and now 200 years ago they
didn't even have cameras and now they do
and now they have this insane ability to
recreate things like game of thrones,
wolves and dragons and she's riding
around on dragon.
I'm like,
it looks like she's on a dragon.
It doesn't look like old school King
Kong movies,
you know,
you ever tried to watch those videos in.
There are some pleasure in that.
There are awesome.
They're awesome too to to just get into
for fun.
But as far as like visual effects,
what they can do now.
And the idea that it's all been done
over 200 years is just spectacular.
Not just capturing the image,
but then recreating an artificial
version and projecting it,
which is,
you know,
a thousand times more difficult.
And there's
the other feature here of the
compounding power of knowledge and
technology were you.
There are certain gains that are truly
incremental,
whereas just everything is hard.
Won.
Everything is just one percent better
than its predecessor,
but then there are other gains that,
where it's just,
you have created an ability that takes
you,
it seems like a kind of quantum leap
beyond where you were and uh,
where you go from just fundamentally not
being able to,
to do anything in that domain.
And then all of a sudden the domain
opens up totally.
So know flight is an example,
right?
So for the longest time people couldn't
fly and it was obvious that you can't
fly or you're heavier than air and
you're not,
you don't have feathers and you're not.
There's no way to flap your arms fast
enough.
We're never going to fly.
Right?
And then at a certain point flight as
possible and opens this whole domain of
innovation.
Uh,
but the difference between not being
able to flow in,
there's no,
there's no progress you can make on the
ground that it doesn't,
doesn't,
uh,
avail itself of the,
the principles of flight as we now know
them that's going to get you closer.
You know,
you can't jump a little bit higher and
it's just not.
And so there's,
it doesn't matter what you do with your
shoes.
Uh,
so there,
there are,
there are kind of fundamental gains that
opened up a whole dna sequencing is,
is a more recent example where
understanding and having access to the
genome and that's you go from,
uh,
the only way to influence the,
your descendants is to basically make a
good choice in wife,
right,
or husband to you can just create a new
species in a test tube if you wanted to
write and that,
and that's a,
um,
that kind of a compounding power of,
of,
um,
understanding the way things work.
Uh,
the,
you know,
that that's,
I think we're at the beginning of a
process that could look very,
very strange very,
very quickly.
And,
um,
you know,
I think,
uh,
you know,
obviously we were both in good and bad
ways,
but,
um,
there's,
I don't think there's any brake to pull
on this train.
I even,
knowledge and intelligence are the most
valuable things we have,
right?
So we're going to,
we're going to grab more in so far as we
possibly can,
as quickly as we can and the moments of
us deciding not to know things and not
to learn how to do things.
I mean,
those are so few and far between as to
be almost impossible to reference,
right?
I mean that there are moments where
people try to pull the brakes and say
there's the whole conference and I say,
you know,
should we be doing any of this,
but then,
you know,
China does it or,
or threatens to do it.
And um,
we wind up finding some way to do it,
uh,
that,
that we consider ethical.
Um,
so there are things like,
you know,
germline tinkering that we,
as far as I know don't do and have
decided for good reason.
We're not doing.
But um,
is that going to stop people from,
from doing this?
I don't,
I don't think there's any way
they're more worried about actual real
diseases than they are.
Man Made Diseases.
When we went to the CD CCS at disease
control,
CDC,
CDC in Galveston,
I guess that's what it is.
It gets the name of the organization,
but it's a building where they housed
some of the most horrendous viruses and
diseases known demand.
Like they had anthrax in the CDC has,
has a lot of that.
Yeah.
And they have these crazy walls like
thick thick walls and vacuums in the
ceilings and everyone's wearing suits
and they wanted us get in the suits and
I went,
fuck you.
There's no way I'm going in that room.
You did this for one of your shows for a
TV show with Duncan Trussell,
the questions,
everything show because we were talking
about weaponized diseases.
And the CDC was like,
forget all that.
Like the real diseases that are
constantly morphing.
We have to stay on top of like,
that's what we should be terrified of
actual real diseases.
Like no one's shown any ability to
create this stuff that's more fucked up
than what we already have,
but weaponized anthrax and things along
those lines.
Like these Russian guys we talked to,
they were talking about how they had
vats of this stuff.
They had all kinds of crazy diseases
that they had created just in case we
had gotten into some insane mutually
assured destruction,
you know,
a disease spreading thing like they were
down for that.
They were like,
well,
we have to be prepared in case to the
United States.
Does that.
Whoa,
but what their concern is the center for
Disease Control's guys that they were
concerned with.
Things like Ebola,
things morphing things becoming
airborne,
natural things,
new strains of the flu that become
impossible.
Murcia mercy as a terrifying one.
Mercy is one that has a lot of people
scared.
A lot of doctors.
Scared.
Yeah.
It's a medication resistant.
Staph infection that's kills people.
I mean,
it can.
It can absolutely kill people if you
don't jump on it quick and take the most
potent antibiotics we have and even then
it takes a long time.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
it's a,
um,
I actually just tweeted this recently,
I think I said well with some
billionaire with some,
you know,
zero point one percent or develop some
new antibiotics because clearly the
government and the market can't figure
out how to do it and it really is,
it's falling through the cracks in the
government market paradigm where it's
like either the government will do it or
the market will do it,
but neither are doing it because the
market can't.
Bill can't generate the rationale for
developing antibiotics because it's so
costly and you take them,
you know,
what you take with any luck,
you take them,
you know,
once every 10 years for 10 days.
And that's it.
I mean,
it's not,
it's not like Viagra or any of the
antidepressant or any drug that you're
going to take regularly for the rest of
your life.
And um,
so there's no real market incentive to
do it.
And,
or at least not enough of one to spend a
billion dollars developing an
antibiotic.
And the government apparently is not
doing it.
And we're running out of antibiotics.
And this has been in the news a lot
recently,
but we're close to being in a world
where it's as though we don't have
antibiotics,
we're,
we're a superbug away from,
from being in that world and
freaking me out.
Sam Harris.
Oh,
I get freaked out.
So it's super bugs are the big concern,
right?
Do you think about that in Jujitsu?
Do I've gotten staff right?
My friend Ari had it and we were playing
pool and he was limping and I go,
what's going on with your leg?
Man?
He goes,
I got a spider bite.
I go,
let me say.
It pulls up his pants.
You've got staff,
you've got to get a doctor.
And he hasn't even done Jujitsu and
years and I think he got staff again and
I think it's one of those things where
once I guess everyone has it on their
body and when you get an infection then
it spreads and grows and apparently it
can be a reoccurring thing.
So people who get it,
particularly Murcia apparently they can
get it again and it can,
it can get pretty bad.
There was that one fighter who just
died,
I don't think related to that,
but he had these.
Kevin randleman random.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Had the men.
He was that.
That was mercer,
right?
A 100 percent.
Yeah.
He was in the hospital.
What was it was staff.
I don't know if it was mercy,
it could have been just staff that he
ignored for long periods of time,
but it was 100 percent staff and he
died.
I don't know what exactly was the cause
of his death,
but I can't think that that helped him
any.
I mean he had gotten so bad that it had
eaten through his body.
If you,
if you're interested in us for people
online that are listening,
Google,
Kevin Randleman staph infection and
these are horrific photos that look
like,
like something took a bite out of him,
like his under his arm pit.
There's,
I mean I'm like a fist sized chunk of
meat was missing.
Yeah.
It's really,
really scary stuff.
Um,
so yeah,
skin infection.
There it is right there.
You could take a good look deep in see
his muscle tissue.
That is hardcore,
no exaggeration,
so was like a baseball sized hole and
he's got two of them.
He's got another one lower down on his
back,
which is eating its way through his
body.
But that was,
that was a year before he died.
Right?
Or say some years.
Yeah,
it was years before he died.
Um,
but who knows,
like how devastating that might've been.
Like that's a really,
really bad infection and I think that
once your body's that compromise to me,
you're like really close to.
I mean he's a real.
He was a really tough,
strong,
healthy guy.
He was a super athlete so I'm assuming
his body probably fought it off pretty
well.
So it's probably one of the reasons why
you let it go so long.
Probably didn't,
maybe didn't even understand how
dangerous it was or who knows.
Maybe it just jumped on him really
quick.
My Dad's girlfriend just got it on her
face and she was in the hospital for two
weeks and they were afraid it was going
to spread to her brain and it almost
did.
And she's not 100 percent out of the
woods yet,
but she's back home now.
It's just got a little scratch on her
face and it spread into her cheek and
then into heard from her cheek.
She got a little red swelling and then
she couldn't see.
And then she had to go in the hospital.
You got staff chill out.
Heavy antibiotics right away.
Yeah,
that's it.
This is one area that this,
this worries me.
They were,
I mean they're,
they're the bad things we do.
And obviously there's a lot to be
worried about their,
you know,
the stupid wars and the,
and the,
uh,
things that,
it's just obvious that,
that,
um,
you know,
if we could stop creating needless pain
for ourselves or needles conflict,
you know,
that would lead a much nicer life.
But then there are the good things we
neglect to do based on the fact that we
just can't,
we don't have a system where the
incentives are aligned to just make it
easy or,
or,
um,
truly compelling to do them.
And the idea that we are not producing
the next generation of antibiotics as
quickly as possible is just unthinkable
to me.
And yet,
and yet we simply were just hamstrung by
the fact that we have a political and
economic system.
That is where the,
this,
there's no incentive,
right?
Like the government.
We don't want to raise taxes,
right?
We don't,
we're so over committed in the ways we
spend money,
uh,
the public money,
um,
and we're so short sighted that we,
even if we suddenly saved money in one
area,
it's not like we would immediately
directed to this lifesaving necessary
work,
right?
Um,
and the market can't get on top of this.
So it's,
it really would,
it would be like,
you know,
uh,
something that,
you know,
the bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
could do and maybe maybe they're
actually doing this and I just don't
know about it.
They're doing a lot of medical work
obviously.
But,
um,
yeah,
we're talking about some billions of
dollars to just get this.
You get kind of a laser focus on,
on this problem.
But it's such an obvious problem.
And that's really the only thing that's
holding it back.
That's what's going on.
It's not a research issue,
it's just a financial issue.
Well,
I'm sure that the research has to be
done because it's,
you know,
if it was,
if it was totally obvious how to build
the next generation of antibiotics that
would not be vulnerable to having their
efficacy canceled,
you know,
in,
in three years by just just the natural
selection among the microbes,
you know,
someone would do it very,
very cheaply.
But,
uh,
so it's,
I'm,
I'll admit that it,
it's probably not easy to do,
but it's got to be doable and it's super
important to do.
I mean,
when you look at just what cesspools
hospitals have become,
where people come at,
you know,
something like 200,000
people a year die in the US based on
essentially getting,
been getting killed by the machinery of
the hospital right there,
getting killed by their doctors and
nurses.
Most of them,
some of this is,
is um,
you know,
drug overdoses or,
or,
um,
kind of incompetence in,
in dosing or given some of the wrong
medication or whatever,
you know,
200,000
people,
people a year.
Right.
But a lot of it is just doctors not
washing their hands.
Right.
And,
but some of this is also super bugs
where it's like,
it's,
it's the burden on hand washing in a
hospital is higher and higher because
hospitals just or just covered in,
in super germs,
right?
So it's a,
a
cycle haunted house.
You're trying to fix people and around
the house or a bunch of demons that are
trying to kill people you're trying to
fix.
I mean that if look,
obviously it's not,
but if you were a person who was
inclined to believe things like back in
the day before they figured out
microscopes,
I mean,
what else is that other than a demon?
You've got a hospital that's filled with
super bugs.
Where else are they?
There's nowhere else in the hospitals
and Jim were they getting them?
Probably from the hospitals,
but it's just like a haunted house
circle.
Hunter House is trying to kill the
people that live in the house.
It is well,
and it's also just ironic that you go to
the hospital to save your life,
right?
You go when you are,
by definition you're most vulnerable and
you are a and you're in your lane,
your body open to the intrusions of the
place because that means they have to
get.
They have to get into your body to help
you.
Right,
and yet that is the very mechanism
whereby you're getting all this misery
and death imposed on you and it's.
It is as simple as hand washing though
in many of these cases,
right?
It's just doctors and nurses not washing
their hands.
That is insane.
It's so insane to think that that is a
gigantic issue that we have these bugs
that tried to get into your body and
kill you is one.
So that's one area.
I don't know if you ever had the bad
luck to be associated with a Nicu and
neonatal Icu,
but our first daughter who's totally
fine was born five weeks early and had
to be in the Nicu for a week and there
are people who are in the Nicu for
months,
you know,
the babies born at 23 weeks or so.
Um,
and it's just,
it's just a totally heroin.
But,
um,
but also just these incredibly
compassionate,
just amazing places where you just
doctors,
nurses or our total heroes,
but that's a space where you see the
hand washing protocol just exactly as it
needs to be.
You know,
like people are,
they just have,
have understood,
you know,
finally that you,
if you're going to go into the Nicu and
see your baby or be around anyone else's
baby and you are going to wash your
hands in as complete way as,
as,
um,
21st century science.
Understand how to do that.
And it's um,
you know,
it is.
It's almost like the decontamination
zone of,
you know,
Silkwood the nuclear reactor or she get
hosed down.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
my hand washing and the fact that we
can't even do that perfectly.
It's pretty impressive.
Now,
is it a fact that mercer was created by
medications or is that a belief or has
that been proven
that it was created by a resistance to
medications?
It gets stronger?
Yeah.
Well,
no.
Yes,
it's a fact that all of these bugs are
evolving and just by dent of
happenstance,
they are producing a changes in their
genome that leaves them no longer
vulnerable to antibiotic X.
Right.
Um,
so whether it's methicillin or,
or any of it's related antibiotics,
and so that,
this is what antibiotic resistance is.
These,
these,
these bacteria,
um,
uh,
their genomes mutate and unfortunately
with bacteria they also can swap jeans
let laterally across bacterial species.
So it's not like only their descendants
in that line can inherit that,
these genetic changes they can,
they can transfer genetic changes across
bacteria.
So it just,
it optimizes the process.
And again,
this is all blind.
It's not like bacteria want to become
drug resistant,
but some percentage of them in any
generation will tend to become in some
generation,
will become drug resistant and then
that,
then then in the presence of the drug,
they will be selected for,
you know,
if you keep bombarding people with
penicillin,
you will be selecting for the bacteria
that isn't sensitive to penicillin in
those people and say the overuse of
antibiotics and the overuse of
antibiotics in our food chain is also
part of this picture.
Right?
So it's the fact that we are,
I don't know what the percentage is,
but it's,
it's more antibiotic use certainly in
cattle and pigs than in,
uh,
people.
Um,
and the same evolutionary principles are
happening there too.
So,
you know,
so you don't know what,
what we're doing to ourselves.
I,
it can't be good to be using antibiotics
everywhere in agriculture.
And then kind of waiting to see what
happens.
Well,
we know for a fact that we get diseases
mean swine flu,
avian flu like Josie,
no viruses.
Yeah.
And a lot of these are coming out of
these facilities where they're
processing cattle,
pigs,
I mean,
that's another element to it.
So it's just that most of infectious
disease over the ages has been born of
proximity to animals and that's the
result of agriculture.
So the fact that you have people in bird
markets in China who,
you know,
they're,
they're dealing with with chickens and
ducks endlessly in confinement,
and then you've got,
you know,
wild birds flying overhead,
dropping their droppings into that space
and you have,
you just,
and you have a viruses that jump species
from,
from birds to pigs and back again.
And uh,
you know,
some of the stuff only stays in those
animals and,
and doesn't become active and people.
But again,
it's just,
it's just like,
is this evolution is just this endless
lottery,
we'll where it's just,
you just got change and change and
change upon change and um,
something makes the jump in this case
between species and thrives or not based
on the opportunities to thrive.
So you have something that becomes
airborne,
right?
You have,
you have a,
a,
um,
a virus that is absolutely deadly and
people but isn't airborne and is
difficult to contract,
right?
Well,
then it's a,
it's a fairly well behaved,
you know,
it could be scary,
but it's not going to become a global
pandemic,
but then suddenly you could get a
mutation on that virus or that bacteria
that allows it to be,
you know,
aspirated in,
become airborne and a cough and hailed
and big and spread that way.
Well then you have this,
this,
um,
you know,
the possibility of a pandemic and um,
and also the time course of an illness
is,
is irrelevant.
So you have,
you have something which kills you very
quickly and horribly.
Well then that's,
that's the kind of thing that is going
to be harder to spread because people
become suddenly so sick.
They don't,
they're not getting on airplanes,
they're not going to conferences,
they're not starting new relationships.
They're,
they're in bed dying,
right?
So,
but if you had something that had a time
course that you felt great for a month,
but you're yet your infectious,
uh,
and then it kills you will then,
then it's spread is only limited by the
damage you can do in that month of
gallivanting around.
Right?
You know,
so,
um,
it's a,
and again,
these mutations are just happening
spontaneously.
So it's,
it's a,
it really is a,
um,
it's a matter of good and bad luck.
They all have one function.
What killed things they do,
our,
they overcome,
they overcome bodies with their life
form.
They spread.
Will there have met their other
functions.
I mean,
obviously this is all blind and there
was no intention or purpose behind it,
but there are viruses and other
infectious diseases that produce
penicillin know that.
But the produce functions which,
which are behaviorally relevant.
I mean,
so that there was a spread and forgotten
is it?
Um,
so toxoplasmosis it makes mice less
fearful and the presence of cats.
Yeah.
So,
so like say the behavioral changes that
makes them attracted to urine,
right?
They get erect right around cat urine.
So he's into their demise,
so it spreads to cats and there are
theses that that either
infectious diseases that change human
behavior that,
you know,
the depression is the result of
infectious illness that we're not aware
of or um,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
so there's a lot that could be going
wrong with us that we haven't attributed
to viruses and bacteria,
which in fact are,
is at bottom a matter of a virus,
viruses and bacteria.
Actually,
Alzheimer's is,
there was recently a report that
suggested that Alzheimer's is the result
of a brain's immune response to
infection,
infectious illness,
um,
uh,
I think it was bacterial,
um,
this is just in the last week or so that
the,
um,
the plaques associated with Alzheimer's
that you see throughout the brain might
in fact be the remnants of an immune
response to some something having
invaded the cross,
the blood brain barrier.
Um,
so yeah,
so if Alzheimer's is the result of
infectious disease and that,
that is a score that as a,
um,
as a,
uh,
a major problem that would be nice to
solve with the right antibiotic regime.
Could you imagine?
I mean,
that would have been fascinated if that
existed during Reagan's time.
I think it just clear them up because
you remember when he will,
like when when someone publicly starts
to go like that and it's a,
a guy like Ronald Reagan who was an
actor and a president and you see him
starting to lose his grip on his memory.
You knew,
you hear all the reports about it that
it's a particularly disturbing because
it's exhibited,
it means that's the head guy,
you know,
to think that that was just a disease.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I don't remember when that became at all
obvious.
I remember.
I,
I know people were trying to do a kind
of a retrospective analysis of it,
but I don't remember when anyone started
to talk about the possibility that he
was not all there and I don't remember
it happening actually during his
presidency,
but know
you were both young at that point.
So,
um,
I do remember comedians doing jokes
about it.
Yeah.
That's like one of my main points of
references or we'll.
They did have this like weird sort of
out of it grandpa type character that
they would do towards his second run,
you know?
Right.
I don't know if that was years before
they were referencing like when,
when was it all going bad them?
Yeah.
I mean neurologists are very neurologist
can spot neurological illness really
well.
I mean they,
they,
they are walking around seeing
neurological illness all over the place.
I'm sure there were neurologists who
were talking about him long before
anyone else was in those terms.
Well,
there was this old joke that Jimmy
tingled did.
Timmy tingles hilarious political
comedian from Boston.
He had this joke about a Ronald Reagan's
trial where he couldn't remember if he
sold arms to Iran.
It was Mr to President next time you
sell ams to Iran,
jotted down,
make a note,
put it on the refrigerator,
but it was just.
That was his.
That was his excuse when he was in trial
and everybody thought that this is
bullshit.
This is his defense.
He doesn't remember,
and then it started coming out that he
had.
And then the conspiracy theory was he
was always fine.
He was like,
was that guy's name Vincent the Chin
Gigante who'd walk around in a bathrobe
and pretend to be crazy.
I remember that guy,
the mob guy.
No,
there's a famous mob guy who was running
the mob but pretending to be a crazy old
man.
So he would walk around with people.
I forget how they busted him,
but he had it nailed.
He'd walked around the bath robe and
talk to himself and he will put on an
act like going on the street and act
like a crazy person.
And then he would go on walks with like
these capos and tell them,
look,
kill this fucking guy and get me a
million bucks and all that kind of crazy
shit.
But all the while he had an world wire.
Some somehow or another they caught him.
I don't remember exactly how they caught
them,
but everyone knew like they kind of knew
he was doing that.
And so some people were thinking that's
what Reagan was doing.
It was getting closer.
I don't remember what I did,
what I ran in a matter of fact,
I don't remember shit.
I can't think I got a disease.
I can't remember anything and just
started pretending was.
It could be both.
Could be true.
I mean he could only clearly did have
Alzheimer's in the end,
but he could have also been lying.
What if it was a big conspiracy?
There'll be a great movie like how good
of an actor was Ronald Reagan who was
such a good actor to the latter days of
his years.
You've avoided interviews by pretending
to have Alzheimer's.
He felt like that was the only way out,
so it just.
Him and Nancy,
they prepped her lines and when,
when you know he'd go out there to the
public,
he just started acting like he couldn't
remember anything.
Alzheimer's.
Unfortunately it's going to be a bigger
and bigger story.
It's really a baby boomer moment is
coming and it's just going to.
This is something we need a full court
press on to.
Yeah.
If you can find that that's actually a
disease and you can cure that disease.
That's a disease and infectious disease.
Well,
the,
if you ever seen the support stuff on
the Toxoplasma Robertson Stanford,
he's the guy that's like one of the four
forefront researchers and one of the
guys is like really vocal about stress
and.
But he,
yeah,
they were also talking about a direct
proportionate,
a direct relationship between motorcycle
crashes and testing positive for
toxoplasmosis and they felt,
they felt that it might've either
hindered reaction time or loosened
inhibitions to same way it sort of
triggers these mice to go near cats.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what I was referencing.
Yeah.
So I think it's a lot of,
it's speculation,
but there's a lot of strong court.
There's a strong correlation apparently
to motorcycle crashes and that is,
I guess one of his professors had told
him that when he was younger and he
remembered it while they were dealing
with some guy who came into the er
victim of motorcycle crash,
but it kind of makes sense.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the underlying biology of risk avoidance
and,
and not risk seeking is,
that's fairly well conserved in mammals.
It's not like there's a reason why we do
most of our research in things like
mice.
I mean,
it's not a totally analogous brain,
but it's are similar enough to us that,
you know,
doing research on dopamine receptors in
mice is,
allows us to extrapolate to humans and
um,
yeah,
so it's a um,
uh,
it's not,
it wouldn't be a surprise that it's
having an effect on people.
Was it Steve?
Remember I was supposed to bring this up
to you before?
Um,
when you were talking about,
um,
plants and plants having some sort of a
consciousness,
was it steven pinker see if you could
find this?
Who gave a speech where he talked about
how some plants you can actually use
sedatives on them and that some of them
actually produced certain neurochemicals
like dopamine,
if that makes any sense that Steven
pinker.
No,
it didn't make any sense.
Right?
Well,
it was surprised me if pinker said
anything about this,
but I haven't heard anything about it.
I think it was a speech he was given
about something,
but I think it's controversial.
It's one of the reasons why I wanted to
bring it up to you because I had never
heard that before that a plant can
produce.
It was either dopamine or Serotonin in
that somehow or another sedatives would
be,
would be effective on a plant.
I tell it didn't make any sense.
I don't know what effective means.
Uh,
I don't know either.
That's why I waited for you have a plant
that's pretty.
Well,
it's a dated as far as I'm concerned.
I remember as soon as I saw this,
I'm like,
must get this to Sam Harris,
please decipher.
But I actually.
Everything I almost everything I
remember about or that I learned about
plant biology I've forgotten.
So I don't know,
but I'm pretty sure if you can't find it
does not have a brain stuff for Steven
pinker and in plants and consciousness,
but nothing with sedatives specifically
coming up with that.
Maybe it was two.
Maybe I can come.
What's the combined two different
articles they made?
Did the pink one?
I know it was.
What did what pinker say about
plants and consciousness?
Oh,
he was just talking about the surprising
amount of calculations.
I think that was one of the,
uh,
we'd have to read the entire piece,
but I think it was just,
they were just highlighting what we know
so far I've reached the limits of the
human bladder.
Oh,
how dare you this early.
You're too healthy,
man.
Coffee and water.
So what have you found on it,
Jamie?
Not really,
nothing specific about it,
but I did have something earlier that
was kind of interesting.
I'll show it to you here when you was
talking about Ai.
I put up something on minority report
and that pulled me to this article,
which Microsoft has an app that can,
it's actually developed by Hitachi.
It's called predictive crime and that
analytics,
um,
they can predict crimes up to 91 percent
accuracy.
And then there's also already being
enacted at Maryland and Pennsylvania as
of 2013.
They have crime prediction software that
can find out if an inmate that's going
to be released is going to predict or
committed another crime.
And so they're using that to follow
them.
And there's some civil rights people
that are saying like,
you can't do that.
Obviously that's not good.
Hold on,
scroll down just a little bit.
What is it?
Professor Burke says his algorithm could
be used to help set bail amounts and
also decides sentences in the future.
And then I got down to this part in
Chicago.
They're doing something and they have
it.
It's called a heat list in Chicago.
They have 400 residents that are listed
as potential victims and subjects with
the greatest propensity of violence and
they go and knock on their door and tell
them that they're being watched.
And I like I've clicked on this thing
and it's an actual like Chicago
directive from the police.org.
It's a pilot program about going and
tell people that are being watched for
someone might be after you or some shit
like that out.
It's really crazy.
I didn't want to interrupt you guys to
tell you about this,
but
custom notification under the violence
reduction initiative in partnership with
the John Jay College of criminal justice
community team who will serve as
outreach partners when the social
service and community partners show show
him this.
This is crazy.
While the while we were doing this,
Microsoft has this,
these programs scroll up to the top
Jamie.
They revealed an application they think
that can predict crimes in the future
and decide if inmates get parole.
It uses all sorts of data,
public data from twitter,
a closed circuit camera feeds,
public Wifi signals.
There's like an la.
There's all sorts of microphones all
over the place listening for gunshots
and whatnot.
There's this New Light Poles I told you
about that are adding four g
connectivity to the city that obviously
can be added to this probably if they
needed it.
Sure.
Yeah.
That doesn't surprise me at all.
I mean,
I think,
I think that is a,
um,
all of that's come in.
I mean it would just look at just
consumer behavior.
We just just look at how someone
can understand about you based on your
zip code and your last three Netflix
movies you watch to the end and it just
a few other data points,
right?
And then we basically know we can
predict,
you know,
with some horrendous accuracy what
you're going to like a given,
you know,
the menu of options.
I mean,
we can advertise to you,
uh,
with,
with immense precision.
I'm in facebook,
obviously is,
is at the forefront of this,
but uh,
when you talk about,
when you add everything else that's
coming more and more intrusive
technology of the sort we've been
talking about,
it's,
you know,
none of that surprising,
right?
Nothing surprising anymore.
If you had read that 30 years ago,
it would have looked like an article in
the onion here,
right?
You'd be like,
what they're going to have.
This is judge dredd.
This is crazy.
Here's the onion version,
which did just happen,
right?
I think this was Microsoft where they
put out a,
what they were calling an Ai Bot on
twitter.
There was a ai that just became a Hitler
loving sex spot because it was being
turned up by its interaction with people
trolling on twitter.
Did you see the guy who got arrested for
falling asleep inside his tesla when it
was on auto drive?
No.
No,
no,
no.
He got busted.
I don't know if he got arrested.
He got busted though.
They have cameras.
Have camera photos of him rolling
through an intersection,
completely unconscious on his way to
work.
Look at this guy.
Look,
look at this.
The car is driving him and he's asleep
while it's on autopilot.
This is insanity.
This is going to be okay.
Great moment to see.
And I'm sure this is coming where a one
self driving cars become just obviously
the only truly safe alternative.
Then you'll be arrested for the opposite
violation.
You'll be,
you'll be arrested.
W if your hands are on the wheel,
if you're driving a car that is this ape
piloted as opposed to a robot driven.
And that's that say,
um,
maybe we got 30,000
people a year dying every year based on
ape driving.
Um,
so the moment we crack that,
which we're very close to doing,
um,
it's just going to seem you're,
I mean,
you've,
you've got your old muscle cars or
whatever you're into,
it's going to be like,
that's going to be the equivalent of
like,
you know,
celebrate Tory gunfire.
You're going to reserve the right to
like at,
at your wedding
shoot,
shoot your ar 15 and the air and not
care where the bullet lands going to
have to get a licensed,
operate them.
You're going to have to move out of the
big city.
You get to take them to the hills and
unload the amount of,
uh,
of the back of a truck driving for a
very short distance as right monitor how
much a governor on them that they can go
five miles an hour.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean if you look at,
in terms of safety for sure.
And then it seems to be the thing that's
the reoccurring theme,
right?
You give up your privacy for safety.
He,
you give up your,
your ability to drive a car wherever you
want,
whenever you want,
however you want to give that up to give
that up for safety and uh,
people are really reluctant to give up
fun shit like lying and driving their
car fast.
Like those two things.
People are going to have a hard time
with you,
like actually getting into the,
into their mind,
seeing their actual mind and being able
to do that so we can know without a
doubt whether or not someone's guilty or
innocent.
But my question to you is if you could
get inside someone's mind and it was
like that really super.
I'm a suggestive guy that you were
talking about earlier that just
confessed all the horrific demonic
possession stuff and eating babies.
What if it's like getting to that guy's
mind?
What if you can't tell?
Well,
the case that,
that worries me,
and this is perhaps an inept segue to a
politics,
but the,
um,
I mean we're in people's minds.
You get someone talking long enough,
you know their minds.
I mean,
they,
they can only conceal what they're
about.
A only so well right,
and you can because you're a super smart
wizard type.
Just Jamie,
I don't know about.
I don't know if he's a mind reader,
but the question is what will people
care?
You know?
It's like if you,
if you have,
we don't even need a lie detector.
If you have someone who's openly line
right,
who,
who just gets caught in lies again and
again,
you could see it too.
You feel it right,
but people don't seem to care in the
least in a political process.
Now I'm thinking in this case of trump
where you have someone who is in in some
cases line or just changing his mind in
such an incoherent way that it's the
functional equivalent of line.
I mean someone who becomes totally
unpredictable.
He has a stance that is a on Tuesday and
it'll be on Wednesday and when the
discrepancy is pointed out,
he tells her to go fuck yourself.
Right?
So it's just.
No,
there is no accountability to his,
his own states of consciousness that
he's going to be held to.
And the people who love him don't seem
to care.
They actually in it,
as far as I can tell,
I don't know so many of these people
personally,
but from based on,
you know,
social media and seeing the few articles
where someone has explained why they
love trump.
People view this as a kind of this sort
of this dishonesty what is on,
in my view,
both dishonesty and a kind of a kind of
theatrical hucksterism of person who's,
who's pretending to be many things that
he probably isn't.
They see it as a new kind of
authenticity,
right?
Like this guy,
he's just letting it rip.
He doesn't care what is,
what is true.
He doesn't care what your expectations
for coherence are.
He's just going to tell you to fuck
yourself every which way.
And this is the new way of being honest,
right?
This is a new form of integrity.
It's amazing to watch.
It's getting has been.
I'm someone who actually,
I remember on my own podcast,
I think I was talking to Paul Bloom,
this gal psychologist,
who's,
who's great and we had taught.
We got into politics and this is at
least a year ago,
but at that point I said there's no way
we're going to be talking about trump
and a year.
I mean,
this is kind of completely flame out and
I was,
this is a,
I don't tend to make predictions,
but this was a clear moment that I
remember making a prediction,
which is now obviously false.
Um,
but I just couldn't imagine it,
that this was this when people were
going to find this compelling enough to,
for,
for him to be on the,
on the cusp of getting elected.
It's,
it is terrifying.
Have you talked,
have you talked to this issue to death
on your podcast?
Or.
I guess we kind of have.
Well,
I think this is how everybody feels.
Everybody feels like you're supposed to
be like with their person,
whether it's Bernie or whether it's for
Hillary or whether you're a trump
supporter or whatever it is.
Like you have to be all in.
But like if you look at the choices that
we're given,
the.
None of these kids really be described
as ideal.
Like Hillary Clinton.
You could want a woman in the White
House and you want to,
you want to show everyone that a woman
can do that job just as well as a man
and she's got the most experienced and
she certainly has the most experience
dealing with foreign governments and she
certainly has the most experience in
politics,
can make an easy a,
but she's also involved in to criminal
investigations.
She had an observer in her bathroom.
This is squirrely stuff going on like,
no,
she's.
She's terrible in.
Anyways,
she was gay marriage,
Oh,
2013 and then wouldn't admit the change
of mind either.
She's a politician,
she's probably a brilliant woman,
but she's also set in her ways and a
politician,
a politician to the end and part of
being a politician is being a fucking
huckster.
You got to be able to get those people
to see your side and the way you do that
is to talk like this.
You can't talk like a normal person
needs a speech coach.
They all do.
He's terrible to.
Trump's not even good at it and he kicks
their asses.
I know,
but who knows,
but her voice or she,
she has a kind of to use the sexist
trope.
She has a
real for when you were,
when you get her in front of a mic and
there's a crowd and she thinks she's
talking over the crowd,
which she doesn't have to do because
she's in front of a mic.
The sound you get is just,
it's,
she's yelling when she doesn't need to
yell at someone.
Someone has to teach her how to dial
that back.
What you just did is called
mansplaining.
I'm explaining to the men in her who
should,
who should
talk some sense into her,
but she is,
she's a,
she's a bad candidate,
right?
I have no doubt that she's very smart
and she is well informed and she's
qualified and she is absolutely who I
will vote for given the choices.
But you know,
I totally understand people's
reservations with her.
She's a liar.
She's an opportunist.
She's just almost preternaturally and
authentic.
I mean,
she's just like,
she will just focus group every third
sentence and you feel that from her.
Right?
And,
and this is all true,
and yet I also believe that people who
say I've never met her,
but people who know her and have met her
say behind closed doors,
you know,
one on one,
she's incredibly impressive and great.
Um,
but that doesn't translate into her
candidacy.
She probably thinks she has to do it.
Old School,
you know,
I mean,
the way she's doing it,
but she,
I mean,
the thing is,
she's,
when you look at the,
what's worked,
what worries me?
So I went on facebook the other day and
I,
I've said very little about this,
but I've made enough noise is of the
sort that I just made,
that people understand that I've,
that I'm for Clinton,
despite all my reservations about her.
Um,
and when I got on my own facebook page,
which you have to assume is filtered by
the people who are following me on
facebook.
And I already liked me in some sense,
just like a thousand comments of pure
pain.
I mean,
no one loves hillary.
No one,
no one said,
oh,
thank God someone's someone smart is for
Hillary.
Um,
it was all just Bernie people and trump
people flaming me for,
for,
for the most tepid possible endorsement
of Clinton.
All I said was,
listen,
I understand Clinton's a liar and she's,
and she's an opportunist and she's,
um,
I,
I completely get your reservations about
her,
but at least she's a grownup,
right?
And she's going to be the candidate.
It's not going to be sanders for the
moment.
Now is the moment to put your political
idealism behind you.
If you're a sanders person and recognize
that there's a vast difference between
Clinton and trump and no itch.
No,
she's not going to change the system,
but he's also not going to run
civilization off a cliff.
Right?
And I didn't,
I forget how I said it on facebook,
but it was just the most,
it was just,
it really was a lesser of two evils
argument.
And it just,
it was,
um,
it's amazing to see how energized and
passionate people are in defensive trump
and sanders.
And there's almost none of that for
Clinton.
It's like people are just sheepishly
saying that they just divulging that
they will vote for Clinton,
but they are may.
Maybe somewhere that I haven't noticed.
Someone loves absolutely loves Clinton,
but it's just,
it's.
She does not have her defenders the way
these guys do.
Have you seen the man enough to vote for
her campaign?
No.
It's with like hipster dudes with
tattoos and beards that are going to
vote for Hillary.
No,
I hope it's fake
because it's so brilliant.
I hope it's not real.
Is it fake?
Is it God?
It's so good though because it's not
that fake.
It's pretty good.
Like you could almost see.
So wait a minute.
I mean this is not for her,
right?
This is.
No,
no,
no.
It's not bad for just funny.
If someone would like make a joke,
political ad,
you know that you have to be man enough
to vote for Hillary was like,
there's guys out there that would buy
that.
They would.
They would,
they'd do it.
It's a scary time because it doesn't
seem like anybody that you would want to
be president wants to be president and
so we're left with,
all right,
what do you pick?
It's like as if we're going to play the
super bowl with three of the shittiest
teams we can find.
We're just going to go get some drunk
high school kids,
get some inmates with club feet,
which is going to throw whoever we're
going to have the worst game ever and
this was what this game is.
It's not a good game.
This is not a game where you've got like
a John F Kennedy versus a Lyndon Johnson
or it's not.
It's not like like powerful characters.
It's trump I guess is a really powerful
character,
but in more ways like a showman
like what what he's doing.
He's like,
he's putting on a great show and he's
going to win probably because he's
putting on such a great show and people
like a great show,
but I do think.
I think
I'm now have among the people who think
something new witnessed were witnessing
something new with trump.
It's not just the same old thing where
the process is so onerous that it's
selecting for the kind of narcissist or
thick skin person who is willing to
submit to the process.
And then there are many,
most of the good people just aren't
going to put up with this.
I mean,
yes,
there's that too.
But there's,
um,
there's something,
there's a,
it's a moment among the electorate where
it's like,
it's fun.
It's an antistatic.
There's an ant,
there's enough of an antiestablishment
mood and vote now is it happening with,
with sanders to where people just want
to jam a stick in the wheel of the
system just to see what happens.
So it's like,
well,
this is the main gripe against Hillary
really is that she is politics as usual.
She's not going to change the system,
right?
People want to change the system,
but they're not really thinking about
the implications of radically changing
the system.
And in the case of trump,
um,
I may hear or someone who is,
who was advertising his lack of
qualifications for the office in every
way that he can.
It's like he,
like,
there is no,
I mean,
I'm not even,
I'm not even bothered by his racism or
his misogyny or his demagoguery or his
bully.
I mean,
all of that I'm willing to to guess is
an act right.
That he's decided that that's somehow
pandering his base and he's actually,
in truth,
he doesn't have a racist bone in his
body.
Say I'm willing to,
to believe that amount.
I don't know why I would think that's
plausible,
but it's,
it's,
uh,
you know,
I have a hunch that he's far more
liberal than he seems and it's just
pandering.
But the thing that,
that,
um,
can't be true is there's no way he's
actually brilliant and well informed
about all the issues and is saying the
things he's saying.
He's not pretending to be as uninformed
and as incoherent and as irresponsible
as he's seeming.
Um,
because you wouldn't withhold
information.
It will make you a better leader.
Well,
it's just,
it's.
Yeah.
And it's just,
well,
it's just the vacuous snus of his
speech.
It's like he's,
he'll say that he'll say the same thing
three times in a row.
And it was meaningless the first time,
right?
He'll say,
it's going to be amazing.
It's going to be very,
very amazing.
Trust me,
it's going to be so amazing.
And he does.
He does this with everything.
If you look at the transcripts of his
speeches and the fact that he can't,
he has never met so far as I've seen.
He has never once strung together a
string of sentences that was even
interesting.
Right?
But he'd be like,
he's,
he's never.
He just,
there's never a moment where I read or I
say,
Oh,
this guy is smarter and better informed
than I realized at that moment.
Never comes where I keep expecting to
see that happen.
Um,
and it's a little bit like my head is
this image of like imagine you have an
urn,
right?
And you just keep pulling things out of
it and all you pull out of it as junk,
right.
You know,
you pull,
you know,
chicken bones and broken marbles and gum
and,
and it's,
it's still possible that you,
that if you root around in that earn
long enough,
you're going to find the hope diamond.
I mean,
in each round that you pull something
out that really has no logical
implication for the next thing you might
pull out of the earn,
but mines aren't like that when I see
what this guy says,
he does not say anything that a well
informed,
intelligent person would say.
And it's just.
And,
and ideas are connected,
right?
It's like you can't,
um,
you can't fake this stuff.
You can't fake,
you can't fake being this,
this uninformed and you can't fake being
really well informed and he's just,
I mean,
we just look at one policy that he wants
a,
the,
the um,
uh,
you know,
the rounding up of illegal aliens,
right around 11 million illegal aliens.
Now this,
this gets stated as,
yeah,
we're going to round them up and send
them back to Mexico.
And what worries me is no one seems to
care about that.
If you just look at the implications of
doing this,
it has this one policy.
Claim alone is so impractical and
unethical.
It's just,
what are we talking about here?
You're talking like your gardener,
your housekeeper or the person who works
at the carwash.
The person who picks the vegetables that
you buy in the market is going to get a
knock on the door in the middle of the
night by the Gestapo and get sent back
to.
The vast majority of these people are,
are,
are law abiding.
People are just working at jobs that
Americans by and large don't want to do.
And many of them have kids who were
American citizens,
right?
And somebody to say someone's got kids
under the age of 10 who are American
citizens and what you're going to send
that person back to Mexico and you're
going to do this by the hundreds of
thousands and millions.
It's just that one point alone held in
isolation from all of the other things
he said.
The crazy things like climate change is
a hoax concocted by the Chinese to
destroy our manufacturing base.
And,
um,
you know,
the,
the fact that he likes Putin,
I mean,
everything else he said,
write this one policy.
Claim alone should be enough to
disqualify a person's candidacy.
It's so crazy with the moment you,
you look at it,
um,
and yet no one seems to care.
In fact,
it's just,
it's just more energizing to the people
who already like it.
I know that he said that he wanted to
build a wall,
but I didn't know that said that he
wanted to get rid of the illegal aliens,
round them up and around them up and do
one with them,
send them back to their country.
It's so crazy.
It's such a crazy idea and it's so
brutal.
The idea that.
I mean,
it's like a,
it's a sub human thing.
The only reason why people would come to
America is because they felt they felt
like it would make their life better.
So people take a big risk.
It's not,
there's not an easy way to do it.
If you're poor,
you don't have any qualifications for
any unusual job.
I mean you're trying to get across to
Mexico,
but everybody who does it does it
because they want to improve their life.
You know,
and the idea that one group of people
shouldn't be able to do it in one group
should just because they were born on
the right side of some strange line that
is only a couple hundred years old,
but I actually,
no,
I'll go further in meeting him in the
middle.
Whereas.
So,
so I think we should be able to defend
our borders.
Right?
So it is.
I don't have a good argument for having
a porous border that we can't figure out
how to defend and we don't know who's
coming into the country.
Right.
So,
so I think building the wall is almost
certainly a stupid idea among his many
stupid ideas,
but I think it would be great to know
who's coming into the country and have
a,
a purely legal process by which that
happened.
I mean,
ultimately that's got to be the goal,
right?
Um,
and we are in perfectly doing that.
And um,
so I don't have an argument for open
borders or porous borders,
but the question is what do you do with
11 or 12 million people who are already
doing jobs we want them to do that help
our society and the vast majority of
them are law abiding people who as you
say,
or just trying to have better lives,
the idea that you're going to break up
families and send people back by the
millions and the idea that you're going
to devote your law enforcement resources
to doing this when you have real
terrorism and real crime to,
to,
to deal with is just pure insanity.
Right?
And,
and also totally unethical and yet he
doesn't get any points docked for this
aspiration.
I mean,
it's just,
it's one of the things around which
people are rallying.
But the climate change thing is also
insane and dangerous.
He was a birther,
right?
Yeah,
right.
He was one of the original birthers.
He was saying that Obama's birth
certificate was bullshit and he was born
in Kenya,
right?
Wasn't he one of those guys?
Oh yeah,
he was,
he was.
Um,
I would love it if funding that for
awhile.
Yeah,
I would love to if he got in the office
and just said,
listen folks,
I am nothing like this person.
I pretended to be to win the presidency.
I just wanted to show you that you can
be manipulated and get it together.
Then peaches,
punk to all going to hire some people
who actually know how to run things and
we'll see.
That's the,
the,
the smart people who are voting for him
think.
And this is,
I think an actual,
a crazy position.
But they think that he is just pandering
to the idiots who he needs to pander to
to get into office.
So He's,
he's not disavowing the white
supremacists votes with the,
the Alacrity that you would if you were
a decent human being and you found out
that David Dukes who supported you,
um,
uh,
because he needs to.
He just,
he needs those votes and he knows that,
that most of the people in his base
aren't going to care and he can just
kind of move on in the news cycle.
And he's doing this on all these issues.
Where he looked,
where smart people see that he looks
like a buffoon and,
and,
and they are treating him as a,
the people who don't like him or
treating him as a comic figure who he
can't really believe that stuff.
He's not really,
he's too sophisticated to really believe
that stuff.
So He's just pandering.
Um,
I mean,
one is that people aren't seeing if
that's true,
just how unethical and weird that is
right here.
The guy has no compunction about lying
and demonizing people.
It's like,
well,
let's say he,
let's say he thinks that that Clinton
really isn't guilty,
but Bill Clinton isn't really guilty of,
of a rape.
Right?
And now he's calling him a rapist.
Right now,
at the time he was saying he wasn't a
rapist and he's just being defamed.
And this is outrageous.
He was taking,
he was taking the side of a friend who,
you know,
he invited to his wedding,
but now he's,
he's calling him a rapist,
right?
A sexual Predator who's,
who've harmed women's rights more than
anyone.
I'm so,
which is true,
right?
So there's,
there's no version of the truth here
that makes trump look at all acceptable
as a person.
It's like either he knew he was a rapist
and was defending him because he was
just cozying up to power at that point,
right.
Didn't care that he's a rapist or now
he,
he knows he still,
he's still the guy who thinks he wasn't
a rapist,
but now he's just for purely
opportunistic reasons.
He's,
he's,
he's willing to call a guy a rapist who
he knows isn't,
um,
they're both horrible.
Right?
And it's not like there's new evidence
has come forward in the intervening
years that would have changed his mind
about what happened in,
in Clinton's presidency.
So he's um,
uh,
but I think people think that he's got
to be much more sophisticated than he is
and that if he got into office,
he would just be a totally sober and
presidential person.
There's just no reason to believe that.
I mean that if he thinks climate change
is a hoax and that we should pull out of
the Paris accord,
then we should ramp up coal production
and when to bring back the coal jobs.
I mean,
this is what he's saying,
right?
There is no reason to think he doesn't
believe this at this point.
Um,
that's just,
it is a disastrous thing for a president
to think.
The only,
um,
fascinating versions of this that I've
been hearing from people that I respect
are that the idea that he is like,
uh,
the political version of the asteroid
that killed the dinosaurs.
Like he's going to come down and smash
it and it's going to be so chaotic that
they're going to be forced to reform the
system and people are going to respond
in turn,
like the way people responding against
factory farming and more people are
going Vegan,
like that kind of thing.
They're going to see it and they get to
respond in turn that has such a.
So it's like he's going to toss the
applecart up in the air.
It's just going to fuck this whole goofy
system up.
And then we'll be able to rebuild after
trump has dismantled all the,
all the different special interest
groups and lobbyists and all the people
that we really would like to get out of
the system.
We really don't like the.
The.
The fact that they're such insane
amounts of influence that big
corporations and lobbyists have had on
the way.
Laws get passed that.
This might be the way to do it.
You have some wild man.
Everyone's fired.
You have fired.
You have fire Jetson.
It's like a character.
Like he's coming in.
His hair's plastic is all fired up.
He's a billionaire.
He made all his own money,
sort of.
Dad gave him some money,
but he turned it into a lot of money.
Point being,
he doesn't need anybody to.
My truth is he's probably lying about
the amount of money has to.
Is He is,
but he's a baller for sure though,
right?
At the very least,
he's got to be worth some cash.
Yeah.
I made.
It could be a big difference between
what he's claiming and what is in fact
true.
But he's.
He's a many pieces here.
When people assume that because he's a
successful businessman,
he must understand the economy,
right?
Which is no necessary connection there,
There's a lot of rich who are totally
confused about economics.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
most economists don't have a lot of
money,
so there's no real connection there.
But the,
the uh,
I mean,
so what you're describing is a kind of
just random,
like,
like you're just,
let's just,
let's just smash the window and then see
what happens.
Right?
Like I'm going to light a fire to this
place and see what happens.
And that's,
um,
it almost any process by which you would
change the system is more intelligent
than that,
you know,
and,
and it's also not value in how much harm
one bad president could do,
right?
Like,
there's no,
I think even,
I haven't tested this,
but I'm imagining that even trump
supporters would answer this question
the way I would hope,
which is like if I had a crystal ball
that could tell you,
I can't tell you who's going to be
president,
but it tells you how it works out for
the next president.
So like if I,
if I look in the crystal ball and it
says the next president of United States
is a disaster,
right?
Just,
it's like the worst president we've ever
had.
You just think of,
you know,
just just failures of governance and,
and the toxic influence of narcissism
and Hubris that comes along just like
once every thousand years.
Right?
Just,
just disaster.
I think,
you know,
even if you're a trump supporter,
which candidate that was like only trump
is,
is likely to screw things up that badly.
It's not a Clinton is going to,
is going to be almost perfectly
predictable.
She's going to be a politician.
She's going to,
she's going to be basically centrist on
a lot of the,
on foreign policy and domestic policy.
You know,
she's going to be liberal on social
issues.
Um,
she is not going to try to dismantle
NATO and to get into a war with North
Korea or get into an alliance with Putin
or image.
She's not going to do something insane.
Um,
and so alliance with Putin.
Yeah,
he,
he said basically only favorable things
about Putin.
They're homeless,
they're tight.
So she get get,
uh,
hopefully we'll,
we'll see pictures with both of them on
horseback,
shirtless and a golf shirt on.
He'll probably keep my shirt on.
I don't see them as being the shirtless
guy.
I know.
Yeah.
When,
when you just look at the landscape
between Bernie and Hillary in him and
uh,
you know,
to me it looks like the last gasps of a
dying system.
So that's representative government
system for a lot of people are saying
that things like that,
but they're not hearing just nihilistic.
That is if.
True.
Right,
right.
It's like,
oh,
well we,
there's so much stuff we have to get
right.
And there's so much.
And the only tool to get it right is,
is having your,
your mind actually understand what's
going on in the world and how to
manipulate the world in the direction
you want it to go.
So you have to understand like what,
whether or not climate change is true,
your beliefs about it have to be
representative of that truth.
Right?
So like,
if let's say,
you know,
let's say it's,
let's say I'm mistaken and there's,
you know,
there is no human caused climate change
is not a problem and every moment spent
thinking about it,
worrying about it,
correcting for it is just a waste of
time.
That's just throwing out,
you know,
the wealth of the world,
right?
That would be a terrible thing,
So it really matters who's right about
that and the fact that we have a
president or a candidate who is coming
in saying,
uh,
this is all bullshit,
you know,
in,
in defiance of all of the science,
um,
is,
uh,
and it's,
it's true,
but it's on every other part of the
problem.
He doesn't know anything about it.
I guarantee you he doesn't know the
difference between Sunni and Shia Islam
or which countries are Sunni
predominantly in which are Shia
predominantly.
And I mean,
I'm sure he's going to do,
I don't know when he's gonna Cram for
this final exam,
I'm sure before one of those debates
he's going to get,
you know,
someone's gonna sit down with him and
give him some bullet points.
He's got to have in his head,
but his head is just not in this game.
It's never been in this game.
It's obvious from everything he says and
that's what that is.
Something you can't say about Clinton.
Right?
For all of her flaws as a person,
I don't care how much you hate her as a
person.
She understands what's going on in the
world and that that difference is so
enormous.
Forget about all the other character
flaws of this guy who is just obviously
going to.
I mean he's,
but are we attached to much to this idea
of one person being the figurehead,
figure it out.
Someone has to be the decider.
If we all woke up today,
if everybody woke up and there was just
no government,
there was nothing more.
All just what happened?
I don't know,
but we've got to figure out how to run
this thing.
Well,
we had no,
no previous understanding of government.
Would you think anybody would say,
we need one dude to just run this whole
giant continent filled with 300 million
people who are most likely if we woke up
and we had technology like we have
today,
we have the ability to communicate like
we have today with social media and
whatever.
We would probably say we need to like
figure this out amongst each other and
find the people that have the most
qualified for each one of these
positions and we'll start running our
government that way.
Well that that's what we're attempting
to do,
but it's just,
and I totally agree with you that it is
astonishing that out of a nation of 300
million people,
these are the choices you would think
you would think would be starting from
your base.
That you know,
your zero set point of just,
you know,
now we're going to reboot civilization.
Um,
you would think that if you had this
kind of process,
each candidate would be more impressive
than the next man.
You'd be like,
I can't believe each,
each person who came to the podium like
James,
oh yeah.
It'd be like,
it'd be like the dunk contest,
you know,
for the NBA and be like,
oh my God,
I could just,
when you thought you saw the best dunk
in your life,
you know,
the next guy comes along and it would be
that.
It would be that on every topic,
right?
It'd be like you'd be talking about the
science of climate change.
You'd be talking about the actual
dynamics of the war on terror,
so topics that seem to have no
relationship where you would have to be.
You'd be amazed at anyone could be an
expert in all of them.
You would find someone who is an expert,
a functional expert in all of them.
Agility,
winter dude.
Yeah,
yeah.
But,
but someone who also ethically wise who
wasn't just wasn't obviously an asshole.
Um,
and who,
uh,
who,
who had a,
a mature relationship to change in his
or her mind.
Right?
So,
like the whole bit about flip flopping
and,
and not,
um,
you know,
being like someone who could honestly
represent changes of mind in,
in,
across a political career.
Right.
You know,
it's nowhere written.
That is a good thing to believe today,
what you believe 20 years ago.
In fact,
if they do that on every topic,
it means basically you haven't been in
dialogue with the world,
but there's something,
it's so taboo to change your mind that
either you have to lie about it or you
have to pretend it was a,
it was always that way.
Or um,
it's just a,
uh,
the system,
the system is,
is broken in that respect,
but given the choices,
you know,
and when you have a choice between
someone who is for all her flaws,
been in the game for long enough to be
really well informed and capable of
compromise and capable of,
uh,
not just,
just breaking the entire machine and you
have someone who's just,
he could just got stepped off the set of
his reality TV show and then the lied
about everything and,
uh,
and elbowed his way onto your television
set and never left because,
you know,
CNN couldn't figure out how to give the
mic to someone else.
Um,
it's,
uh,
it's amazing.
Well,
he's a product of attention because they
realize that there's the heated race,
right?
The heated race,
this guy was really famous and in a
heated race,
this guy would say some crazy stuff and
so they would tune into him so everybody
had to do an intro.
So because of him saying crazy stuff,
he accelerated the amount they were
talking about them.
So they're constantly talking about him
and barely talking other people and.
But he's created
warm hole in our political process now
where there's nothing so crazy that
could disqualify him among the people
who like him to so he can just keep it
just like nuclear bombs of craziness
that,
that the press can't ignore that the,
every time they think,
okay,
this is the crazy thing he said that's
going to harm his candidacy,
so let's shine a light on it.
It just helps him,
you know,
he could,
he could get on twitter right now and
say,
you know who I'd like to fuck,
I'd like to fuck Nikki Minaj and,
and it would work for him.
It was work for them.
You would see a use a tweet storm of a
billion people who say,
I'd like to fuck Nikki Minaj to go get
her,
and it's insanity.
That's where we are.
But in a sense,
if w w we,
we do admit this is a fucked up system.
It's not ideal.
It should definitely be reworked and
it's so hard to rework.
Wouldn't the best way to rework it?
A trump asteroid just slams right into
the White House.
Boom,
blows the whole thing sky high.
Who knows what terrible things have to
happen,
but maybe that would be enough.
The thing is we have those,
those assets,
troy's are coming anyway.
So when you look at like nine slash 11
was an asteroid,
right?
So it's like a or,
or a superbug that,
that becomes a pandemic,
that these are things that are coming
and we need people who are in touch
with,
with reality to deal with them.
Right?
So like the moment someone advertises
their,
not only their ignorance,
but the fact that they don't care,
that they're ignorant and they do that
this again and again,
they keep doubling down that person.
It's like if you put that person at the
helm,
what you have done is basically put
chaos at the hill,
right?
It's like,
like,
this is,
this person's going to believe whatever
he believes,
regardless of the information coming in
and regardless of the consequences,
that's just.
I mean,
it's,
it's worse than having no one in charge.
I mean,
because you've,
you've,
you've put the power in this person's
hands,
right?
So this,
this person is,
everything has to go through this node
in the network that is just like an
information scrambling device.
Right?
So like,
know how Matt,
no matter how good the information is
coming in,
you have everything that you've got a
bottleneck here which just screws up the
signal,
right?
Um,
that's what you're doing.
If you're,
if you're,
if you're hiring someone like this,
who I'm,
I mean,
yeah,
in the best case,
you're,
what you stated earlier would in fact be
true,
which,
uh,
he'll,
he'll get into the oval office and even
he will be scared about,
of the prospect that he is now
running the better part of human
civilization.
And he will hire the best people,
some semblance of the best people he can
get access to and say,
tell me how to not screw this up.
And that will be a.
and then it'll.
Then it'll essentially be business as
usual.
Right?
Insofar as you've hired,
the best people will be people.
People who are deeply in this game
already,
right?
You know,
he'll defer to the generals when it
comes time to make
wore the being real.
Really pragmatic about how they pick
politicians and how they push certain
people and decided I had to push others.
Do you think that something like trump
completely changes how they move forward
now they realized that this can happen.
Like now that you see that people are so
goofy were so wwe eat out that you can
get this guy,
you know,
I mean this is,
this is where we're at.
We're,
we've got a guy.
I told them the wall just got 10 foot.
Hi.
Everybody gets crazy.
Like how could you say that?
Yeah.
Once they realize that that's possible.
How long before you get like some
motivational speaker type dudes?
Long before they started jumping in
there,
Tony Robbins had presence.
That's what we have.
I mean,
that's.
Oh,
this is way worse than Tony Robbins for
president.
Yeah.
Way.
Way more positive dude.
Yeah.
But I'd vote for him.
You know,
Tony Robbins,
positive guy.
No,
that's not what I mean.
I mean,
but that sort of ability to excite
people get like one of those
motivational speaker dudes,
those guys.
Whereas a lot of yoga pants and he's
gonna.
He's gonna be the next president is
going to get us in shape.
Getting be a reality show.
America is a reality show where there
were awesome.
We're the best.
Did you see this press conference he
held?
I think it was yesterday.
I did not know.
There was a very funny moment where
there was one journalist.
I didn't recognize who it was,
who gets hooked.
So trump was being very combative with
the press pool and he was,
he was basically,
you know,
shouting them down,
not answering any of the questions.
And one journalist,
just a gas said,
is this what is going to be like when
your president and is this,
how is this what is going to be like to
be in the White House press corps and
deal with you?
And uh,
and he said,
yes,
this is exactly what's gonna be like.
And,
but you,
you could just see that like the
journalists,
like they,
they,
they turn the camera on the room,
a journalists and they,
they are astonished by what is happening
here.
Like they don't know they're
participating in this process and in,
in,
in some sense they've created this
process.
Um,
but,
uh,
no,
not all of you.
Many of you are enough of us.
Is this what you do?
Is it,
is this what it's going to be like
covering you if your president?
Yeah,
let,
let me just have this kind of take
charge in the restroom.
Okay.
Yeah,
it is going to be like this David.
If the press writes false stores like
they did with this because you know,
half of you are amazed that I raised all
this money.
If the press writes false start as like
they did where I want it to keep a low
profile,
I didn't want the credit for raising all
this money for the vets.
I wasn't looking for the credit and by
the way more money is coming in.
I wasn't looking for the credit but I
had no choice but to do this because the
press was saying I didn't raise any
money.
Them not only that,
I raise it,
much of it was given a long time ago and
there is a vetting process and I think
you understand that,
but when I raised almost $6,000,000
in probably in the end were raised more
than six because more is going to come
in and is coming in.
But when I raised five point 6 million,
as of today,
Maura's coming in and I.
and,
and this is going to phenomenal groups
and have many of these people vetting
the people that are getting the money.
And
you played the moment I was referring to
probably live here.
Is it a case where he's probably almost
certainly line about his history of
giving to veterans affairs and says he,
he gave money very recently after people
started fishing around to see if he
actually had given the money that he
claimed to have given to,
to veterans.
Um,
but,
uh,
I mean this is,
what's difficult about this is that,
I mean the pr,
yes,
there are the presses highly imperfect
and there and also partisan and there
are false stories and there are
exaggerations and they screw people
over.
Yes.
And there are reasons to not trust the
press from time to time,
but in this case you have a,
someone who there is no amount of fact
checking and discuss information of his
statements that,
that forces him to ever acknowledge
anything that he's done wrong and the
and the lack of acknowledgement that he
pays no price for it among,
among the people who like him.
And so the press is powerless and then,
and then.
But the net result of like a,
of a press conference like this,
if you were a trump's follower is he
just showed how biased and and petty the
press pool is.
And the press do need to just be beaten
up by a strong man who,
who's not going to stand for their
bullshit,
but it's a,
it's a,
um,
I mean it's unbecoming at the very
least,
that kind of communication.
It's kind of unbecoming that person that
we expect.
And that's pretty mild.
No,
that's my.
Compared to his leg,
his parody of the,
of the,
um,
the disabled reporter.
Who He.
I mean,
you saw that bit where he did like a,
a,
um,
a cerebral palsy invitation at,
at one of his speeches.
He was the.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He was interviewed by.
I don't happen to know who the reporter
was.
Oh,
he was making.
He was making fun of somebody with
cerebral palsy.
He's done so many things that you could,
that you would think would be
fundamentally canceling of a person's
political aspirations.
Like,
like you,
you can't even cut marco rubio
pretending to be like a.
just goofy on someone's cerebral palsy,
added at one of his campaign events.
Oh,
trend,
right.
One of the things that some Ted Cruz was
that video of him
with his family,
the outtakes where they like,
oh,
you didn't see it.
It's a gem.
It's spectacular.
It's him with his mom and he's like,
my mom prays for me often for hours
everyday,
and she like her.
She looks.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
You're talking about four hours every
day?
No,
I don't.
He can't even say that.
And so they have all these really
awkward moments like,
okay,
I'm going to go in for a hug.
I'm going to say I love you.
It's all.
It's all like weirdly mapped out and
that got online and people were like,
Oh,
Christ,
okay.
See this is.
This is a bad game.
Like you're not even good at this game.
This is you.
You're terrible at this game.
Yeah.
He was objectively terrible.
Well,
that's his.
That's trumped competition.
Well,
the thing that would think about
crews that never even got out,
which was the reason to be scared about
a Cruz presidency,
was his level of religious craziness.
I mean,
no one was even pushing on that because
there was just enough to push on before
and got to that door and then you have
to hold onto those weapons.
But I mean,
it hadn't been for had crews been the
nominee,
it would have been all about religion.
What's,
what's odd is that that's not a handicap
in 2016 that you can have that and
people consider it an asset.
Well,
the one thing that's surprising and
actually hopeful in trump's candidacy is
the fact that he has,
he has dissected out the religious,
social conservative component of,
of the Republican Party.
So like the evangelicals,
for the most part,
we're going for trump over crews when it
was pretty clear to them that trump was
just pretending to be religious.
And I mean,
so it's a.
trump gave one speech at know I think
Liberty University where he spoke.
He said Corinthians two,
um,
and you know,
that's not the way any bible reader
would,
would speak about the second
Corinthians.
How would you say it?
Second Corinthians,
that's how you would say,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so,
so he,
so he said Corinthians two as like,
as though this is something that he just
opened every,
every night before he went to sleep.
And so it's clear that it was clear to
them that he's,
that he is just,
just mining the language,
you know,
or,
or I'm impersonating a person to faith
and um,
but they don't care really as long as he
does it.
And that's,
that is,
you know,
if you're gonna look for a silver lining
to this,
it,
it shows that it's not,
it's they just want a space where their
religious convictions are not under
attack and they don't really care that
the person in charge share them.
Just usually,
if you pretend to share them,
that's good enough.
And that's,
um,
that's better than actually carrying
that.
This person really believe in the
rapture or anything else that is quite
obviously crazy.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
so I don't think any Christian who was
voting for trump thinks they'll say,
I'm not going to judge another man's
faith,
right?
Or I'm not.
Who am I to say what's really in his
heart?
Right?
They'll say that,
but he's just given you,
if you've been paying attention to who
he's been and,
and if you just look at how he talks
about these things,
um,
I don't think he's falling any,
any Christian that.
So I think they're willing to vote for
someone for it now,
for other reasons that are fairly
depressing in their own right.
They're willing to vote for someone
who's,
who doesn't really play the game the way
they do.
You have to believe in God to be
President Two thousand 16.
Right?
Wouldn't you?
Wouldn't you say that?
That has to pretend to believe in God.
But I think with trump,
I think,
I think the pretense is,
is obvious enough that I don't think
he's fooling the better part of the
people who were voting for him who,
who would,
who would say they care about a person
of faith being in the White House.
So I,
if anything,
he might be in one thing he might be
breaking is the barrier on having an
atheist president because I think he,
you know,
it's just nobody,
nobody thinks he is a person to faith.
I don't think anyone really thinks that.
So he's perfect.
He's made,
it might be our first atheist president
who would help us in that,
in that regard as well.
Another trump media right into the White
House.
I'm starting to sound like a trump
supporter.
Occasionally an asteroid does something
good.
Who would be the ideal president?
I mean like what,
what kind of a person?
I mean it would probably be a person who
doesn't seek attention.
Probably be a person that.
Well,
I don't think it could be that.
I mean the,
the,
the process is even,
even an optimized process will be,
um,
will,
will require enough sacrifice of what
ordinary people want.
Most of the time that it will be an
unusual personality who has to get
promoted and you will,
you will be on some metric be.
I mean,
it's almost by definition narcissistic
to think that you should be in this role
right?
Who are you to think that you should be
running a civilization at this moment in
human history?
Um,
and to,
for you to be on it,
for you to honestly stand at the podium
and say,
I'm the guy or the woman like,
I am the most qualified,
I should be doing this.
Right.
I can help.
Um,
you know,
if you,
if you're going to scrutinize the kind
of personality that could give rise to
those opinions,
it's not you.
Yeah.
There's some dials you would probably
want to chain tweak if you,
if you had to be married to this person
or if it's not an optimal personality.
So there's going to be kind of pathology
of,
of power seeking that might be just
intrinsic to it.
But,
um,
you want someone who is actually wise
ethically.
I mean,
just,
you're just trying to map that onto
trump,
right?
Just,
he's.
Imagine someone saying thing I like
about trump is that he is so deeply
ethical and wise,
right?
It's just,
it does not.
I mean,
it's like saying it's because of his
hair looks so natural.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's,
there's no,
um,
it,
it is the antithesis of what he is,
right?
Um,
the,
the thing I like about trump is that he
is so well informed about the way the
world works and where he's not informed,
he recognizes his ignorance so quickly
and he remedies it as fast as possible.
He do know he seeks out the best
experts,
defers to them.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
he's just,
he's mindful of the limits of his
knowledge.
Seo As,
as he is about his expertise and his
expertise is vast.
Right.
You'd want to be able to say that about
a president.
You could not begin to say that about
trump,
right?
You could probably say that.
Honestly.
You could probably say that about
Clinton,
right?
Like,
for,
for all her defects,
she's very knowledgeable and I'm sure
she will just try it.
Where she,
where she doesn't feel like she's got
the knowledge he's going to try to go
to,
go to the source of the knowledge.
Right.
Just grab the best experts you can find.
Um,
I think she,
I think she will be as aware as you are.
I would be of the consequences of not
knowing what's going on,
right?
She's just going to want to find out
what's going on.
Whereas this,
I mean all trump has advertised about
himself is that he thinks that bluster
and banality and bullying will win in
every situation.
It's just like it's just attitude.
He's the guy is the guy is winging it
and it could not be more obvious that
this guy is winging it on every level.
I mean like it's just,
it is.
It is,
isn't it?
There there'd be no way for him to
signal the fact that he's winging it
more clearly than he is with everything
he's doing and and yet there's no
penalty.
Do you think it's possible that in this
age of information,
the way we can communicate with each
other that we're going to experience
these cycles,
these waves,
these in and outs,
these high and low tides of really smart
presidents and really stupid president
and we just people revolt and there's
just.
It's so easy to stay alive.
It's plenty of students who fill out
there and so they're only willing to
vote for other dme folks,
so the other dme folks get into
position.
They send out the frequency that only
the dummies here and everybody else is
going,
what the fuck is everybody voting for
this guy for what is happening,
and then it makes the smart people
rebound and for years and challenge
themselves a new because they they need
some of an enemy to rally against to
reach their full potential and that
without the low tide,
you cannot have the high tide Sam
Harris.
Hopefully that's not an analogy that
applies for the maintenance of
civilization.
This smell the time man.
Maybe at the very least,
it's a wakeup call for the political
establishment.
This silly game that you've been running
have two candidates just doesn't work.
Someone can cooperate your candidacy.
Get in there,
throw the fucking monkey wrench into the
gear system and guess what?
Trump's running for president now.
He's the.
He's the head,
he's the head guy for the Republicans.
How is that even possible?
They don't know.
Amazing.
It is a way,
if nothing else,
it has a total wakeup call for the
Republicans.
I mean,
they are just,
it's June aghast.
Yeah,
it's June.
Everything's decided locked down.
So we have July,
August,
September,
October,
November.
We're that close.
But he's not someone who has been,
who is aligned with the Republican
platform in most ways.
Right.
So it's like he's been,
truth is virtually no one knows what his
policies are because he,
he keeps changing his position on things
like taxation and it's like,
if there actually is no keys,
he said he's talked to on both sides of,
of,
of core issue,
core Republican issues.
But I mean,
in many ways he's left of Hillary,
right?
He's,
you know,
he's left of Hillary in terms of being
an isolationist.
Like he's,
you know,
he,
his,
his relationship to war is,
but both extremes.
Like,
he's like,
no,
we're just gonna.
We're gonna get out of the world's
business.
Right?
We're going to be isolationists,
which is deeply anti Republican.
Um,
but I'm going to be the maniac who
you're never going to know who I'm going
to bomb next.
We're going to,
we're going to wipe out isis.
We're just straight away,
right.
Did Not,
not a man left standing.
Um,
and I'm not gonna take any shit from
anyone including China and North Korea.
And so he's that.
But we're going to pull back in a huge
way and not be in anyone's business,
right?
He said both of those things.
Um,
uh,
it's,
it's way too interesting way it may.
We don't want politics to be this
interesting and it's going to be
November is going to be if the polls are
closed and watching those debates and,
and,
uh,
waiting for swinging the polls as a
result,
it's just going to be,
it's to be way too interesting.
That's gonna be like watching the
superbowl,
those first debates,
you know,
it's going to be 100 million people
watching those debates.
I have a prediction.
I think,
uh,
I think it's entirely possible.
This whole thing was a plot that didn't
work out.
I think he probably came out of the gate
saying crazy shit,
thinking he would tank the Republican
Party and get his friend Hillary Clinton
into the White House that she didn't
attend to work out.
He kept trying to insult her,
kept trying to make stuff up about
Mexicans and it just kept making them
get better and better and now he's
stuck.
He can't pull out that.
That would be.
That would be a great moment.
That would change the system.
Well,
we're going to have to go through
something like this in order for us to
realize that this is crazy,
that a guy can just do this,
can just not really have any interest in
politics until that.
And then he should get the Nobel prize
for everything.
If he pulls out at this point and says,
listen,
I'm just,
I took you to the precipice here just
because I wanted you to recognize how
unstable this situation is.
I mean,
you,
you guys could elect a demagogue who is
actually an incoherent demagogue.
I'm not,
I haven't even been playing an
incoherent authoritarian.
Right?
I'm,
uh,
on one hand,
a very liberal right and tolerant and on
the other hand I'm like getting ready to
be Hitler and you guys can't figure out
who I am and yet you're still prepared
to vote for me.
Um,
I mean,
yeah,
for him to do a postmortem on,
on his Punkin of,
of the culture,
that would be the best thing to ever
happen.
But,
uh,
I don't think that's what's happening.
We need someone like this so that we
realize how silly this whole thing is.
Do we need some,
we need a qualified person to deal with
all of the other hassles and dangers
that are coming our way,
that have nothing to do with,
with what we do.
But that person's not there.
Even even if we were doing everything
perfectly,
they would still be this tsunami of risk
and hassle and waste and all the rest of
the world's chaos that is coming our
way.
And it just forget,
even if we had our,
our house in order,
in every respect,
we still have terrorism and the global
climate change will,
you know,
you've got,
you've got China and India and what are
they doing in terms of a compliant with,
with,
um,
climate goals?
Uh,
you have all the things we've been
talking about,
the virtual certainty that there's going
to be a pandemic at the,
what I'm talking about,
bioterrorism,
we're talking about just the sheer fact
that in 1919 there was a killer flu and
there's going to be another killer flew,
right?
There's just no way.
There's not gonna be another killer flu.
Um,
and we need,
we need people and we need people,
people to smart people to change the,
to optimize the system,
to deal with these kinds of things.
And if we're promoting religious maniacs
and,
and crazy narcissists and liars and
ignoramuses and only those people,
how could this end will.
No,
this is just a weird year for
heavyweight boxing.
You know,
they have those weird years for Tony
happened to be where you could be the
heavyweight champion of the world.
They went through a period of time in
like the early eighties for Tyson came
around was a series of like these champs
that were like,
you know,
sort of like journeymen fighters and
then Tyson came along.
Maybe that's what it is,
but only only with heavyweights,
right?
Yeah.
Mostly with heavyweights.
The lighter weights,
they were always bad ass,
but I think that maybe that's what's
going on.
Maybe we need to have this bad season,
get the season out of our way,
realize the danger of having an inept
person in office,
whether it's a liar or a to hates money
or,
or trump or whoever it is.
Just go through it and realize how silly
it is that we have it set up this way
still.
Yeah.
Except people thought that of Hitler.
I mean,
this is any comparison to Hitler
obviously brands you as a,
um,
an exaggerator but
they thought let them get in there and
fuck it up and then we'll have somebody
better.
Hitler was a,
a
comic figure for awhile,
for a good long while.
And people were including the American
press were incredibly slow to recognize
what a sinister character he was.
And he was,
he was considered a buffoon and a.
and there was,
you know,
there was like a,
Oh,
this is,
maybe Jamie can find this.
I think it was home and garden.
I think it was homeland,
it house in home and garden,
you know,
there was a,
a,
like a write up on his,
you know,
Eagle's nest or his house that was just,
just this pure puff piece of,
of,
you know,
Hitler love in our architectural
magazine.
I'm at home with the fuel.
I think this is it.
This is a,
was like a guardian right up under
something.
Homes and gardens.
Yeah.
So that people can see the,
um,
the actual pages.
I think they're pdfs online of the
actual pages of the article.
But this is probably a,
the actual text of the article.
But it's hilarious.
It's just,
you know,
like architectural digest does,
the Eagle's nest and.
But it's at a time where it's not too
far away from a moment where it should
have been absolutely obvious to every
thinking person that this guy was going
to try to conquer the world for evil.
Right?
And yet it was not obvious.
And,
and when you look at how it was not
obvious,
it's pretty humble.
I mean,
you,
you don't know,
you would have been necessarily
different because up until this
conversation practically,
I've been looking at trump as a clown.
Right?
But how,
how,
what,
what would this clown actually do with
the power of the presidency?
I,
you know,
I don't know that he couldn't be.
I mean,
he's,
he's given voice to a kind of
authoritarianism that,
you know,
some people are,
his enemies are noticing,
his friends are discounting,
but he's talked about,
you know,
going after the press.
And I mean,
he's bragged about how many people,
he's gonna Torture,
right?
He's talked about,
you know,
well of course we're gonna would do
waterboarding and we're going to do
worse and what maybe will kill the kill
the families of terrorists.
Right?
And he told he he,
but there's a kind of a um,
I mean it's just,
he's going to make America great again.
He,
what would he do if he actually had more
power than anyone in the world?
I think it's,
it's,
it's a legit question.
The transition from comedy to a,
Oh my God,
we can't take this back,
you know,
in anything like a short order,
that would be,
that could well be terrifying.
What do go back to the question of
heavyweights?
Why do you think you could be a fake
heavyweight and not a fake
middleware?
There's not that many really good
athletes.
They go to boxing when they really
large.
They tend to go to football or
interesting or basketball after really
tall.
It's like,
um,
if you look at the amount of money that
like guys in the NBA can make or guys in
the NFL can make.
I mean,
they're really top level guys can make a
tremendous amount of money.
So when you get to really super athlete
guys,
um,
they tend to gravitate towards the big
name.
I mean,
there's no bigger name sport than
football.
So getting someone to abandoned the
whole team thing and having the balls to
go one on one in a cage and having that
mentality that's also very different
because it's not necessarily the
smartest thing to do,
but it's the most challenging thing to
do and there's some really smart people
that do it.
So even though cage fighting isn't,
it's not the safest way to get through
life for a lot of people that engage in
it and it becomes like an extreme,
extremely difficult pursuit and then
that's what it becomes to them,
you know?
And in the heavyweight division,
those guys were being lured into other
ways and boxing was just kind of went in
through like a hit,
a peak and a valley when Ali.
And then it went.
Larry Holmes,
Larry Holmes was amazing.
People didn't appreciate him for how
good he was.
So that doesn't have the middleweight
level.
That was not the same competition for
that kind of athlete.
It will for a little dinky little lulls
in the middleweight division,
but it's always pretty fucking strong.
But I mean,
why?
Why wouldn't you have the same
competition for the high level athlete
at one 65 weight?
I mean there's just not our favorite
sports or require bigger people.
Yeah.
Bowling,
basketball and football and baseball
doesn't really apply here.
The amount of cultures that produce
heavyweights,
first of all are fairly limited.
Like very few heavyweights have come
from Asia except a polynesian guys,
which I guess is kind of Asian.
But like uh,
like Samoans,
samoans known to be great for.
But giant,
sturdy heavyweights.
Like the Chinese don't really produce
them that often,
so they don't.
The people don't get that big in Japan.
Sumo,
but yeah,
but they're very fat.
There's never been like a guy who looks
like Mike Tyson that came out of Japan
and the eighties,
you know what I mean?
We're seeing more of that now.
But I mean if we had a guy that was like
a Japanese version of Mike Tyson just to
super fast,
blinding knockout fighter with a fucking
head,
like a brick wall and the giant neck
that started above his ears and went
down to his traps.
You remember Tyson when he first came on
the scene,
he was unbelievably terrifying,
so there was never been a Japanese
person that has that kind of physical
strength,
so I think it's limited genetically and
I think in a lot of the competitive
boxing countries that tend to be poor
countries and I think also in a lot of
poor countries you'll see much smaller
men like you'll see like some some
manner like flyweights,
like it's very rare you find an American
flyweight.
Most Americans are larger.
They get more food.
I think it probably has a lot to do with
it or just just the genetics in general.
But like South America produces a lot of
flyweights like the Philippines.
Of course we're manny Pacquiao came from
him.
He was like eight weight classes lower
when he first started and if you're a
great athlete at at 120 pounds or 130
minutes.
Not a lot of sports.
Yeah.
What else can you do?
Especially if you read.
Some of these guys are really tiny,
but they're amazing boxers,
like,
um,
I mean there's a ton of them,
but the United States,
Johnny Tapio was a smaller guy.
I think what it would wait to Johnny
Tappia fight out.
So you find that there was some
lightweight guys that were just so
incredible.
They brought so much attention to those
divisions,
but there was never.
This is my little peaks and valleys
where greatness comes in and people have
to recover and the new people come along
with are great,
but there's always been pretty steady.
What did he fight at?
Super Flyway?
Yeah.
So he was one of the rare Americans,
Mexican American Johnny Tap.
He was a bad motherfucker super fly
away.
Which is,
what is that like one slash 26 or
something?
Maybe 1:30.
I don't even know what that [inaudible]
Bantam weight.
I think it's in the UFC.
It's different.
There's different weight classes.
One hundred,
15 pounds.
Wow.
Crazy.
That was tiny.
Yeah.
And he was a wild,
wild guy.
They did a documentary about him.
How did he do?
He died.
Yeah,
he died.
I don't remember,
but he had a lot of problems with drugs
and crime and craziness and he had like
Mi Vida loca tattooed on his chest.
I might get you to the presidency now.
He was a wild man,
but just an amazing fighter to watch.
So much fun.
But I think,
you know,
put in where the bigger people are,
I just think they tend to gravitate
towards other sports and I think that's
all it is.
And boxing like always like one 60,
1:47
and one [inaudible] always been like the
promised land.
That's sugar ray Leonard and Marvin
Hagler.
Roberto Duran.
I'm a floyd mayweather's in there.
Sure.
Shane Mosley's in there.
So many guys are in that mix.
That's the sweet spot.
That's always has been this great
fighters in pretty much every class.
Strength and speed that.
Yeah.
I think you see in the UFC to.
There's um,
well I think,
well when it comes to just freak
movements,
I always think that the flyweights in
the Bantam weight,
it's 25 and 35,
so the fastest and the best coding like
20 percent faster than.
Yeah.
But I always wonder like,
how much of that is because they're just
not affected by gravity as much because
that was effected by the,
the blows that are being landed by the
other guy.
It's like,
it's.
Unless it's mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse is the one of the few guys
in that division that consistently stops
people.
Did you see his last fight with Henry
Cejudo?
No,
it was,
it was incredible.
It was insane.
I mean,
he,
um,
he fought this Guy Henry,
so who does an Olympic gold medalist,
one of the best wrestlers to ever
compete in MMA.
I mean,
he is just a stud wrestler and a really
good kickboxer too.
And mighty mouse clenched up with them
and hit them with these knees to the
body that we're just out of this world
technical.
Just so perfect.
No wind up,
no slop.
Just drilled them in on each side with
perfect precision and he just crumbled.
He was like,
what the fuck?
He got the victory on knees to the body,
just need the shit out of his body and
eat them in the face.
But it was the fluidity of the way.
Who is moving his knees in the perfect
position?
I mean,
it was,
there were so perfectly oiled,
like everything was going down a path
that it had gotten a million times,
which just like a tight clench or.
Oh yeah,
but it was,
it was better than I've ever seen.
I mean,
it was without a doubt the most.
One of the most.
Well there's two,
there's another one in between Anderson
Silva and rich Franklin,
but that was like a prolong brutal beat
down where Anderson just keep beating
him up,
beating him up in the clench and broke
his nose.
Is that.
There's one where uh,
yeah,
I,
I saw,
I remember victor was at Wildman or,
or was it silver?
I can't remember if someone just won on
a knee to the chest against someone who
was.
Can you,
can you need someone who's,
who's down?
It was jail son and.
Yeah.
Anderson Silva.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was pretty brutal.
What,
what mighty mouse did in this fight.
That was crazy.
It was the precision of the placement of
the knees and how quick they came.
Just Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
Just controlled him and he's
controlling.
Your guy was an Olympic gold medalist
wrestler,
just a stud wrestler.
It was really pretty impressive stuff.
Like really,
really amazing sharp technique.
But I wonder what could a heavyweight
even move like that?
Yeah,
probably not.
No,
I mean,
as you get bigger,
there are just things you can't do.
It clearly is.
There's a limit to the size you can be
and be not only athletic,
but even ambulatory.
I mean,
you can't,
you couldn't have a 30 foot tall person
who could walk around and,
you know,
your bones would break and,
you
know,
because because mass goes up,
but with a cube of,
um,
just the side.
So it's why it's why if you,
um,
a part of ammunition that kind of a
different point.
But like if you,
if you could drop an ant off the empire
state building and it'll,
it's,
it'll fall and hit the ground and be
fine.
If you dropped a horse off the empire
state building,
it's going to,
you know,
be illiquid horse.
Um,
it's a,
uh,
I mean they are,
you have,
you know,
kind of the air resistance with surface
area,
uh,
the,
the air resistance goes up with,
by,
by the square,
the surface area,
so,
but that doesn't counteract for the mass
going up with a cube,
the volume.
So,
so the horse is bigger,
you'd think it might be able to kind of
act like a wing more as much as the
atwood.
He has got a lot of air resistance is
giant.
It's always a horse,
but it's,
um,
it's,
it's mass is going up with,
with a cube of.
It's with the cube of its size.
So it's um,
uh,
the air doesn't resist this fall at all
compared to them what it's doing for an
end.
Um,
but yeah,
we haven't the limit on this.
This is one function,
like if you,
if you're going to engineer the super
athlete and if we're going to give you
like a chimpanzee muscle proteins or
whatever to make you super explosive and
strong,
um,
you'd have to get that right with your,
you know,
your connective tissue and your bones
and everything else because you could
rip your own arm off with your holistic
moves.
Imagine if you had chimps strength and
human tendencies like good luck once you
take your own arm off and beat the
person with it.
Well use.
I'm sure you saw that video of the
little boy who got into the gorilla
cage.
Yeah.
Shoot the gorilla.
That seemed.
I heard a lot of.
I didn't pay a lot of attention to the
commentary,
but it seemed pretty straightforward to
me.
I mean,
they have to shoot the gorilla.
Yeah.
Like I'm with the zoo on that one.
I missed.
Totally tragic and it's how is the zoo?
The zoo was certainly culpable for
having an enclosure that a three year
old or four year old can get into.
Right?
I.
How the hell did that happen?
But.
So you've got to fix that and um,
but it's totally tragic,
but once you have a 400 pound gorilla
that has a human child and is not
letting it go and just kind of dragging
it around,
I mean,
it wasn't looking at aggressive toward
the child,
but it just,
the fact that it moved it around,
would that kind of force who then,
who knows what was going to happen?
I mean,
it looked like you had to end that as
quickly as possible.
We have to assume that that girl is
going to know that a baby's more fragile
than a baby gorilla.
We'd have to assume.
I don't assume anything.
You can't say no,
no.
There's no way I could know.
I never experienced that have just
ripped or torn his head off easily.
Accidentally.
Oh yeah.
Easily.
No.
Was totally tragic.
And I'm sure the,
the,
uh,
the parents and this and the zoo are
reaping sufficient criticism.
But um,
once that situation is unfolding,
I think,
I mean,
you can't tranquilizer because it
doesn't work fast enough.
So I might grab a,
a fear and it's being attacked.
Jesus Christ.
That's scary though,
but if it was your kid,
I think he'd probably shoot that fucking
gorilla if it was your kid.
Yeah.
It's um.
I mean if more people were carrying guns
you where it was in Cincinnati,
right.
If that had been in Texas a property
with some innocent bystander who was
going to take the law into his own hands
and Chuck Norris plants.
I'm prayed over the open fire.
Yeah.
It's,
I saw some horrible comments to where
people like they should just shot the
parents while they were at it.
I'm like,
well,
it's easy to be outraged.
Somebody fucked out.
It's a little kid.
Shouldn't have been able to get in.
First of all this you gotta see gorilla
and closure.
It is an architectural failing.
They should,
it should be impossible.
It's not like,
it's not just like a year old could do
it.
How could a three year old,
like it should be impossible for an
adult to get in there with it,
with a gorilla would have been.
It's been happening with like pretty
regularly lately.
Like guys had been breaking into zoos
and it's like some guy tried to kill the
lions recently,
right?
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
you gotta realize you gotta a lot of
responsibility when you have monsters in
occasion,
your city,
you can't let babies get in there with
them.
I mean,
that's a gorilla as awesome as it is,
but if it wanted to attack you,
it's a monstrous beast.
It's a thing with power that you
couldn't even fathom.
A gorilla could literally pick you up
and throw you.
Like you could have football.
I mean,
they can launch you there is so strong.
Oh yeah,
don't do it.
Didn't we?
Google it.
They get to be like 500 pounds or
something crazy.
Yeah.
Well this was like 400 pounds,
but not,
but not.
Not Four hundred pounds,
like a Boston sap.
Four hundred pounds when he was 300
pounds,
but it's like a 300 pound gorilla is
much stronger than Bob Sapp.
Yeah.
They're not equivalent pounds.
It's unfathomable.
The amount of physical strength and must
just sucks that they keep them in zoos
in the first place.
It sucks that they had to kill him,
but it really sucks that they keep doing
the zoo thing with smart stuff,
like if you want to have giraffes in the
zoo.
And I had a whole bit about it that they
look like real relaxed because there's
no lions around,
you know,
like they don't care,
they just give them some food.
But there's some animals that look
tortured and primates in particular,
they just look so freaked out in this
enclosure and this weird place where
people are staring at them.
They're pacing and trying to get away
from people's gazes.
It's just,
I think it's very,
very stressful to them.
I think.
Well,
it's a hard question,
uh,
of what to do given certainly these
species or are on the verge of
extinction.
Right?
So like how do you preserve them?
I mean,
you obviously you can preserve them in
all kinds of technical ways,
like,
you know,
have their DNA frozen and,
and be able to reboot them at a certain
point when we,
when we haven't,
when we figured out how to preserve
their habitat.
But the,
um,
I mean,
I,
I think that I got to think there's a
role for,
for good zoos to,
to get it because you also,
you just want to maintain the public's
connection to these animals because the
decision to destroy habitat is made by
people who don't really care about the
prospects of extinction.
Right.
It's a very good point when you present
it that way because the people that are
over there are face,
I mean the people that are over in
Africa trying to save gorillas and
chimps and I mean that is an
unbelievably difficult struggle and they
might not make it when there's a real
concern that if there was no regulation
at all and there was no one telling
anybody what to do,
but they could just go in there and wipe
them all out.
Well,
that's mean historically that's what
we've done.
Right?
So if any,
with kind of everything that we profited
from anything that you can make money
off of anything that you can.
I mean the,
the,
I don't know what the hell they use
chimps and gorillas for.
Well there's the whole trade.
Well,
no,
they,
they just,
I mean there's bushmeat they eat them,
but then there's the,
why do they call it bushmeat?
Well there's,
you go into the Bush,
you go into it's content,
just shoot everything.
Well,
it's just,
it's just your,
they're hunting species that you know,
you don't think of is food species,
but they're,
you know,
they're eating monkeys and gorillas and,
and that's why they call it bushmeat.
Well,
I mean,
bushes.
They call bushes like the jungle.
So it's um,
it's just hunting species that are,
that are,
they're not,
they're not.
Um,
the,
there's the other component of it which
is they're like,
you know,
the,
the crazy ideas that the Chinese have
about the medicinal properties of tiger
bone,
wine writer,
Rhino Horn or so let's say you have
these species that are being hunted by
poachers because there's a market for
their,
um,
their parts,
you know,
like I the ivory trade,
but the,
um,
now,
but some,
some people just eat species that are
endangered to just the deterrent.
Bushmeat is always associated with
primates for some reason.
I was always trying to figure out why.
I don't know,
is that true?
No,
probably not.
Maybe my mind was when I read about
people eating chips and how common it
was,
my friend Steve Rinella did a show in
Bolivia where they shot and they ate a
monkey and it's so weird to watch these
people.
Yanomami the Yanomami,
uh,
they live in Bolivia and they live in
very much like the way they probably
live hundreds of years ago.
They are handmade bows and arrows.
He's long spear like arrows that it's
not like a regular bone marrow that's
like a five foot long arrow restraint.
They walk around barefoot and uh,
they have some Russian shotgun and their
favorite thing to do is they have a
Russian shotgun.
The other got a Russian shotgun and
somehow they got from somebody and it
made it all the way deep into the
jungle.
But the shelves are very precious.
But their favorite thing to do is shoot
an eat monkeys.
It's like their number one favorite
thing to eat and they cooked it on the
show and it was really weird to watch.
You talk about some strange genetic
connection that you have with a very,
very human shape,
like the lips and the eyes and the face
of a,
you can recognize a certain amount of
human in that little little fella when
they are fellow female,
whatever female version of fellow would
be.
But um,
so they,
they cooked it over this fire and then
made this stew out of it.
Right?
Well,
actually to go back to our,
um,
cultured meat conversation,
one thing that's weird about that
prospect is that if,
in fact,
so if you're making,
if you're growing cells in a vat,
then there's no problem with
cannibalism,
right?
So that you could be growing human meat
and fat,
right?
That's that.
I mean there's zero ethical problem,
but it's just as,
as rote task is as a,
at least to my palate,
has fairly grotesque thing to
contemplate.
But these are just the distinction I'm
just talking about.
I mean,
you know,
there is no in principle,
human DNA,
right?
And this and that.
And at the cellular level,
the,
the difference between human muscle
protein and bovine muscle protein is not
me.
That's if this,
if this was never attached to an animal,
it's a.
we're dealing with concepts here and
it's like when you,
if you bite a fingernail and swallow it
or you are practicing auto cannibalism,
right?
I mean it's,
it's a,
at some level it is a concept is doing a
lot of work.
It's uninsurable when you're talking
about depriving another person of life.
But if you're talking about spinning up
sells in a Vat,
then then it becomes,
well,
does it really matter whether this is.
This was a person,
you know,
maybe people would decide that would be
the only ethical choice to hasten
cultured human meat.
If you can eat meat,
you have to eat human meat.
There's the end of this economy.
You can't harm any other animals.
Not only can you,
you have to eat yourself.
This is what the cattle industry could
do to just quash this.
That just spread the rumor that there
are human cells and those vats and you
go to your local center,
you get scraped and then they start
making your monthly supply of you.
Soylent Green is people
and they just have it in a vat and they
break you off a cube every week.
He'd take it back to you and you eat
yourself and that's the only meat you
were allowed to eat yourself while we
figured out a way to live in harmony
with nature.
We just have to kill everything except
us and then eat ourselves.
Tell us which part of your own body you
want to eat for the rest of your life
and we will culture themselves.
Well,
I know it was you that I was having this
conversation with once,
I believe where we were talking about
how when areas become more educated and
women become more educated,
it tends to slow the population down
like people tend to.
They tend to even worry that if these
graphs continue further on that people
in industrialized parts of the world as
you know the they get into the first
world.
If they do,
they'll more likely to have less and
less people.
Paul has less and less children.
Fertility goes down with literacy and
education with among women.
Yeah.
Um,
and there's know.
So just to kind of map that onto,
you know,
life is,
adheres is a women given all the choices
available,
know educational,
economic and an ability to plan a
pregnancy.
So here we have women who want to have
careers,
want to go to college and they,
they delay pregnancy to the point where
they have realized a lot of those um,
aspirations and so pregnancies come
later and later and later and,
and,
and families get smaller and smaller
and um,
and so,
you know,
virtually no one chooses to have 10
kids,
um,
in the face of all of this other
opportunity that were the things they
also want that life,
right?
Even if,
if they,
if they can avoid it,
if you can't avoid it,
well then you just find yourself with 10
kids.
Right?
Or if you have some religious dogma
which says,
you though it's possible to avoid.
You shouldn't avoid it because you were
put here to have as many kids as
possible,
but are you allowed to bring that up?
When you talk about the population
crisis,
are you allowed to.
I mean,
that's a,
that's a fascinating piece of
information.
Well,
what,
which population crisis are you thinking
of?
Because there,
there is a bunch of them.
They're two different ones.
They're two opposite ones,
which is China where they don't let you
have girls will just,
you.
You don't want the,
they live lesson that I think they've
relaxed that a,
I think they've relaxed the one child
policy,
but I'm not sure I remember hearing
something about that.
And the other one you would say India.
Well,
no,
I'm excited.
States know that there are the other,
there there's an overpopulation crisis
in certain countries and in and
disproportionately in the developing
world and there is under population in
the development world.
I mean they're there.
Most of western Europe is not replacing
itself.
So you're having,
um,
these senescent populations,
uh,
who have to,
they just have to import the,
they rely on immigration for,
for just that to carry on the functions
of society because they're just,
they're not at anywhere near replacement
rate is the most surprising detail that
brings us home is that there are more
adult diapers as Japan and more adult
diapers sold in Japan than baby diapers.
Now just think about that for the
implication of that for society,
right?
How do you have as a sign of how do you
have a functioning society,
you know,
barring,
perfect robots that can tend to your
needs,
um,
where you have just,
disproportionate number of people who
are no longer economically productive
relying on the Labor of the young to,
you know,
keep them alive and cure their diseases
and,
and um,
uh,
defend them from crime and all that.
But the,
the ratio is totally out of whack,
right?
So you need,
we need people like the world is a giant
Ponzi scheme on some level you keep,
you need new people to come in to
maintain it for the old people.
Barring,
you know,
apart from having some technology that
allows you to do that without people.
Um,
but I think our,
everything I've heard about population
recently,
it suggests that we are on course,
you know,
globally to peak around nine and a half
billion and then taper off.
I don't,
I don't think anyone now is forecasting
this totally unsustainable growth where
we're going to wind up with the St Louis
and I nine and a half billion people you
said billing,
um,
where we're going to hit something like
20 billion people,
right?
I don't think anyone,
even the most mouth,
Uzi and people are expressing that
concern at the moment,
which,
which was the case like 20 or 30 years
ago where they thought this is just
going to keep going and we're going to
hit the carrying capacity of the earth,
which is something like 40 billion
people.
Um,
wow.
Uh,
I don't think anyone thinks w w because
we're just.
Fertility is falling everywhere but it.
But it has fallen actually below
replacement in the developed world.
Do you think in our lifetimes in or in
our children's lifetime,
it's feasible that we figure out a way
in some way to,
I'm not endorsing like taking people's
money and giving it to other people,
but in some sort of a way to eliminate
poverty.
Is that even possible?
Is it ever going to be possible to
completely eliminate poverty worldwide
and within like a lifetime?
Well,
I think we talked about this the last
time when we spoke about ai,
but I mean this is the implication of
much of what we talked about here.
If you,
if you imagine building the perfect
labor saving technology,
right?
What do you imagine?
Just having a machine that can build any
machine that can do any human labor,
you power by sunlight more or less for
the cost of raw materials.
Right?
So you're,
you're talking about the ultimate wealth
generation device and now we're not just
talking about blue collar labor,
we're talking about the kind of labor
you and I do,
right?
So like the artistic labor and
scientific labor and um,
you know,
just a machine that comes up with good
ideas.
Right?
And here's what we're talking about,
general artificial intelligence,
um,
this,
if in the right political and economic
system,
this would just cancel any need for
people to have to work to survive,
right?
It just would be,
there'd be enough of everything to go
around.
And then the question would be,
do we have the right political and
economic system where we,
where we actually could spread that
wealth or would we just,
we just find ourselves in some kind of
horrendous arms race and,
and,
uh,
situation of,
of wealth inequality,
unlike any we've ever seen.
Um,
it's a,
um,
we don't,
we don't have the,
it's not in place now.
And if someone just handed us this
device,
you know,
if,
um,
and it were,
you know,
all of my concerns about ai or gone,
I mean,
there's no question about this thing I'm
doing things we didn't want it would do
exactly what we want when we want it.
And there's no,
there's just no danger of it.
That's interest becoming misaligned with
our own.
It's just like a perfect oracle and a
perfect designer of new technology.
Um,
if it was handed to us now,
I would expect just complete chaos,
right?
I would explain if,
if,
if facebook built this thing tomorrow
and announced it or rumor spread that
they had built it,
right?
What are the implications for Russia and
China?
Well,
in so far as they are as adversarial as
they are now,
it would be rational for them to just
nuke California,
right?
Because it,
because the happiness device is,
there's a winner take all scenario.
I mean,
you,
when the world,
if you have this device,
you can turn the lights off in China,
you know,
the moment you have this device,
you can just imagine it's just the
ultimate because literally we're talking
about and you know,
many people are may doubt whether such a
thing as possible.
But again,
we're just talking about the
implications of intelligence that can
make refinements to itself in over time
course.
That is,
it bears no relationship to what we
experienced as apes.
Right?
So you're talking about a system that
can make changes to his own source code,
um,
and become better and better at learning
and more and more knowledgeable.
Has Instantaneous,
if we give it access to the Internet,
it has instantaneous to all human and
machine knowledge and uh,
it does,
you know,
thousands of years of work every,
every day of our lives,
right?
They thousands of years of equivalent
human level intellectual work.
It's just a,
it's on our intuitions completely falter
to,
to capture just how immensely powerful
such a thing would be.
And there's no reason to think this
isn't possible.
I mean,
the,
the most skeptical thing you can
honestly say about this is that this
isn't coming soon,
right?
It's like,
this is not to say that this is not
possible.
Makes no scientific sense at this point.
There's no reason to think that a
sufficiently advanced digital computer
can't,
can't instantiate general intelligence
of the sort that we have.
There's no reason to think that.
I mean,
the intelligence has to be at bottom
some form of information processing and
if we get the algorithm right with
enough hardware resources and the,
and the limit is definitely not the
hardware at this point.
It's,
it's the,
the algorithms.
Um,
there's just no reason to think this
can't take off and,
and scale and that we would be in the
presence of something that is,
that is,
uh,
like having an,
an alternate human civilization in a box
that is making thousands of years of
progress every day.
Right?
So just imagine that if you had in a
box,
you know,
the 10 smartest people who've ever lived
and you know,
every time,
every week they make 20,000
years of progress,
right?
Because,
because that is the actual,
the,
you were talking about electronic
circuits being a million times faster
than,
than biological circuits.
So even if it was just,
and I believe I said this the last time
we talked about ai,
but this is,
you know,
this is what brings it home for me,
even if it's just a matter of faster,
right?
It's not,
it's not anything especially spooky.
Just this can do human level,
intellectual work,
but just a million times faster.
And again,
this totally under sells the prospects
of superintelligence.
I think human level intellectual work
is,
um,
uh,
it's gonna seem pretty paltry in the
end,
but if you just imagined just speeding
it up.
If you imagine if we were doing this
podcast,
imagine how smart I would seem if
between every sentence.
I actually had a year to figure out what
I was going to say next.
Right?
And so I say this one sentence and you
say,
you asked me a question and then in my
world I just have a year.
I'm going to go spend the next year
getting,
getting ready for,
for Joe,
and it's going to be perfect.
And this is just compounding upon
itself.
Like not only can I not,
not only,
uh,
I,
um,
am I working faster?
Ultimately I can change my,
my ability to work faster.
I mean,
we're talking about software that can
change itself.
You're talking about something that,
that becomes self improving.
So there's a compounding and function
there.
But,
um,
it's the point is,
is unimaginable,
uh,
in terms of how,
how much change this could affect.
And if you imagine the best case
scenario where this is under our
control,
right,
where there's no alignment problem,
where it's just,
it doesn't,
this thing doesn't do anything that
surprises us,
this thing will always take direction
from us.
It will never,
it will never develop interests of its
own.
Right?
Which is again,
the fear.
But let's,
let's just say this is totally obedient.
It's just an oracle and a genie route
in,
in one.
And um,
you know,
we say,
cure Alzheimer's and it cures
Alzheimer's,
you know,
you solve the protein folding problem
and,
and it just is.
It's just often running and to develop a
perfect nanotechnology and it does that.
This is all,
again,
going back to David Deutsch,
there's no reason to think this isn't
possible because anything that's
compatible with the laws of physics can
be done given the requisite knowledge,
right?
So you just get enough intelligence as
long as you're not violating the laws of
physics,
you can do something in that space.
Um,
so,
but the problem is this is a winner take
all scenario.
So facebook does it tomorrow,
and China and Russia find out about it.
They can't afford to wait around to see
whether the US decides to do something
not entirely selfish with this,
right?
Because they're their worst fears could
be realized if Donald Trump is
president,
was Donald Trump going to do with a
perfect ai when he has already told the
world that he hates Islam?
Right?
Um,
it's a,
um,
we would have to have a political and
economic system that allowed us to
absorb this ultimate wealth,
save it will wealth producing
technology.
Um,
and,
and again,
so this may sound like pure Saifai
craziness to people.
I don't think there is any reason to
believe that it is,
but walk way back from that edge of
craziness and just look at dumb ai,
you know,
narrow ai,
just self driving cars and automation.
And I'm an intelligent algorithms that
can do human level work,
uh,
that is already poised to change our
world massively and create massive
wealth inequality,
which we have.
We have to figure out how to spread this
wealth.
What do you do when you can automate a
50 percent of,
of human labor?
Were you paying attention to the
artificial intelligence go match?
Yeah.
I don't actually play go,
so I wasn't paying that kind of
attention to it,
but I'm aware of what happened there.
And you know,
the rules of go.
I'm not,
not so that I know.
Actually I don't,
I don't,
I don't play,
I don't know.
I don't know if I know vaguely how you,
how you,
um,
how it looks when a game is played,
but I don't supposed to be very
complicated.
The more complicated and more
possibilities than chess and that's why
it took 20 years longer for a computer
to be the best player in the world.
Um,
it's,
it is.
Um,
did you see how the computer did it too?
Well,
I didn't,
I,
I know,
I mean this is the company that did it
is deep mind which was acquired by
Google and they're at the cutting edge
of ai research and yeah.
Well,
it's,
the cartoons are unfortunately not so
far from what is possible,
but um,
the,
uh,
yeah,
I mean there's,
again,
this is not,
this is not general intelligence.
We're talking like these are not
machines that can even play tic Tac toe
right now.
There's some,
there,
there have been some moves away from
this or like deep mind has trained an
algorithm to play all of the Atari Games
like,
uh,
from 1980 or whenever and it is very
quickly became superhuman on most of
them I think.
I don't think it's superhuman human,
all of them yet.
But it could play in a space invaders
and all these and break out all these
games that are,
are,
um,
uh,
to highly unlike one another and it's
the same algorithm becoming expert and
superhuman in all of them.
And that's,
that's a new paradigm and it's using a
technique called deep learning for that.
Um,
and that's,
and that's been very exciting and I will
be incredibly useful.
You know,
this is in the other,
the flip side of all this.
I know that everything I tend to say on
this sound scary,
but this is all like,
I mean,
the next scariest thing is not to do any
of this stuff.
It's like we,
we want intelligence,
we want automation,
we want to figure out how to solve
problems that we can't get solved.
So like intelligence is the best thing
we've got.
So we want more of it.
Uh,
but we have to have a system where,
I mean,
it's scary that we have a system where
if you gave the best possible version of
it to one research lab or to one
government,
it's not obvious that that wouldn't
destroy humanity,
right.
That wouldn't lead to massive
dislocations where you'd have,
you know,
some trillionaire who's trumpeting his
new device and,
and just,
you know,
50 percent unemployment in the US,
in a month.
Right.
I mean like he,
like,
it's not obvious how we would absorb
this level of,
of progress.
Um,
and we,
we,
we definitely have to,
to figure out how to do it.
And now of course we can't assume the
best case scenario.
Right?
That's the best case scenario.
I think there's a few people that put it
the way you put it,
that terrify the shit out of people and
everyone else seems to have this rosy
vision of increased longevity and
automated everything and everything
and easy to get to work and medical
procedures would be easier.
They're going to know how to do it,
but everybody looks at it like we are
always going to be here,
but are we obsolete?
I mean,
is this idea of a living thing that's
creative and wrapped up in emotions and
lust and desires and jealousy and all
the pettiness that we celebrated all the
time.
We still see it.
It's not getting any better.
Right?
If,
if we obsolete,
I mean,
what if this thing comes along and says,
listen,
there's a way to do.
You're going to abandon all that stupid
shit.
He can abandon all that makes you all
the stuff that makes you fun to be
around.
Yeah,
and also fucks with.
You can live three times as long without
that stuff.
Oh,
I think it.
It would in the best case,
would usher in a,
a.
The possibility of,
of kind of fundamentally creative life
where on the order of something like the
Matrix,
whether it's in the matrix or it's just
in the world that has been made as
beautiful as,
as possible.
Um,
based on
what would functionally be an unlimited
resource of intelligence.
Let me just say,
it's just like for there to be a,
a,
an ability to solve problems of a sort
that we can't currently imagine.
I mean,
it's just,
it really is like a place on the map
that you can't,
you can't,
you can indicate it's over there.
You know,
it's like the blank spot on the map.
Ms Dot why it's called the singularity,
right?
It's like,
this is it.
This is a,
uh,
it was,
it was John von Neumann,
the.
I'm the inventor of Game Theory who a
mathematician who,
um,
want along with Alan Turing and a couple
of other peoples who's really
responsible for the computer revolution.
He was the first person to use this term
singularity to describe just this,
that,
that there's a speeding up of,
um,
information processing technology and a
cultural reliance upon it,
uh,
beyond which we can't actually foresee
the level of change that can come over
our society.
It's like,
you know,
an event horizon past which we can't
see.
Um,
and uh,
this certainly becomes true when you
talk about these intelligent systems
being able to make changes to
themselves.
And again,
we're talking mostly software.
It's not,
I'm not imagining,
I mean the most important breakthroughs
are almost certainly at the level of
have better software.
I mean,
is we have,
in terms of the computing power that the
physical hardware on earth,
it's not,
that's not what's limiting our ai at the
moment.
It's not like we need more more,
um,
hardware,
but we will get more hardware to up to
the limits of physics and it gets
smaller and smaller as it has a.
and,
you know,
if quantum computing becomes possible or
practical,
um,
that will,
uh,
and actually David Deutsch is,
is,
um,
the physicist I mentioned is one of the
fathers of the concept of quantum
computing that will open up a whole
nother area,
a extreme of computing power.
That is,
I'm not at all analogous to the kinds
of,
of uh,
machines we have now.
But,
um,
it's just,
when you imagine people don't,
people seem to always want to have it.
I just had this conversation with,
with Neil degrasse Tyson on my podcast.
He named Robert.
It was just keeping people.
I'm just,
I'm just attributing these ideas to
handle a.
he's not a,
he doesn't take this line at all.
He's not at all.
He thinks it's all bullshit,
right?
He's not at all worried about Ai.
What does he think he thinks that,
you know,
we just,
we just use.
He's drawing an analogy from how we,
you currently use computers,
that they just,
they just keep helping us do what we
want to do.
Like we decide what we want to do with
computers and we just add them to our
process.
And that process becomes automated and
then we'll find new job somewhere else,
like you didn't need a stenographer once
you have voice recognition technology.
And I'm a.
that's not a problem,
a stenographer,
I'll find something else to do.
And so the economic dislocation isn't
that bad and computers will just get
better than they are.
And you know,
eventually Siri will actually work,
you know,
and you'll,
she'll answer your questions well and
you're not,
it's not going to be a laugh line what
series said to you today.
And um,
then all of this,
we'll just proceed to make life better
right now.
None of that is imagining what it will
be like to make because it will be a
certain point where you'll have systems
that are,
you know,
it's like the Cha,
the best chess player on earth is now
always going to be a computer right
there.
There's no,
there's not going to be a human born
tomorrow that's going to be better than
the best computer.
I mean,
it's like,
it's already like it's.
We have super human chess players on
earth.
Now imagine having computers that are
superhuman at every,
every task that is relevant,
every intellectual task,
right?
So the best physicist is a computer.
You know,
the best medical diagnostician is a
computer.
The best.
A prover of math.
Theorems has a computer,
the best engineers,
a computer,
right?
Then there's no,
there's no reason why we're not headed
there.
I mean,
it would be the only reason I could see
we're not headed there is it something
massively dislocating happens that
prevents us from continuing to improve
our intelligent machines.
But if you just the moment admit that
intelligence is just a matter of
information processing and you admit
that we will continue to improve our
machines unless something heinous
happens because it's intelligence and
automation are the most valuable things
we have.
Um,
at a certain point,
whether you think it's in five years or
500 years,
we're going to find ourselves in the
presence of superintelligent machines.
And then at that point,
the best source of innovation for the
next generation of software or hardware
or both will be the machines themselves.
Right?
So then you.
So then you just have,
then that's where you get what,
what was,
what the mathematician Ij good described
as,
as the intelligence explosion,
which is just that the process can take
off on its own.
And this is where,
you know,
the singularity people,
um,
either either are hopeful or worried,
but because there's nothing,
there's no guarantee that this process
will be remain aligned with our
interests.
And,
and every person who I meet even,
you know,
very smart people like Neil,
um,
who says they're not worried about this,
when you actually drill down on why
they're not worried,
you find that they're actually not
imagining machines making changes to
their own source code.
Um,
and they're not [inaudible] they're,
they,
they simply believe that this is so far
away that we don't have to worry about
it now.
Right?
And that's actually a nonsequitor I
mean,
to say that this is far away,
is not actually grappling with.
It's not an argument that this isn't
going to happen.
And um,
and it's based on what to,
and it's,
and it's based on,
first of all,
there's no,
there's no reason to believe.
Jamie want to find out where it is.
Um,
there's no,
I mean we don't know how long it will
take us to prepare for this,
right?
So like,
like if you were,
if you knew this was going to take 50
years for this to happen,
is 50 years enough for us to prepare
politically and economically to deal
with the ramifications of this and to do
it and to say nothing of actually
building the ai safely in a way that's
aligned with our interests.
I don't know.
I mean 50,
so 50 years is we've had the iphone for
what,
10 years?
Nine years.
It's like 50 years.
Not a lot of time right.
To,
to deal,
to deal with this.
And um,
this has no reason to think it's,
it's that far away if we keep making
progress.
I mean it's,
it's not,
it will be amazing if it were 500 years
away.
I mean that,
that seems like it's,
it's,
it's more likely from what I mean,
the sense I get from the people who are
doing this work,
it's far more likely to be 50 years than
500 years.
Like,
you know,
I'm uh,
I mean the peanut that people who think
this is a long,
long way off or they're saying,
you know,
50 to 100 years,
no one says 500 years.
No,
no.
As far as I know,
no one who is actually close to this
work and some people think it could be
in five years,
right?
I mean the people who are,
you know,
like the deep mind people who are very
close to this or are the sorts of people
who say because the people,
the people who are close to this work
are astonished by what's happened in the
last 10 years.
Like we went from a place of very little
progress to,
you know,
wow,
this is all of a sudden really,
really interesting and powerful.
And um,
and again,
progress is compounding in a way that's
counter intuitive.
People systematically overestimate how
much change can happen in a year and
underestimate how much change can happen
in 10 years.
And I,
you know,
as far as estimating how much change can
happen in 50 or 100 years,
I don't know that anyone is good at
that.
How could you be with giant leaps come
giant exponential leaps off those leaps
and it's.
It's almost impossible for us to really
predict what we're going to be looking
at 50 years from now,
but I don't.
I don't know what they're going to think
about us.
That's what's most bizarre about it as
well.
We really might be obsolete if we look
at how ridiculous we are.
Look at this political campaign,
look at what we pay attention to in the
news,
look at the things we really focus on
where are strange,
ridiculous animal,
and if we look back on some strange
dinosaur that had a weird neck,
why should that fucking thing make it?
You know,
why should we make it?
We might be here to make that thing and
that thing takes over from here with no
emotions,
no lust,
no greed,
and just purely existing electronically
and for what reason?
Well,
that that's a little scary.
There are,
there are computer scientists who,
when you talk about why they're not
worried or talk to them about why
they're not worried,
they just swallow this pill without any
qualm like we're gonna make the thing
that is far more powerful and beautiful
and important than we are.
And it doesn't matter what happens to
us.
I mean that was our role.
Our role was to build these mechanical
gods and,
and it's fine if they squash us and
I've,
yeah,
I've literally heard a,
a people say I've heard someone give a
talk.
That's what woke me up to,
oh,
to how interesting this areas.
I went to this conference in,
in San Juan about a year ago and there
were a,
you know,
like the people from deep mind where
they are and the people who were very
close to this work were there.
And I'm going to hear some of the
reasons why you shouldn't be worried
from people who were interested in
common.
The fear is so they could get on with
doing their very important work.
Um,
it was amazing because they were highly
uncompelling reasons not to be worried
was just so,
so they had a,
they had a desire to be compelled.
They're not,
they're not at all.
I will know that people,
people want to do this.
There's a deep assumption in many of
these people that we can figure it out
as we go along.
Right.
You know,
it's just like we're gonna we're just
gonna get going to get closer.
We're foot.
We're far enough away now,
even five year.
Even if it's five years,
five years,
we'll,
we'll get there.
Once we get closer,
once we get something a little scary,
then we'll pull the brakes and talk
about it.
But the problem is they are assigned.
Everyone is essentially in a race
condition by default and you have,
you know,
Google is racing against facebook and
the US is racing against China and
every,
every group is racing against every
other group.
Um,
however you want to conceive of groups.
This is a,
to be the first one to be the first one
with an incredibly powerful,
narrow ai is to be the next,
you know,
multibillion dollar company,
right?
So everyone's trying to get there and
uh,
if they suddenly get there and sort of
overshoot a little bit and now they've
got something like general intelligence
or something close to what we're relying
on every.
And they know everyone else is
attempting to do this,
right?
Um,
W we don't have a system set up where
everyone can pull the breaks together
and say,
listen,
we've got to stop racing here.
We have to share everything.
We have to share the wealth with the
share the information we have to um,
this truly has to be open source in
every conceivable way.
And um,
we have to diffuse this winner take all
dynamic.
Um,
you know,
I think we need something like a
Manhattan project to figure out how to
do that,
you know,
not,
not to figure out how to build the AI,
but to figure out how to,
to build it in a way that does not
create an arms race that does not create
an incentive to build unsafe ai,
which is almost certainly going to be
easier than building safe ai interested
to work out all of these issues because
it's not because what I think we are,
we're going to build this by default.
We're just going to keep building more
and more intelligent machines and this
is going to be done in by everyone who
can,
can do it with each generation.
If we were even talking about
generations,
it's going to be.
It will have the tools made by the prior
that are more powerful than anyone
imagined 100 years ago and it just going
to keep going like that.
Did anybody actually make that quote
about giving birth to the mechanical
gods or.
That was just made,
but it was,
there was a scientist that actually was
thinking and saying that,
but that was,
that was the content of what he was
saying.
He's,
we're going to build the next species
that is far more important than we are
and that's a good thing.
And it,
and actually I can go there with him.
I mean,
it actually,
the only,
the only caveat here is that unless
they're not conscious,
right?
Like say if the true horror for me is
that we can build things more
intelligent than we are,
more powerful than we are a and that can
squash us and they might not.
They might be unconscious,
right?
That there might be nothing like the
universe could go dark if they squashes
right,
or,
or at least our corner of the universe
could go dark.
And yet these things will be immensely
powerful.
Um,
so if,
and this is just,
you know,
the jury's out on this,
but if there's nothing about
intelligence scaling that demands that
consciousness come along for the ride,
um,
then it's possible that,
I mean nobody thinks our machines are,
you know,
very few people would think are machines
that are intelligent or conscious.
Right?
So at what point does consciousness come
online or maybe it's possible to build
super intelligence that's unconscious,
you know,
super powerful,
does everything better than we do,
you know,
it'll recognize your emotion better
than,
than another person can,
but then the lights aren't on that.
That's,
that's also,
I think possible,
but maybe it's not possible,
but that's,
that's the worst case scenario because
in the ethical silver lining,
in speaking outside of our self interest
now,
but just from a bird's eye view,
the ethical silver lining to building
these mechanical gods that are conscious
is that yes,
okay,
we've,
in fact if we have built something that
is far wiser and has far more beautiful
experiences and deeper experiences of
the universe and we could ever imagine.
And there there's something that it's
like to be that thing that's just,
you know,
it is a hesitant kind of a godlike,
a experience.
Well that would be a very good thing.
Then we will have built and we will have
built something that was,
you know,
if you stand outside of our narrow self
interest,
I can understand why the,
he would say that he was just assuming
what was scary about that particular
talk because he was assuming that
consciousness comes along for the ride
here.
And I don't know that that is a safe
assumption,
but this really terrifying thing is who,
if,
if this is constantly improving itself
and it's under the Beck and call of a
person then.
So it's either conscious conscious where
it as itself,
right?
It acts as an individual thinking unit.
Right?
Or as a thing outside of it's aware,
right?
Either it is or it isn't.
And if it isn't aware and some person
can manipulate it,
like imagine if it's getting 10,000.
How many,
how many thousands of years in a week
did you say?
If it was just improvement,
it was just a million times faster than
we are.
It's 20,000
years,
20,000
years in a week and a week in a week.
So with every week this thing constantly
gets better at even doing that.
Right?
So it's reprogramming itself.
So it's all exponential.
Presumably it just,
it just imagine again,
if you could keep it in the most
restricted case,
you could just keep it at our level,
just,
just faster,
just a million times faster.
But if it did,
all of these things,
if it kept going and kept,
every week was thousands of years,
we're going to control it.
A person that's even more insane.
Just imagine being and
dialogue with something that had,
that lived the 20,000
years of human progress in a week and
you come back,
you know,
on Monday and say,
listen,
um,
I,
that thing I told you to do last Monday,
I want to change that up and this thing
has made 20,000
years of progress.
Um,
and if it's in a condition where it has
access,
I mean,
so we're imagining this thing,
you know,
in a box,
air gapped from the Internet and it's
got nothing.
It's got no way to get out,
right?
Uh,
even that is an unstable situation,
but just imagine this emerging in some
way online,
right?
Already being out in the wild,
So let's say it's in a financial market,
right?
Um,
that's again,
this is what worries me most about this
and what is also interesting is that our
intuitions here,
I think the primary intuition that
people have is no,
no,
that's just,
that's just not possible or not at all
likely,
but if you're going to find,
you're going to think it's impossible or
even unlikely,
you have to find something wrong with
the claim.
That intelligence is just a matter of
information processing.
Um,
I don't know any scientific reason to
doubt that claim at the moment.
Um,
and a very good reasons to believe that
it's just undoubtable,
uh,
and the,
and you have to doubt that we will
continue to make progress in the design
of intelligent machines.
And,
but once you,
then it's,
then the,
all this left is just time,
right?
If,
if,
if intelligence is just information
processing and we,
we're going to continue to build better
and better information processors,
at a certain point we're going to build
something that is super human.
Um,
and so whether it's in five years or 50,
it's a huge.
I mean,
it's,
it's the biggest change in human history
I think we can imagine,
right?
Um,
so,
uh,
and,
and people I what I felt fine,
I keep finding myself in the presence of
people who seem,
at least to my eye to be refusing to
imagine it like that they're treating it
like the y two k virus or whatever where
it's just the y two k bug where it just
may or may not be an issue.
Right?
Like,
it,
like it's a hypothetical,
like maybe this is just,
we're going to get there and it's going
to be.
It's either not going to happen or it's
going to be trivial,
but how you don't,
if you don't have an argument for why
this isn't going to happen,
uh,
then you have to have then then you're
left with,
okay,
what's it going to be like to have
systems that are better than we are at
everything in the entire intellectual
space.
Um,
and
you know,
what will happen if that suddenly
happens in one country and not in
another,
right?
It's um,
it's,
uh,
I mean,
it has enormous implications,
but it just sounds like science fiction.
I don't know what's scarier.
The idea that an artificial intelligence
can emerge,
it's conscious,
it's aware of itself,
and then acts to present per,
per protect itself,
or the idea that a person,
a regular person like,
have today could be in control of
essentially a god.
Right?
Because if this thing continues to get
smarter and smarter with every week and
more and more power and more and more
potential,
more and more understanding,
thousands of years,
I mean it's just,
yeah,
this one person,
a regular person controlling that is
almost more terrifying than creating a
new line or,
or any group of people who don't have
the total welfare of humanity as their
central concern.
And so just imagine what would,
what would China do with it now?
Right?
What would we,
what would we do if we thought China,
you know,
Baidu or what are some Chinese company
was on the verge of this thing?
What would it be rational for us to do?
You know,
if North Korea had it,
it would,
it would be rational to nuke them given
what they say about their relationship
with the rest of the.
So it's um,
well that kind of rational,
that kind of power is.
It's so life changing.
It's so paradigm shifting,
right?
But if you have to wind this back to
what someone like Neil degrasse Tyson
would say,
is that the only basis for fear is,
yeah,
don't give your superintelligent ai to
the next Hitler,
right?
That's,
that's obviously bad.
But if we don't,
if we're not idiots and we just use it,
well,
we're fine.
And that I think is an intuition that is
just,
that's just a failure to,
to unpack what is entailed by,
again,
something like an intelligence
explosion,
a process that once,
once you're,
you're talking about something that is
able to change itself and you have to
get.
So what would it be like to guarantee
level?
So we decide,
okay,
we're just not going to build anything
that can make changes to his own source
code.
You know,
any change to,
to,
to software to certain point is going to
have to be run through a human brain.
Um,
and we're going to have veto power.
Well,
is every person working on ai going to
abide by that rule?
It's like what we agreed not to clone
humans,
right?
But we're going to stand by that
agreement for in the rest of human
history and is,
you know,
is our agreement binding on China or
Singapore or any other country that
might think otherwise,
it's just,
it's a free for all and at a certain
point we're going to be,
you know,
close enough,
everyone's going to be close enough to
making the final breakthrough that,
um,
unless we have some agreement about how
to proceed if someone is going to get
there first,
that is a terrifying scenario of the
future.
You know,
you cemented this last time you were
here,
but not as extreme as this time.
You seem to be accelerating the
rhetoric.
Exactly,
yes.
You're going deep.
Boy,
hope you're wrong.
I'm on team Neil degrasse Tyson.
This one go neil,
um,
and well and so in defensive of the
other side too.
I should say that.
So David Deutsch also thinks I'm wrong,
but he thinks I'm wrong because we will
integrate ourselves with these machines.
I mean,
so this will be,
there'll be extensions of ourselves and
they can't help but be aligned with us
because we will,
we will be connected to them.
That seems to be the only way we could
all get along.
We have to merge,
become one,
but I just think there's no,
there's no deep reason why,
like even if we decided to do that,
right,
like in the US or,
or,
or in half the world one,
there's,
I think there are reasons to worry that
even that could go haywire,
but there's no guarantee that someone
else couldn't just build ai in a box.
I mean,
if we're,
if we can build ai such that we can
merge our brains with it.
Um,
someone can also just build ai in a box,
right?
And,
and that's,
uh,
um,
and then,
then you inherit all the other problems
that people are saying,
we don't have to worry about if it was a
good Cohen brothers movie,
it would be invented in the middle of
the presidency of Donald Trump.
And so then that's when ai would go
live.
And then ai would have to challenge
Donald Trump.
They'd would have like an insult
contest,
but that,
that that's when this thing becomes so
comically a terrifying.
Whereas just just imagine Donald Trump
being in a position to make the final
decisions on topics like this for the
country that is act is going to do this
almost certainly in the near term.
It's like,
should we have a Manhattan project on
this point,
Mr.
President,
um,
you know,
the idea that anything of value could be
happening between his ears on this
topic.
We're 100 others like it I think is now
really inconceivable.
And so what,
uh,
what,
what price could we,
might we pay for that kind of
inattention and,
and self satisfied in attention to these
kinds of issues?
Well,
this,
this issue,
if this is real and if this could go
live in 50 years,
this is the issue you're in.
Unless we fuck ourselves up beyond
repair before then and shut the power
off if it keeps going.
Yeah.
No,
I think it is.
I think it is the issue,
but unfortunately it's the issue that
doesn't.
It sounds like a goof.
It does just sound.
You sound like a crackpot even worried
about this issue.
It sounds completely ridiculous,
but that might be what's how it's
sneaking in?
Yeah.
I mean,
it just,
it.
Just imagine that the tiny increment
that would make suddenly make it
compelling.
I mean,
just imagine,
I mean chest doesn't do it because chess
is so far from any central human
concern.
But just imagine if your,
if your phone recognized your emotional
state better than any than your best
friend or your wife or anyone in your
life and then did it reliably.
Right?
So as your body,
like that movie with Joaquin for her,
he falls in love with his phone.
Right?
I mean,
that's just not,
you know,
that is not far off that far off.
It's not,
it's a very discreet ability.
I mean,
you could do that.
You could do that without any,
any other ability.
And the phone really.
It's like,
it doesn't,
it doesn't have to to,
uh,
stand on the shoulders of any other kind
of intelligence.
It could just,
you know,
you have.
This could be,
you could do this with just brute force
in the same way that you have a great
chess player that doesn't necessarily
understand that it's playing chess.
You could have some facial recognition,
facial recognition of emotion and the
and the tone of voice,
recognition of emotion and the idea that
it's gonna.
It's gonna be a very long time for
computers.
They get better than people at that I
think is is very far fetched.
I was thinking.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I was just thinking,
how strange would it be if you had
headphones on and your phone's in your
pocket and you have rational
conversations with your phone,
like your phone knew you better than you
know you like.
I mean,
I don't know what to do.
I don't think I was out of line.
She yelled at me.
I mean,
what should I say and I would have
listened to every one of your
conversations with your friends.
Exactly.
Train up on that.
Just talk to you about it and go,
listen man,
this is what you gotta do.
Your sounding angry.
You got defensive.
He got defensive.
I apologize.
Relax.
Let's all move on.
If you could accelerate it.
Are you okay?
You right man.
Right man.
And like you're talking to this little
artificial.
Maybe that's the first version of
artificial intelligence.
Uh,
we suggest we go.
All right.
Let's give it a and like self help guys
in your phone of like a personal trainer
in your phone.
How to talk to girls and it's probably
slow down.
Slow down.
You're talking too fast,
Kinda cool.
Yeah,
that would,
I mean literally like giving you
information.
They'll be like step one.
That'd be like the Sony Walkman.
Remember when you had a Walkman,
like a cassette player that was like a
VCR.
I know when we were on our way to what
we have today where you have 30,000
songs in your phone or something.
I think I remember the first Walkman.
The first thing I just want to,
back when I skied,
there was something called,
it was called astral tunes or something.
It was like,
it was like a car radio that you could
just put in a pack on your chest.
Um,
yeah it was.
They kept coming out with those sounds
they would get smaller and smaller,
so then that little,
the little dude would start telling you,
Yo,
man,
dude,
listen to keep replace me every year.
Just let them stick me in.
Your brain will be together all the
time.
I've been given you good advice for
years,
Bro.
Let me in your brain,
and so you and this little artificial
intelligence has you have a relationship
over time.
Eventually it talks you into getting
your head drilled and screw it in there,
and your artificial intelligence has
always powered by your central nervous
system.
Have you seen most of these movies?
Like did you see her and.
No,
I didn't know.
And that was one of my top 10 all time
favorite movies.
Yeah,
I love that movie.
Actually.
I like it.
I saw it twice.
I said I,
I,
I was slow to realize how well they did
it.
I mean,
it was just the first time I saw it,
I thought I wasn't as impressed and I
watched it again and they really,
first of all the performance of,
of um,
I forgot the actress's name.
Uh,
the candor candor is that with the woman
who plays the robot in x,
Makkah is just fantastic,
but I'm scary.
Good.
Tuck you in anything.
We're getting a little full on time.
Yeah,
what do we like five hours and a half
hours in?
But I just got a note about this,
about the Philip.
Wait a minute.
How many hours for a half hour
computer's about to fill up.
We did.
We just did a four and a half hour.
We were ready to keep going to Jesus.
I,
Jamie,
didn't,
you know what man,
once you opened up that box up Pandora's
box of shit and I've looked up,
is there any sort of concept of autism
and ai,
like a spectrum of Ai,
like Oh,
there are dumb ai and there's going to
be smart Ai.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
So,
I mean the scary thing.
So yeah,
it's like super autism.
There's no,
um,
across the board there's,
I think that super intelligence and
motivation and goals are totally
separable.
So you could have a super intelligent
machine that is purposed toward a goal
that just seems completely absurd and
harmful and non common sensical.
And they said they,
the example that Nick Bostrom uses in
book superintelligence,
which was a great book,
um,
and did more to inform my thinking on
this topic than any other source.
He talks about a paperclip maximizer.
You could,
you could build a super intelligent
paperclip maximizer.
Now,
not that anyone would do this,
but the point is you could build a
machine that was,
that was smarter than we are in every
conceivable way,
but all it wants to do is produce
paperclips.
Right now that seems counterintuitive,
but there's no,
there's no reason when you dig deeply
into this,
there's no reason why you couldn't build
a superhuman paperclip maximizer just
wants to turn everything,
you know,
just like literally the atoms in your
body would be better used as paperclips.
Um,
and so this is just a,
the point he's making is that
superintelligence could be very
counterintuitive.
It's not necessarily going to inherit
everything we find,
as you know,
common sensical or,
or emotionally appropriate or wise or
desirable.
It could be totally foreign,
totally trivial in some way,
you know,
focused on something that means nothing
to us but means everything to it because
of some cork and how it's motivation
system is structured and yet it can
build the perfect nanotechnology that
will allow it to build more paperclips.
Right?
So,
um,
and Lisa,
at least I don't think anyone can see
why that's ruled out in advance.
I mean,
there's no reason why we would
intentionally build that,
but the fear is we might build something
that either is not perfectly aligned
with our goals and our common sense and
our,
and our,
um,
aspirations and that it could form some
kind of separate instrumental goals to
get what he wants he wants that are
totally incompatible with life as we
know it.
And that's,
you know,
again,
the,
the examples of this are always
cartoonish.
Like,
you know how I mean,
Elon Musk said,
you know,
if you built up super intelligent
machine and he told it to reduce spam,
well then it could just kill all people
as a great way to reduce spam,
right?
Um,
but see the reason why that's law,
if it's laughable,
but you,
you can't assume the common sense won't
be there unless we've built it,
right?
Like,
you have to have anticipated all of
this.
You can't,
if you say take me to the airport as
fast as you can.
Again,
this is Bostrom,
you know,
and you have a super intelligent
automatic car.
Um,
you know,
a self driving car,
you'll just,
you'll get to the airport covered in
vomit because it'll just,
it's just going to go as fast as it can
go.
Um,
so it's a,
it's our intuitions about what it would
mean to be super intelligent necessarily
are,
are.
Um,
I mean there's no,
we have to correct for them because I
think our intuitions are bad.
You're freaking me out and you've been
freaking me out for over an hour and a
half.
Freaked out that we did four and half
hours and I thought that's ridiculous.
We're coming up on three,
man.
I hope wrong about all that stuff.
Maybe so it doesn't.
It doesn't seem that.
I don't know.
It doesn't look that Rosie.
Jamie,
I'm sorry.
To be such a buzzkill.
Look to the woods.
Might have to figure out how to live off
the land.
You're the ultimate prepper.
No,
it ain't easy,
man.
Fucking I'm bad at it.
I'll starve wellstar.
I won't be a vegetarian.
I'll come to your house for bear meat
and it might get ugly.
Folks,
let's hope Sam Harris wrong.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it.
And your podcast.
Tell people how to get us.
Waking Up is my podcast and you can find
it on my website,
Sam Harris,
dot org,
or on itunes.
You can get his book,
one of his books if you go to
audible.com,
forward slash Joe,
right?
Isn't that get one?
Go get one of those folks.
All right,
thank you ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you Sam.
That was awesome.
Thank you bro.